REYES GOOD MORNING AND WELCOME
TO THE ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE IT'S A LITTLE PAST
TEN. BEFORE WE GET STARTED
TODAY WE DO HAVE A QUORUM SO
WOULD YOU START BY CALLING THE
ROLE PLEASE. HERE. THE DALLAS.
DOLLARS. YEAH I DON'T.
OBERNOLTE FEAR. REYES HERE YEAH.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A- QUORUM
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LIMON WHO WILL
BE JOINING US TODAY IN PLACE OF
MR MAIENSCHEIN WHO'S NOT ABLE
TO BE HERE. AND I WANT TO
REMIND EVERYONE OF THE CONTINUE
TO STAY AT HOME ORDER WE ARE
PRACTICING PHYSICAL DISTANCING.
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM ANSWER
AT THE CAPITOL BUILDING. SO WE
CAN ONLY HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER
OF MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC JOIN
US HERE. IN OUR ROOM FORTY TWO
TO TODAY. WE REQUIRE THAT MASKS
BE WORN AND PHYSICAL DISTANCING
BEING MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TESTIFYING
WEATHER HERE IN THE ROOM OR AT
OUR VIDEO CONFERENCING SITE OR
OTHER SITES. IF YOU DO NOT HAVE
A MASK. JUST ASK HIM AND WE CAN
MAKE SURE THAT ONE GETS
PROVIDED TO YOU ALSO ARE
COMMITTEE WROTE RULES REQUIRE
THAT MEMBERS THE PROPERLY
ATTIRED. WEARING A MASK AT ALL
TIMES IS THAT PROPER ATTIRE.
AND NOW I WANT TO. REVIEW THE
OPTIONS FOR WITNESSES
TESTIFYING TODAY. HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO TO AGAIN WE CAN ONLY
ACCOMMODATE A MINIMAL NUMBER OF
THE STAFF IN A MINIMAL NUMBER
OF PUBLIC AND MEDIA SO THAT WE
CAN MAINTAIN APPROPRIATE SOCIAL
DISTANCING. THERE'S STRICT
PHYSICAL DISTANCING PROTOCOLS
FOR THE PUBLIC TO ENTER AND
LEAVE THE CAPITAL IN AS WELL AS
FOR THOSE IN THE ROOM ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM. WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
BILL AT THE APPROPRIATE TIMES
RAISE YOUR HAND AND I WILL CALL
ON YOU TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. WHICH IS. UP THERE
YET. BUT WE ARE ALSO ASKING THE
PUBLIC NOT TOUCH THE MICROPHONE.
YOU CAN EXIT THE HEARING ROOM
ONCE YOU'RE DONE TESTIFYING
WILL RETURN TO YOUR SEAT PLEASE
BE SURE TO OBSERVE PHYSICAL
DISTANCING UPON LEAVING THE
CAPITAL- INCLUDING LIMITING
ELEVATOR USED TO ONE PERSON AT
A TIME. WE HAVE A COUPLE OF
OTHER SITES WE HAVE A WITNESS
VIDEO CONFERENCE ROOM. AND WE
HAVE REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION
SO THOSE WHO ARE. WANT TO BE
ABLE TO TESTIFY. IN THOSE
AREAS- WE DO HAVE THOSE
LOCATIONS AND THOSE WITNESSES
IN THE REMOTE TESTING STATION
AND I BELIEVE OR IN THE WITNESS
VIDEO COMES FROM AND I BELIEVE
THAT THE REMOTE TESTING STATION
WILL APPEAR ON THE SCREEN HERE
SHOULD THERE BE ANY. AND
MEMBERS CAN WATCH THE TESTIMONY
AND ALSO ASK THEM QUESTIONS
BECAUSE THERE'S A TWO WAY AUDIO
FEED. FOR DIALING WITNESSES.
WE'LL BE USING A MODERATED
TELEPHONE SERVICE. AND ANY
WITNESS CAN TESTIFY ON A BILL
THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR THIS
HEARING. IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN THAT NUMBER SHOULD BE
APPEARING ON YOUR SCREENS AGAIN
THE DIAL IN NUMBER 877-692-8957
THE ACCESS CODE. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR TWO TO. AGAIN THE
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR TWO OH TWO YOU CAN
ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AND AGAIN HOPEFULLY ON
YOUR SCREENS IF YOU'RE CALLING
IN PLEASE DO SO AS THE AUTHOR
OF THE BILL YOU'RE TESTIFYING
ON BEGINS THE BILL
PRESENTATION. THE OPERATOR ON
THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE PLACE
IN THE QUEUE BASED ON WHETHER
YOU'RE SUPPORTING OR OPPOSING
THE BILL IF YOU'RE CALLING IN
PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE AND THIS INCLUDES MUTING
YOUR LIVE STREAM FOR YOUR SMART
DEVICES TO READ DEUCE THE SOUND
DISTORTION. IT'S ALSO BE
ADVISED THAT IF YOU'RE A AIN
WITNESS PROVIDING TESTIMONY FOR
OR AGAINST THE BILL. YOU WILL
REMAIN ON THE LIVE LINE AND
WILL NEED TO MEET YOURSELF
UNTIL YOU'RE CALLED ON TO
SPEAK. AND ALSO YOU MAY BE
CALLED ON TO ANSWER QUESTIONS.
FROM THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE IF YOU'RE HAVING ANY
PROBLEMS WITH A MODERATE A
PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE. HAD NINE ONE SIX.
THREE ONE NINE. TWO THREE THREE
FOUR. AGAIN THAT'S NINE ONE SIX
THREE ONE INE. TWO THREE THREE
FOUR MY STAFF WILL TRY TO HELP
YOU. YOU CAN ALSO ALWAYS SUBMIT
WRITTEN TESTIMONY. THROUGH THE
POSITION. LETTER PORTAL ON OUR
COMMITTEES WEBSITE. THANK YOU
FOR BEARING WITH US AS WE TRY
AND IMPLEMENT METHODS TO
CONTINUE TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. BUT ALSO KEEP
EVERYBODY SAFE. SO WE'RE NOT
GOING TO START THROUGH OUR
AGENDA AND WE'LL START WITH
ITEM NUMBER ONE ON THE AGENDA
WHICH IS SENATE BILL. ELEVEN
FIFTY SEVEN SENATOR BRADFORD IS
HERE. SO OPERATOR YOU CAN OPEN
THE LINES FOR SENATE BILL
ELEVEN FIFTY SEVEN. IN FIND ARE
OPEN RIGHT THANK YOU ANY OF
THOSE ON THE PHONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY ON SB ELEVEN
FIFTY SEVEN EITHER FOR OR
AGAINST. SHOULD BE. DIALING IN.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO HAVE THE
PARTICIPANTS TESTIFY AT THIS
TIME THE PUBLIC COMMENT NO NOT
AT THIS TIME I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT THEY ARE DIALING INTO
BEING READY WE'RE GONNA START
WITH OPENING STATEMENT OF. THE
AUTHOR. SENATOR BRADFORD. THANK
YOU MISTERMEMBERS. OF YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF- FOR THE HELP
THAT WE'VE- THEY PROVIDED IN
GETTING THE BILL TO WORD IS
TODAY ALSO WANT TO THANK.
CALIFORNIA REALTORS AND TO ALL
THE STAFF OF THE AMENDMENTS
THAT HAVE BEEN BROUGHT FORTH TO
REFLECT THIS PRODUCT TO THE DAY
SB ELEVEN FIFTY SEVEN WILL BE
THE FIRST BILL IN THE NATION TO.
REQUIRE LANDLORDS TO REPORT
HAHA NOT PAYMENTS FOR THOSE WHO
OWNS- SUBSIDIZED RESIDENTIAL
MULTI FAMILY PROPERTY- AND ITS
OPTION TO REPORT THAT TO A
MAJOR CREDIT BUREAU BY FOCUSING
ON SUBSIDIZED HOUSING THIS BILL
IS TAILORED TO THOSE TENANTS
LIKELY TO RECEIVE THE GREATEST
BENEFIT FROM ESTABLISHING OR
IMPROVING THEIR CREDIT SCORES.
ELEVEN FIFTY SEVEN ALSO
INCLUDES DELAYED OPERATIVE DATE
OF JULY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TO ALLOW TIME FOR LANDLORDS TO
PASS COMPLY WITH THIS MEASURE
SB ELEVEN FIFTY SEVEN IS A
SIMPLE GOAL TO PROVIDE RUNNERS
AWAY TO ESTABLISH OR PROVE
THEIR CREDIT THE PAYMENT OF
RENT- WE ALL KNOW THAT THERE
ARE SOME. TENANTS WHO LIVE IN
BUILDINGS FOR YEARS AND PAY THE
RENT ON TIME BUT NEVER A YOU
SHOULD GET THE BENEFIT OF THAT
STABLE PAYMENT YET MANY TIMES
WHEN YOU FAIL TO PAY YOUR RENT
THAT IS QUICKLY REPORTED TO THE
CREDIT BUREAU AND THAT. CAN BE
A LASTING EFFECT ON PEOPLE'S
ABILITY TO GET OUT OF DEBT AND
MOVE AHEAD AND EVEN ACHIEVE THE
AMERICAN DREAM OF HOME
OWNERSHIP THERE'S NO REASON
RUNNERS WHO READ WE PAY RENT.
SHOULD RECEIVE A POSITIVE
IMPACT OF A CREDIT SCORE BY
DOING SO- TODAY UP TO WITNESSES
WHO WILL TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
SEARCH OF THEM. ALL WITH THE
CREDIT BUILDERS ALLIANCE AND
HOW THEY CAN ON THOSE KIANA
SECTION TODAY WITH MISSION.
ASSET FUND. THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR SO WE DO HAVE TWO
PRIMARY SUPPORT WITNESSES
SEARCH EVAN AND JOSE CAN UNITS
ARE EITHER OF YOU ON THE PHONE.
I AM THERE OKAY SIR. GREAT
SERVICER THAN. GREAT THANK YOU
SO MUCH- CENTER BRADFORD MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS COMMITTEE-
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF ELEVEN FIFTY SEVEN I
AM IF YOUR CHARACTER AND THEN
WITH A CREDIT BUILDERS ALLIANCE
WE ARE A NATIONAL NONPROFIT
THAT SEEKS TO HELP
ORGANIZATIONS MOVE PEOPLE FROM
POVERTY TO PROSPERITY THROUGH
CREDIT BUILDING AND AS WE ALL
KNOW A GOOD CREDIT HISTORY IS
CRUCIAL IN TODAY'S ECONOMY AND
WILL BE EVEN MORE IMPORTANT AS
WE HOPEFULLY SOON- EMERGE FROM
THE CURRENT PANDEMIC- CREDIT
MARK. ALREADY TIGHTENING
WITHOUT A PRIME CREDIT SCORE
INDIVIDUAL TO PAY HIGHER
INTEREST THEY PAY HIGHER FEES
ON FINANCIAL PRODUCTS AND THEY
SPEND MORE ON ESSENTIAL
SERVICES LIKE CAR INSURANCE AND
CELL PHONES AND OFTEN HAVE.
UNLIMITED RENTAL HOUSING
OPTIONS. ADD TO IT IN IN AT. IT
COMP FINANCIAL AND IT MAKES IT
EVEN MORE DIFFICULT FOR LOW AND
MODERATE INCOME HOUSEHOLDS MANY
OF WHOM ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
HOUSEHOLDS OF COLOR TO GET AND
STAY AHEAD. WONDER ALRIGHT MORE
LIKELY TO HAVE LOWER INCOMES
AND LOWER WELL THEN THEY'RE
HOMEOWNER COUNTERPART AND SEVEN
TIMES MORE LIKELY TO HAVE A
MINIMAL CREDIT HISTORY THAT IS
DEEMED AND SQUABBLE.
FURTHERMORE MANY HAVE FEWER
OPTIONS TO BUILD THEIR CREDIT
HISTORY AND POSITIVE AND
NEGATIVE MORTGAGE PAYMENTS ARE
UBIQUITOUSLY REPORTED TO THE
CREDIT BUREAUS. BUT ON BALANCE
HAVE YOU HEARD THE SENATOR
SAYING ONLY DEROGATORY RENTAL
PAYMENTS ARE REPORTED- FOR
RENTERS. REPORTING IS A PROVEN
STRATEGY TO GIVE RENTERS THAT
SAME OPPORTUNITY TO BUILD
CREDIT. TO BUILD CREDIT THAT
HOMEOWNERS HAVE JUST BY MAKING
THEIR MONTHLY HUSING PAYMENT.
SEVERAL YEARS AGO MY
ORGANIZATION CBA COMPLETED A
PILOT THAT INCLUDED ONE
THOUSAND LOW INCOME RENTERS. A
100% OF THOSE. WHO ARE CREDIT
INVISIBLE AT THE OUTSET ENDED
UP WITH THE HIGH NON PRIME OF
PRIME CREDIT SCORE AND 79% OF
THOSE WITH LOWER COURT FATHER
SCORES INCREASED BY AN AVERAGE
OF TWENTY THREE POINT. AS A
RESULT 15% MOVED INTO A LOWER
RISK HERE WITH SOME EVEN GOING
ON TO PURCHASE THEIR OWN HOME.
THE FUEL BY THE FINDINGS AND
SUBSEQUENT EFFORTS EPA HAVE
SEEN TREMENDOUS INTEREST IN
RENT REPORTING BECAUSE OF ITS
HIGH IMPACT PLATE BASED SIMPLE
AND SCALABLE SOLUTION. WITHOUT
THE BEGUN TO SEE POLICY MAKERS
IN STATES LIKE NEW YORK
MASSACHUSETTS AND DC PROMOTE
WHAT REPORTING IS A VIABLE AND
POWERFUL ECONOMIC MOBILITY
STRATEGY. AND ONE THAT NARROWS
THE RACIAL WEALTH GAP IT'S PAST
HOWEVER SB ELEVEN FIFTY SEVEN
WOULD BE AT THE SENATOR SAID.
UP THE FIRST OF ITS KIND IN THE
NATION TO REALLY MOVE THE
NEEDLE ON RENT RECORDING
ALTERNATELY BENEFITING
POTENTIALLY HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIA. HOW
CALIFORNIANS- THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
TODAY WITH THAT I WILL TURN IT
OVER TO YOU JOSE PERMISSION.
ONE THANK THIS CONTINUOUS. YES
THANK YOU CHARACTER GET YOUR
AND GENERAL BROWN FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS. ISSUE MY
NAME IS AFFECTING. ON THE CEO
AT THE MEASURE AFTER FUND WHERE.
SAN FRANCISCO WE WERE FROM WITH
LOW INCOME. CAN. OPTIM PROJECTS
ARE SECURITY. THANK YOU KNOW
THAT ECONOMIC. HAS BEEN A
DEVASTATING EFFECT IF YOU WHEN
I LIVES. MILLIONS OF P. ARE TO
SEE JOBS. HAVING A VERY HARD
TIME IT MEET YOU KNOW THROUGH
NO FAULT OF THEIR OWN. OUR IN
DOUBT. IN THERE REALLY ARE SO
DOWN THERE SO AND RESOURCE JUST
GET TO SURVIVE NOW. IN A WHILE
WE DON'T KNOW HOW LONG CRISIS
IS GOING TO LAST WE DO KNOW
THAT WE NEED MORE. TO IS ELEVEN
EQUITIES. TO PROVIDE PEOPLE IF
I CHANCE TO WOULD BE IT FROM
LINES SB ELEVEN FIFTY SEVEN
WILL ALLOW PEOPLE THE OPTION TO
CLUE INCLUDE THAT RENT PAYMENTS
IN THE QUERY REPORTS. GIVING
THEM THE OPPORTUNITY TO REBUILD
THE CREDIT SCORES IT WOULDN'T
BUDGET POCKET PAYMENT
TRANSLATES INTO HIGHER SCORES
AND MORE ACCESS TO MAINSTREAM
CREDIT CAN LOWER BARRING. EACH
AND EVERY IMPACT RIGHT BURKE
COLLEAGUES SERRA MENTIONED I
ASK. FOR YOUR SUPPORT. OKAY
DESPERATELY MORE. MORE RESEARCH
LIKE S. B. ELEVEN FIFTY SEVEN.
SO THAT THAT WHAT WE CAN REACH.
OUR FINANCIAL. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU THOSE THE TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES ARE THERE IS THERE
ANYONE HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. ELEVEN FIFTY
SEVEN. RIGHT SEEING NONE IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE WITNESS
VIDEO ROOM. I WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF ELEVEN
FIFTY SEVEN. C. NINE HOW ABOUT
THE REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION. I
DO NOT HAVE ANY INDICATION THAT
THERE'S ANYONE THERE. OPERATOR
IS THE TO OPEN THE LINES FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF SB
ELEVEN FIFTY SEVEN. IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT TODAY PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY THE ZERO. AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE TWENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GREGORY KRAMER
ON BEHALF OF DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. IN ONE MOMENT WE HAVE A
COUPLE MORE QUEUING UP PLEASE.
WE'LL GO TO LINE TWENTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS
BRIAN LOOKED FRUSTRATED NOW
MILLION PEOPLE TO GET UP. IF
YOU. FINE THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS TO ONLY
TOMORROW MAJORITY ON BEHALF OF
THE POLITICIANS ARE LEADERS OF
TOMORROW GROUP FROM SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THERE'S NO
MORE PUBLIC SUPPORT AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO OPPOSITION
I HAVE ONE OPPOSITION WITNESS
LISTED WHO WILL BE WITH US ON
THE TELEPHONE MR KING SAID ARE
YOU ON THE LINE. YES I AM THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN. HI THIS IS RON
KINGSTON I REPRESENT- PRIMARILY
IN THIS CAPACITY THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING MANAGEMENT
ASSOCIATIONS. ARE COLLECTIVELY
THEY- HAVE FILE ALL DEED
RESTRICTED HOUSING FOR VERY LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS THESE ARE THE
HOUSEHOLDS THAT WOULD BE
TARGETED AND- IF WHICH REGARD
JSP ELEVEN FIFTY SEVEN
PROVISIONS ARE WE ARE FIRST OF
ALL DEEPLY APPRECIATIVE OF
WORKING WHERE ARE YOUR STAFF.
AND NOTABLY MISTER BRADFORD
STAFF- OVER THE PAST SEVERAL
MONTHS PRE CODED AND DURING
COATED I WANT TO FOCUS ON- THE
IMPACT OF THE US AND- DISCUSS
WITH YOU WHAT. RING SIZE TO OUR
REQUEST- A POTION WEST BILL AS
AMENDED- FIRST OF ALL. BYE IT
IS ALLEGED RAPE THAT CERTAIN
PEOPLE WILL HAVE THEIR CREDIT
SCORES RACED SHOULD THEY OPT IN
AND PAY TEN DOLLARS A MONTH-
THERE IS A SUBSTANTIAL QUESTION
WHETHER THAT WILL BE THE CASE
BECAUSE THERE ARE TENS OF
THOUSANDS. OF OUR LOW INCOME
RESIDENTS EARNING 50% OR LESS
INCOME- VERSUS THE AREA WIDE
MEDIA THAT WILL NEVER BENEFIT
THIS BILL WON'T BE OFFERED TO
THEM FOR THE TENANTS WON'T OPT
IN SO THEIR CREDIT SCORE AS WE
REFER TO IT. WILL HAVE A LOWER
BECAUSE EITHER ALL SHIPS RISE
FOR DOES THAT OFTEN AT THE END
EVERYBODY WHO DOESN'T OFTEN
WILL SUFFER THE RESULT AND- WE
DO NOT BELIEVE THAT THIS IS
EQUITABLE TO ALL THOSE LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS. SECOND. WE
QUESTION WHY- THIS IS. OFFERED
BY TWO- THE LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS HAVING THIS HAVING
NOTHING TO DO WITH HOUSING ARE
THEY WILL NOT BE BUYING HOUSING
WHEN YOU'RE ONLY EARNING 60% OF
THE AREA WIDE MEDIAN FOR
LAUGHS- THESE ARE HOUSEHOLDS
EARNING- TWENTY FIVE MAYBE
250-003-0000 DOLLARS. YOUR
TOTAL- THEY WILL NOT BY THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM. THIRD V. COST
ACOSTA- HAS BEEN REFERRED TO
AND BITE COMMITTEE ANNOUNCES
THAT THE TENNIS WILL PAY TEN
DOLLARS A MONTH IF THEY OPT OUT.
WHICH THEY CAN DO IT ANYTIME.
ARE WE ARE OBLIGATED TO
CONTINUE PAYING THE CREDIT
BUREAU FOR A MINIMUM OF SIX-
CONSECUTIVE MONTHS WHICH WE DO
NOT LEAVE IS FAILED- NOR IF
THEY OPT OUT AND STOP HEY
ROBERT CATION WE HAVE NO
ABILITY TO COLLECT ON THAT DEBT
WE CAN'T DEDUCTED FROM A
SECURITY DEPOSIT WE CAN WE WILL
NEVER GO TO COURT OVER TO US
AND THEREFORE IT REMAINS TO
COST IT IS GOING TO BE A COST.
SYSTEMATICALLY THROUGH ALL- ALL
OUR RENTAL HOUSEHOLDS. IS
BECAUSE WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO SET
UP A TRACKING SYSTEM BECAUSE WE
HAVE TO OFFER IT TO EVERYONE
AND TRACK IT IF THEY- OPT IN
THAN THEY OPT OUT THEN THEY
OPTED IN THEY OPT OUT THIS
KINGS EVERYBODY TO WRAP UP
PLEASE YEAH. YES I'M GOING TO
I'LL DO THAT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN FOR THE GARDENS. BOB
SO IN ESSENCE WHAT WE'RE ASKING
FOR. IS IF WE HAVE TO BEFORE
OBLIGATED TO PAY FOR IT WE ARE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO RECOVER ARE
HARD COST BECAUSE THESE ARE
HEAVILY DEED RESTRICTED PRICE
RESTRICTED. PROPERTIES AND THAT
THEIR RECENT A LOT. OF MONEY
LEFT. AT ALL AT THE END OF THE
GAME SO WE ASK THAT THE BILL BE
AMENDED- FOR OUR RECOVERY
ACTUAL RECOVERY OF COSTS. AND
THAT IS CONCLUDES OUR TESTIMONY
WAS MADE CHAIRMAN THANK YOU. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE IN CHAMBERS
WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB ELEVEN FIFTY
SEVEN. SEEING NONE IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE WITNESS VIDEO
ROOM. SEEING NONE AT THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION. BUT. ALL
RIGHT SEEING NONE OPERATOR OPEN
THE LINES FOR TELEPHONIC
OPPOSITION TO SB ELEVEN FIFTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AT AGAIN IF YOU'D LIKE TO SHOW
YOUR OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AND WE'LL GO TO LINE
THIRTY SEVEN. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CLEAN GREASY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS. C. A.
R. IS MOVED INTO POSITION TO SB
ELEVEN FIFTY SEVEN AS AMENDED
ON JULY TH. JULY TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY TWENTY. I WOULD LIKE TO
SINCERELY THANK THE AUTHOR-
STATUS POST COMMITTEE STAFF UP
TO WORKING WITH US TO ADDRESS
OUR CONCERNS WE REALLY
APPRECIATED THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. WOULD YOU LIKE ME TO GET
INSTRUCTIONS ONCE MORE. YES IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK. WHO'S ON THE
PHONE SPEAKING OPPOSITION OF SB
ELEVEN FIFTY SEVEN. PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. NOBODY
ELSE'S QUEUING UP. RIGHT THANK
YOU. AND I'M GONNA BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS MR OBERNOLTE I THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN- CENTER MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT-
REPORTING RANT IS SOMETHING
THAT LANDLORDS ARE IN ABLE TO
DO RIGHT NOW BUT JUST THAT MANY
CHOOSE NOT TO DO IT AND THIS IS
THE BILL THIS IS WHAT YOUR BILL
SEEKS TO ADDRESS IS THAT RIGHT
YEAH. THAT'S HI. SO I HAVE A
COUPLE QUESTIONS REGARDING
THAT- THE BILL SAYS THAT A
TENANT CAN FILE A WRITTEN
NOTICE REQUESTING THE REPORTING
OF THE RENT TO CREDIT BUREAU
AND THE LANDLORD MUST COMPLY
WITH THAT. YEAH ON THE THAT THE
TENANT CAN SUBSEQUENTLY
REQUEST. THAT THE LANDLORD STOP
REPORTING AND THE LANDLORD MUST
COMPLY WITH THAT SO MY QUESTION
IS. IT COULD JUST BE USED AS A
TOOL TO PREVENT A LANDLORDS
FROM REPORTING A NEGATIVE-
PAYMENT HISTORY ON A TENANT SO
ANOTHER WORDS IF THAT HAVE
TENDED JUST REQUESTED REPORTING
AND THEN THE NEXT MONTH
REQUESTED TO STOP REPORTING
WITH THE LANDLORDS AND BE
BARRED FROM EVER REPORTING.
DELINQUENCIES AROUND FOR THAT
TENANTS NOW THEY MANY WERE
LANDLORDS ARE DOING THAT RIGHT
NOW WITHOUT THIS BILL SOLD THIS
WOULD PROHIBIT THEM AT ALL
THAT'S WHAT THEY CHOSE TO DO IT.
OKAY BUT THE BILL SAYS
SOMETHING OVERALL REGION THAT
THE SECTION A TENANT WHO ELECTS
TO HAVE REPORTED. MAY
SUBSEQUENTLY FILE A WRITTEN
REQUEST WITH THEIR LANDLORD TO
STOP THAT REPORTING WITH WHICH
THE LANDLORD SHALL COMPLY. SO
MY QUESTION ISTHE BILL SAYS
THE LANDLORD HAS TO STOP
REPORTING. IS THAT RIGHT OR IS
THAT NOT YOUR INTENTION THAT I
MEAN. WE WANT THEM TO STOP IF
IN FACT A TENANT WHO WAS NOT
INVOLVED IN THE REPORTING OR
LANDLORD WASN'T INVOLVED IN THE
REPORTING PRIOR TO THIS BILL.
OPTION TO THIS AND THEN THEY
SAID I WANT ALONG WITH NO
LONGER BE A PART OF IT NO BUT
THERE ARE SOME LANDLORDS WERE
ALREADY REPORTING NEGATIVE
PAYMENTS THE CREDIT BUREAU SO
THEY WILL CONTINUE ON THEY
WOULD STILL HAVE THAT ABILITY
TO DO SO BUT- THEY JUST STARTED
BECAUSE OF THIS BILL AND THEN
ATTENDING ARE ASKED TO. BE
REMOVED FROM THEIR PROCESS YES
THEY SHOULD BE ABLE TO OPT OUT
OF IT OKAY I'M STILL CONFUSED
OR CENTERS THEY HAVE ATTENDED
IS REPORTING CURRENTLY. I'M.
SORRY LANDLORDS LANDLORDS
REPORTING CURRENTLY. YOUR BILL
PASSES ATTENDED REQUESTS
REPORTING AND THAT SUBSEQUENTLY
REQUESTS THEY'RE REPORTING BE
STOPPED. CAN THE LANDLORD
REPORT NEGATIVE PAYMENT HISTORY
ON THAT TEN AND AFTER THE
REQUEST TO STOP RECORDING. IF
YOU WAS DOING THAT PRIOR TO
THIS BILL BEING ENACTED YES
THEY COULD CONTINUE TO DO THAT
RELATIONSHIP THAT WAS
EXTRAPOLATION FOR THIS BILL.
BUT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ONE FOR
A NEW TENANT TO ENERGY AND
GOING FOR THAT THEIR- PAYMENTS
REPORT. OKAY I'M SORRY. I THINK
I AGREE WITH YOU THAT THAT'S
THE WAY IT OUGHT TO BE
UNFORTUNATELY THE BILL AND
PRINT THAT'S NOT THE WAY IT'S
WRITTEN. AND SO I'D ENCOURAGE
YOU IF THE BILL MOVES FORWARD
HERE TO TAKE A LOOK AT THAT
PALATABLE ASSESSORS DEFICIENCY.
ALSO IF I CAN ASK. THE BILL
SAYS THAT THE FEE THAT CAN BE
COLLECTED FROM A TENANT IF THAT
FEE IS NOT PAID THAT
DELINQUENCY CANNOT BE REPORTED
TO A CREDIT AGENCY I WAS
WONDERING WHAT YOU'RE THINKING
WAS ON THAT. I DIDN'T
UNDERSTAND THAT TO BE THE CASE
IT SAYS THAT- ATTENDANT. CAN
OPT OUT OF PAYING THAT FEE BUT-
I DIDN'T I DON'T SEE WHERE THAT
WOULD BE I MEAN WE TALK ABOUT
TEN DOLLARS I MEAN WHY WOULD WE
REPORT TIME ANYWAY I MEAN WE
TALK ABOUT A TEN DOLLAR PAYMENT
WELL IT'S ACTUALLY SO IT'S KIND
OF A DANGEROUS PRECEDENT I
THINK IF WE'RE TELLING. OUR%
CREDITORS IN CALIFORNIA THAT
THEY ARE UNABLE TO REPORT A
NEGATIVE PAYMENT HISTORY ON A
ON A BORROWER- YOU KNOW I DON'T
THINK THAT THAT'S THE PURPOSE
OF I WOULD CREDIT AGENCIES DO I
CAN HEAR SOME OF THE BEST OF MY
THE ROOT OF MY DISCOMFORT WITH
THIS BILL. IS THAT IT SEEMS
LIKE IT'S DELIBERATELY WORDED
SO THAT ONLY POSITIVE PAYMENT
HISTORY CAN BE REPORTED. AND I
THINK THAT THAT COMPLETELY
MOVES THE PURPOSE OF THE BILL
BECAUSE WE'RE TRYING TO HELP
PEOPLE BUILD A CREDIT HISTORY.
AND CREDIT BUREAUS KNOW THAT.
ONLY POSITIVE. PAYMENT HISTORY
CAN BE REPORTED THAT THEY'RE
JUST GOING TO COMPLETELY
DISCOUNT THAT PAYMENT HISTORY.
WHEN THEY'RE COMPLETING A
CREDIT SCORE ANYWAY. BECAUSE I
MEAN AND THAT THEY'RE THEY'RE
EXPERTS THEY'RE NOT STUPID THEY
THEY KNOW EXACTLY WHAT'S GOING
ON HERE AND SO. I WOULD
ENCOURAGE YOU TO BILL MOVES
FORWARD TO FIX THOSE
DEFICIENCIES BECAUSE I REALLY
THINK THAT- THAT INCLUDES THE
WHOLE POINT AFTER. YOU'RE
YOU'RE TRYING TO MAKE WITH THIS
BILL. BUT THANK YOU THIS RACE.
ON I WANT TO THANK YOU THIS IS
VERY CREATIVE I THINK WHEN WE
HAVE TENANTS WHO HAVE DONE THE
RIGHT THING IN PAYING THE RENT
ON TIME NEVER GET ANY CREDIT I
WAS LISTENING TO THE
OPPOSITION- AND EVERY REASON
GIVEN WAS THE REASON WHY THIS
BILL NEEDS TO BE ENACTED IS
THAT WE HAVE PEOPLE WHO CAN'T
AFFORD SO MUCH BUT WHEN THEY
FINALLY GET TO THE POINT WHERE
THEY CAN'T AFFORD THEY HAVE THE
WORST CREDIT SCORE BECAUSE ALL
THAT'S BEEN REPORTED OR THE
NEGATIVE THINGS WE KNOW THAT
AND LANDLORDS DON'T ALWAYS
REPORT THE NEGATIVE. BUT SOME
OF THEM DO AND THEY WILL NEVER
REPORT THE POSITIVE IT'S
UNFORTUNATE THAT WE HAVE TO
HAVE A BILL THAT WOULD REQUIRE
THEM TO ALSO REPORT THE
POSITIVE SO I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR PRESENTING THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU OKAY. I MISSED
REFERENCE ONE TO GIVE YOU A
CHANCE TO RESPOND TO THE
ARGUMENT FROM THE OPPOSITION
THAT- AND THIS WILL ACTUALLY
END UP HURTING- FOLKS WHO DON'T
DECIDE TO OPT IN. NO I DON'T I
DON'T THINK IT AT ALL AND I'M
DISAPPOINTED WITH THE ANALYSIS
THAT IF YOU WERE. LIVING IN
SUBSIDIZED HOUSING TODAY YOU'LL
FOREVER LIVE IN SUBSIDIZED
HOUSING AS THERE'S NO BENEFIT.
OF GETTING YOUR DIRECT.
REPORTED AN ALMOST STATING THAT
YOU'RE DSTINED TO BE POOR
THEY'RE MEMBERS OF THIS
LEGISLATURE WHO LIVED IN
SUBSIDIZED HOUSING AND TO DATE
NO LONGER LIVE THERE SO THIS IS
A OPPORTUNITY TO MOVE FORWARD
TO ESTABLISH CREDIT. AND TO
BUILD THE AMERICAN DREAM OF.
HOMEOWNERSHIP OR ACQUIRING
PROPERTY SO THIS IS IMPORTANT
MEASURES CHAU. SO I IF I AM I
MIGHT BE MISUNDERSTANDING AGAIN
BUT I THOUGHT WHAT HE SAID AND-
I DIDN'T ITEMS TO CONSENT TO
CORRECTIVE I'M WRONG IS THAT-
IF YOU HAVE SOME PEOPLE WHO
OFTEN- AND OTHERS WHO DON'T
THAT EVEN IF THEY HAVE A GOOD.
RECORD AND- THEIR FAILURE OFTEN
WATCHING HER TIME IN RELATION
TO THE PEOPLE WHO DO NOT. STOP
IT'S ALL SOLD HOW COULD SOMEONE
USES NOT TO PARTICIPATE IN
SOMETHING BE ARMED BY VOLUNTARY.
PROGRAM IT'S OPTION. THE
OPPORTUNITY CHOOSES TOP ARE OUT
BUT BILLS EACH NOT TO. THEY'RE
JUST AS THEY START AFTER NOT
GETTING OF THE PROJECT AND THAT
WE ARE. FAMOUS REPORT BUT THEY
JUST WON'T BENEFIT FROM THE
POSITIVE PAYMENT. HISTORY
THAT'S FAIR ENOUGH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. RIGHT SEE NONE I'M
LOOKING FOR MOTION THE MOTION
IS TO PASS. OKAY SO WE DO HAVE
A MOTION AND A SECOND. CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE. HI HI THIS. CLOSE
I'M SORRY THAT THAT'S I'M
SERVICE PRESS MUCH LIKE NO NO
NO. ALL RIGHT OKAY QUIT WHILE
YOU'RE AHEAD. YOU GET THE LESS
WERE OKAY WELL I JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT THIS IS
THIS THE PERFECT BILL MAIL
WE'RE STILL WORKING ON IT WE
UNDERSTAND THE CHALLENGES THAT
THAT PRESENTS BUT I ALLOWS
CALIFORNIA TO LEAD THE NATION
AND HELPING THOSE WHO LIVE IN
SUBSIDIZED HOUSING IMPROVE
THEIR CREDIT HISTORY AND AGAIN
HOPEFULLY ACHIEVE THE AMERICAN
DREAM AT SOME POINT. OF
HOMEOWNERSHIP CHARGE BACKLESS
BRIDAL. THANK YOU SO WILL
STRIKE THAT PRIOR RULE. NOW
YOU'LL CALL THE ROLL WE DO HAVE
THE MOST IN A SECOND MOTIONS TO
PASS. HI STONE HI GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NOT BOOTING JOE JOE I
TO CHIU AYE GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
HOLDEN KALRA KALRA AYE KILEY
AYE KILEY AYE LIMóN. OBERNOLTE
NO OBERNOLTE NO REYES REYES HI.
THE BILL HAS SEVEN VOTE THE
BILL IS UP THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THANK YOU AND
ARE YOU OUR NEXT IS YOUR BILL
WITH CENTER COPYRIGHT FOURTEEN
TEN ARE YOU PRESENTING THAT
LEFT YEAH OKAY THAT IS NEXT ON
OUR DOCKET SO WE'LL MOVE TO
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN. TEN
OPERATOR IF YOU OPEN THE LINES
FOR. SENATE BILL FOURTEEN TEN.
IF YOU WANT OPEN OUR LINES ARE
OPEN THAT BILL OKAY- GOOD AND
CENTER CABALLERO. YEAH IS
JOINING. SENATOR PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT SB
FOURTEEN TEN AN IMPORTANT
MEASURE TO ENSURE RENTER
FAMILIES AND LANDLORDS RIGHT
CALIFORNIA REMAIN WHOLE DURING
THESE EXTRAORDINARILY DIFFICULT
TIMES. I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
EXTEND MY APPRECIATION OF BOTH
THE JUDICIARY AND THE REVENUE
AND TAX COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR THOROUGH REVIEW OF THIS
ISSUE PROVIDED IN THE ANALYSIS.
AND I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO
USING THE FEEDBACK AS WE
CONTINUE TO WORK OUT THE
DETAILS OF THIS BILL AND I JUST
HAVE TO SAY THAT. THERE ARE
ONGOING CONVERSATIONS BETWEEN
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IN THE
ASSEMBLY IN THE SENATE AS WE
LOOK AT- THE BILLS THAT HAVE
BEEN PROPOSED IN THIS AREA AND
TRYING TO WORK THROUGH- SOME OF
THE SOLUTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
OUTLINED. IN THE ANALYSIS- SO I
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT DETAIL
THAT'S INVOLVED AND THE WAY
THAT IT WAS IT WAS- ORGANIZED
BECAUSE IT'S REALLY A CHECKLIST
I THINK FOR WHAT WE NEED TO DO.
AS WE MOVE FORWARD. AS YOU'RE
AWARE THE CORONA VIRUS PANDEMIC
IS HEADED AN UNPRECEDENTED
EFFECT ON CALIFORNIANS. SINCE
THE ONSET. OF THE SHELTER IN
PLACE ORDER BY THE GOVERNOR
CALIFORNIA HAS EXPERIENCED
HISTORIC. JOB LOSSES.
CALIFORNIA UNDER THE CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT ANNOUNCED IN JUNE.
THE UNEMPLOYMENT RATE PEAKED AT
SIXTEEN POINT THREE PERCENT.
WHICH IS A SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER
THAN THE PEAK UNEMPLOYMENT
RATE. DURING THE GREAT
RECESSION OF TWELVE POINT THREE
PERCENT. AND SINCE THE
BEGINNING OF THE PENDANT
DEMOCRATS WERE SEVEN POINT FIVE
MILLION CALIFORNIANS HAVE FILED
UNEMPLOYMENT CLAIMS. ALL RECENT
NUMBERS HAVE SHOWN A MODEST
IMPROVEMENT THERE'S NO TRUE END
IN SIGHT. AND THE ECONOMIC TOLL
HAS BEEN TREMENDOUS. ALL THE
STATE AND FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
HAD PROVIDE BENEFITS FOR
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES WHO
HAVE LOST THEIR JOBS. MANY OF
THESE BENEFITS HAVE RUN OUT AND
ACTION AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL IS
LACKING. THIS PANDEMIC HAS
EXACERBATED THE STRUGGLE FOR
MANY TO MAKE ENDS MEET. IN
JANUARY AND ANALYSIS BY BY THE
PUBLIC POLICY INSTITUTE OF
CALIFORNIA. SHOWED OVER 50% OF
CALIFORNIANS PAID 30% OR MORE
OF THEIR HOUSEHOLD INCOME ON
HOUSING COSTS. MEANING MORE
THAN HALF OF OUR RESIDENTS ARE
ALREADY BURDENED BY THE HIGH
COST OF RENT IN IN MY DISTRICT.
THAT NUMBER IS CLOSER TO SIXTY
THREE PERCENT. AS A RESULT MANY
RENTERS HAVE STRUGGLED TO PAY
THE RENT. SINCE THE ONSET OF
THE CUPBOARD. NINETEEN VIRUS.
IN ARIL 24% OF RENTERS WERE
UNABLE TO PAY THE RENT ON TIME.
WHICH IS INCREASED TO THIRTY
PERCENT. IN JUNE ACCORDING TO A
RECENT NATIONWIDE STUDY. THE
APPROXIMATELY TWO POINT FOUR
MILLION HOUSEHOLDS. ARE UNABLE
TO PAY RENT. AND THERE ARE AT
RISK OF EVICTION. SO THE
NUMBERS ARE STAGGERING. WITHOUT
STATE INTERVENTION THE NUMBER
OF RENTERS UNABLE TO MEET THEIR
FINANCIAL OBLIGATIONS BORING
HI. OR CONTINUE TO GROW ITS
FULL ECONOMIC RECOVERY. IS
LIKELY STILL A LONG WAY OFF. SB
FOUR FOURTEEN TEN PUT FOUR KEY
PROVISIONS IN PLACE. IT CREATES
COVERED. NINETEEN EVICTION
RELIEF AGREEMENTS. SIR REST IN
TO DEMAND FOR AND- OR OBJECTION
ACCRUED. UNPAID RENT- EVICTION
ACCRUE DURING THIS OF EMERGENCY
AND SPECIFIED TIME THEREAFTER
PROVIDE TO PERSONAL. INCOME OR
CORPORATE TAX CREDIT EQUAL TO
THE OF RENT FOR GIVEN LAN OR
ARE PER OR OWNERS IT'S A DOLLAR
FOR DOLLAR WHICH CAN BE SOLD
FOR IMMEDIATE CASH RELIEF FOR
USED BEGINNING IN TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR. AND REQUIRES TENANTS TO
REPAY THE RENT TO THE STATE IN
ANNUAL INSTALLMENTS INTEREST
FREE BEGINNING IN TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR AND NOT TO EXCEED TEN
YEARS. FINALLY THE BILL
PROVIDES FURTHER AID TO RENTERS
BY ALLOWING QUALIFYING
PARTICIPANTS THE ABILITY TO
NEGOTIATE WITH THE FRANCHISE
TAX BOARD TO FORGIVE SOME OR
ALL OF THE DEFERRED RENT BASED
ON INCOME LEVEL. I WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO ADDRESS AN ISSUE THAT'S BEEN
RAISED THAT IS VERY PERSONAL TO
ME MANY OF THOSE DESPERATELY IN
NEED. FOR HAVE THE LEGAL STATUS
TO ENTER INTO THE AGREEMENTS
UNDER THIS BILL LET ME BE CLEAR
THE INTENT OF THIS BILL IS TO
PROTECT ALL CALIFORNIANS FROM
EVICTION AND PROTECTION SHOULD
NOT BE BASED SOLELY ON WHETHER
OR NOT YOU FILE A TAX RETURN. I
COMMIT TO YOU HERE TODAY THIS
REMAINS A TOP ISSUE AND I
BELIEVE THE BY THE TIME THIS
BILL IS IN FINAL FORM WHETHER
IT'S THIS BILL OR ANOTHER BILL
THIS ISSUE SHOULD BE RESOLVED.
NOW I WOULD LIKE TO TURN IT
OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE AND JOINT
AUTHORS SENATOR BRAD BIRD TO
MAKE SOME CRITICAL COMMENTS AS
WELL. THANK YOU SENATOR. NUMBER
THANK MICHAEL. CENTER COP. FROM
OVER HER WORK AND WORLD. THE
STAFF FOR HELPING US GET TO
POINT. AS STATED AS FORTY
TENNIS CLARISSA. TO THE DESK.
TO MANY TO ALLOW ORDER FOR. TO
COLD BUT NOW. NEARLY ONE
MILLION LEARNERS HOW TO RETURN
ARENA HOW. HAVE X. JOB LOSS BY
OF COLD AT NIGHT. THAT'S
APPROXIMATE ONE INCH ALL
ROUNDERS. BUT THIS PROBLEM
EXISTED WILL BE. COLD WITH NINE
MANY LONG. CALL WERE ALREADY
WRITTEN BURDEN AND CLASS ONLY
MAY IT WORK. YET AGAIN WE SEE
THIS BILL. PAIN AND ON PEOPLE
OF COLOR AND MAKE UP ALMOST
EIGHTY PER. AROUND OUR HOUSE
WHO HAVE YOUR- THIS OUR REGION
THROUGH THE WORKING ECONOMIC
LOOKING GROUP THE SENATE WHICH
ARE SENATOR HURTS PULLED. HELLO.
AND WE KNOW OUR COLLEAGUES IN
THE ASSEMBLY FEEL THE SAME.
THERE ARE A FEW FUNDAMENTAL-
FUNDAMENTALS THAT GUIDE US ON
THIS BILL TENANTS WHO CANNOT
PAY THE RENT DUE TO CALL THE
NINETEEN SHOULD NOT BE EVICTED
FOR ONLY FOR ONLY THAT REASON
LANDLORDS STRUGGLING BECAUSE-
THEY'RE TENANTS ARE STRUGGLING
SHOULD NOT BE FORCED INTO
FORECLOSURE ONLY FOR THAT
REASON. AND THE GENERAL FUND
MUST BE PROTECTED BECAUSE OF
THE OTHER CRITICAL PROGRAMS
THAT- WE MUST SUPPORT AND IF WE
PUT. THE FULL FORCE OF THE
CRISIS ON LENDERS CREDIT WILL
BECOME MORE SCARCE AND WHICH
WILL UNFAIRLY HURT BILLS AGAIN
WITH BAD CREDIT SCORES AND MOST
AGAIN PEOPLE OF COLOR. ARE
EVERYONE TEN IT'S A LOT MORE TO
LIKE- WE HAVE TO COMPROMISE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THIS IS WORKABLE
I'M GONNA BE VERY CLEAR THIS IS
NOT A HANDOUT. TO RUNNERS
ORLANDO. IT'S A HAND. HAND UP
TO HELPFUL SURVIVE DURING THIS
CRITICAL ISSUE I MEAN CRITICAL
TIME MANY PEOPLE CONTINUE TO
SAY THAT. WE'RE PROTECTING THE
LEARNERS KNOW WE WANT TO
PROTECT BILL SMALL MOM AND POP
LANDLORDS WHO. IF THEIR TENANTS
WERE NOT KEEN THEY CAN'T MAKE
THEIR MORTGAGE PAYMENTS BUT AT
THE SAME TIME. IF EIGHT
LANDLORDS NOT MAKING HIS
MORTGAGE PAYMENTS. EVERYONE
LOSES THAT THE TENANT GETS
EVICTED THAT PROPERTY GETS
FORECLOSED ON SO THESE TAX
CREDITS ARE SMALL WAY TO HELP.
KEEP EVERYBODY HOUSE KEEPS
TENANTS FROM BEING EVICTED
DURING THIS EMERGENCY EXCEPT
FORGET HEALTH AND SAFETY REASON
ALLOW THEM TO FOR. MUCH OF THE
MISPRINT AS NEEDED FOR SEVERAL
YEARS INTEREST FREE A STATE
GRANT STRUGGLING LANDLORD TO
TAX CREDIT CAN BE USED OR SOLD
IF NEEDED. THE FIRST PAYMENTS
TO TWENTY TWENTY FOUR AND A
GORGEOUS WHAT. HOMEOWNERS
MORTGAGE PROTECTIONS WITHOUT
SQUEEZING NOT CREDIT
AVAILABILITY THIS BILL IS A
STRONG PROPOSAL BECAUSE IT
SEEKS TO BALANCE BETWEEN.
TENANTS AND LANDLORDS THE
BALANCE BETWEEN KEEPING PEOPLE
HALLS NOW IN DIFFERENT MOST OF
THE COST. ARE TO A LATER DATE.
AND AGAIN WE HAVE WORKED. HARD
ON THIS PROPOSAL AND- I WASTE
FOR JUST A THE GUY THINK ABOUT
HOW TO REACH TO THIS CRISIS AND
THIS BILL IS ONE OF THOSE THE
CENTRAL. CONVERSATION PIECES TO
HELP ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE
CONCERNED RECOGNIZES BILL STILL
WORK IN PROGRESS. AND WE'RE
COMMITTED TO WORKING ON ISSUES
AND WE CONTINUE TO HAVE THIS
FINAL CONVERSATION AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL TODAY
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT IS DANIEL
SOLVING ALL- WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF REGIONAL CENTER
AGENCIES. THANK YOU I DO HAVE
TWO WITNESSES SUPPORTLISTED
DANIEL CITY YOU KNOW. WHO IS
HERE IN PERSON AND DEBRA
CARLTON. ON THE TELEPHONE SO WE
WILL START WITH MISTER CITY YOU
KNOW HERE IN THE CHAMBERS OKAY
GOOD AFTERNOON- CHAIRED MEMBERS
DANIEL SABINO SUBSTATION OF
REGIONAL CENTER AGENCIES.
OBVIOUSLY WERE IN SUPPORT OF
THE POLICY CONCEPT THIS
BALANCES THE INTERESTS OF
RENTERS. WHO ARE AT ECONOMIC
RISK THROUGH NO FAULT OF THEIR
OWN. WITH THE FINANCIAL
REALITIES FACED BY LANDLORDS
WHO DO HAVE BILLS TO PAY.
THAT'S OBVIOUSLY BEEN- WELL
SPOKEN TO BY BOTH THE AUTHOR
AND HER CO AUTHOR. BUT ALSO
LIKE TO SPEAK BRIEFLY ON THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS HUMAN LEVEL.
WE HAVE A PANDEMIC FACING OUR
STATE AND OUR NATION AND STATE
TODAY EVERYBODY IS STRUGGLING.
OUR SYSTEM THERE ARE OVER THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES- THE SERVICES ARE
COORDINATED BY REMEMBER
REGIONAL CENTERS. THESE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
WORKED DILIGENTLY TO PROVIDE
THOSE SUPPORTS AND ENSURE THAT
PEOPLE DEVELOP ABILITIES CAN
LIVE AS INTEGRATED A LIFE AS
POSSIBLE. BUT OF HOUSING IS FOR
HOUSING IN THE FAMILY HOME. IS
ONE OF. CHOICES THAT PEOPLE
MAKE INTO THE REGIONAL CENTER
STRIVE TO SUPPORT. OUR
OPPORTUNITY TO SUPPORT THEM
THOUGH IN THE FACE OF AN
EVICTION IS EXTRAORDINARILY
LIMITED. THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW
THESE INDIVIDUALS TO SEEK
RELIEF THROUGH THEIR LANDLORDS
THROUGH THESE SAARA AGREEMENTS.
AND WOULD THEN ALLOW THE
LANDLORD SOME FINANCIAL
PROTECTION TO ENSURE THAT THEY
CAN STILL MAKE THEIR MORTGAGE
PAYMENTS. THIS IS A GROUP
HOUSING STABILITY. STABILITY OF
HOUSING IS OF COURSE CRITICAL
TO ANY PERSON BUT THIS IS
DOUBLY ND TRIPLY SO CASE FOR A
PERSON WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES. THEIR ABILITIES
TO REMAIN INTEGRATED IN THEIR
COMMUNITY HAD TO CONTINUE TO
MAKE PROGRESS IN THEIR DAY TO
DAY LIVES IS FOUNDED ON THEIR
ABILITY TO HAVE SAFE AND SECURE
HOUSING. WE VERY DEEPLY THANK
THE AUTHOR AND ALL MEMBERS FOR
CONSIDERING THIS FOR THE BILL.
IT WILL PROVIDE STABILITY AND
SUPPORT FOR PEOPLE
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES OF
COURSE BUT OF COURSE THE MANY
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE AT RISK OF
EVICTION AGAIN THROUGH NO
FURTHER ON. WITH YOUR FOR SHIP
UNDERSCORE. THANK YOU. IS
DIFFICULT ON THE LINE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION. YES I AM SIR RIGHT
YOU ARE THE SECOND WITNESS IN
SUPPORT PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS HASN'T
EVER CROSSED WITH THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION WE WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHORS FOR THIS TRULY
HERCULEAN TASK YOU ARE
UNDERTAKING WITH. SENATE BILL
FOURTEEN CAN WE BELIEVE IT'S
IMPORTANT TO CONTINUE TO FIND
THE ANSWERS FOR BOTH OWNERS AND
TENANTS AND WE APPRECIATE THAT
YOU'RE CONTINUING TO WORK WITH
US ON THE LANGUAGE YOU KNOW OUR
GOAL IS TO ENSURE THAT WE DON'T
SEE AFFECTION FOR UNPAID RENT
ACCRUED DURING THE PANDEMIC. AT
THE SAME TIME WE WANT TO ENSURE
THAT WE DON'T SEE PROPERTY
FORECLOSURES BANKRUPTCIES OR
SALES OF THESE SMALL-
PROPERTIES BECAUSE OF LACK OF
INCOME YOU CAN'T TALK ABOUT
RENT PAYMENT DELAY. WITHOUT
TAKING INTO CONSIDERATION THE
NEED FOR FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE
ESPECIALLY FOR SMALL PROPERTY
OWNERS. SENATE BILL FOURTEEN
TEN IS THE ONLY BILL THAT
ATTEMPTS TO DO BOTH. IF WE
DON'T FIND A FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE SOONER FOR THE SMALL
OWNERS THEY WILL LOSE THEIR
HOUSING AND ULTIMATELY THE
TENANTS WILL LOSE THEIR HOMES.
MANY OF THESE SMALL OWNERS HAVE
STRUGGLED TO BILL AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING- BUSINESS
AND RETIREMENT PLAN THEMSELVES.
AND WE KNOW FROM OF THE RECENT
UC BERKELEY TURNER CENTER
REPORT THAT TWENTY FIVE
PERCENT. OF SMALL MOM AND POP
OWNERS HAVE ALREADY BORROWED
MONEY TO HELP PAY THE BILLS.
AND 40% OF THOSE OWNERS BELIEVE
THAT THEY WON'T BE ABLE TO MAKE
IT ANOTHER THREE MONTHS. MOST
OF THE HOUSING IS AFFORDABLE
HERE AND WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT
WE DON'T LOSE THE HOME TO
FORECLOSURE. WE STAND READY TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THE
LANGUAGE OF THIS BILL AND WE
ASK THAT YOU MOVE THIS BILL OUT
TODAY SO THAT WE CAN DO THAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
RIGHT WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
OTHERS IN SUPPORT WE ARE. DONE
WITH THE DETAILED TESTIMONY
WE'RE LOOKING FOR THOSE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO. GIVE US THEIR
NAMES AND THAT THEY SUPPORT THE
BILL SO WE WILL MOVE FIRST TO
THE WITNESS VIDEO ROOM IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE WITNESS VIDEO
ROOM. SEEING NONE WHAT ABOUT
THE REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION.
ALL RIGHT SEEING NONE OPERATOR
WILL MOVE TO THE TELEPHONES FOR
THOSE WHO ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN TEN. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN TO SHOW YOUR
SUPPORT ON THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY THE ZERO.
AND OUR FIRST PARTICIPANT IS
ONE THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MORNING MISTER CHAIR ADAM
BRADLEY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE ONE OF
AGAIN BY THANK YOU BOTH AUTHORS
AFTER THE HEAVY LIFT ON THI
BILL- THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION FOR CALIFORNIA. AND
I WANT TO LINE ARE COMMON WITH
DEBRA CARLTON ANY APARTMENT.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH BOTH OFFERS TO GET
THIS INTO A GREAT PLACE THANKS
SO MUCH. THANK YOU. NEXT TO A
LINE FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU WONDER YOU MUTED. THE
NEW LIFE FIFTY ONE. BUILDING A
LONGER LIFE FIFTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MISTER KAREN MEMBERS
OBVIOUSLY SHOT ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF SANTA MONICA AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND WE WILL
GO TO LINE FIFTY NINE. GOOD
MORNING KAREN MEMBERS FERTILITY
DOCTOR BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
BEVERLY HILLS IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. A SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HOWEVER MANY THEY HAD
THIS WITH LIKE HOT PUBLIC
AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF DAN HELD
PROPERTIES AT OAKLAND SUPPORT
OF THE BILL AND WERE PLEASED TO
SEE THE PROGRESS THAT WE HAVE
AUTHORED MADE WHICH APARTMENT
SITUATION THE CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE. SIXTY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. ACCORDING TO CAMBER
TERRY ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF THE
ARK AND UCPE CALIFORNIA
COOPERATION IS FAR. WE WILL GO
TO LINE TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS GREGORY KRAMER ON
BEHALF OF DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA- WE THANK THE
AUTHORS UP FOR THIS MEASURE AND
ARE IN SUPPORT AND I ALSO
APPRECIATE THE OPEN LINE OF
COMMUNICATION THAT WE'VE HAD
WITH THE AUTHOR STAFF- WE'RE
HOPING TO SEE A COUPLE OF
OTHER. PROTECTION ISSUES BUT
PERFECTLY THANK YOU I'M SORRY
WE'RE NOT AKING ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY AT THIS POINT JUST
SUPPORT. AND WE WERE LINE FIFTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS HERE ROBERT
HALF OF THE CITIES OF BURBANK%
AND STOP IN AND SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. AND WE WILL GO TO ONE
FORTY EIGHT. IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. I'M SORRY COULD YOU
GIVE US YOUR NAME AGAIN. WELL
THANK YOU. AND WE'LL GO TO LINE
SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING RAIN ALLIANCE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA HELPING
CONTORTION WHAT THE SUPPORT
AMENDED POSSESSION THANK YOU.
M. MISTER CHAIR THERE ARE NO
OTHER PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT
THIS TIME. GREAT THANK YOU SO
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO OPPOSITION
IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN THE
CHAMBERS WHO WOULD LIKE TO.
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. SEEING
NONE ANYONE IN THE WITNESS
VIDEO ROOM. SEEING NONE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION. SEEING NONE
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINE STAND FOR OPPOSITION TO
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN TEN. THANK
YOU CARE TO SHOW YOUR
OPPOSITION ON THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. HI
ONE MOMENT THINK THAT THIS GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN NUMBER THIS IS
ALLOCATE BALBOA CAPITAL
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF TO
CALIFORNIA RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION WE HAVE AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION-
CALORIE QUE REPRESENTS OVER
SEVENTEEN THOUSAND MEMBERS
TOTALING MORE THAN FIVE HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND UNITS STATEWIDE.
WE ARE MADE UP OF SMALL MEDIUM
AND LARGE WILL HELP YOU KNOW-
BUT THE BULK OF OUR MEMBERS ARE
SMALL AND IF YOU'RE IN THE
STATE I ALSO WANT TO BEGIN BY
THANKING THE AUTHORS AND
COMMITTEE STAFF TO THIS WORK UP
TO WORK ON THIS ISSUE. CALORIE
TO SUPPORT THE SYSTEM TO RECORD
BUT HAVE BEEN ADVERSELY
AFFECTED BY THE PANDEMIC AND
OUR MEMBERS. WORKING CAN NOW ON
RENT. REPAYMENT AGREEMENT
BECAUSE IT'S BEST FOR ALL SIX
REMAIN IN THEIR UNITS ARE
CONCERNED WITH SB FOURTEEN TEN
CENTERS ON TWO ISSUES. FIRST WE
BELIEVE AT THE FOURTEEN TEN IS
OVERLY BROAD BECAUSE IT IS NOT
LIMITED TO RENTERS WHO HAVE
BEEN NEGATIVELY IMPACTED BY
COPING NINETEEN FINANCIALLY-
DIRECTOR REQUIREMENTS
REGISTRATION OR WRITTEN
DOCUMENTATION ATTEND ACTUALLY
SUFFERED FINANCIALLY- THEREFORE
pBE INCENTIVIZED TO STOP PAYING
RENT EVEN IF THEY CAN AFFORD IT
THIS WILL RESULT IN A HUGE
FINANCIAL LOSS RENTAL HOUSING
PROVIDERS AS WELL AS TO THE
STATE SO WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT THE BILL BE
AMENDED TO. ADDRESS TEND TO
ACTUALLY VERIFY KOBE NINETEEN
RELATED HARDSHIP. AND THEN
SECONDLY. SB FOURTEEN CAN
PROVIDE NO IMMEDIATE FINANCIAL
RELIEF FOR RENTAL HOUSING
OWNERS IT IS GOING TO BE
ESPECIALLY DETRIMENTAL TO
SMALLER OWNERS WILL LIKELY GO
BANKRUPT OR THEIR PROPERTY ONE
THIRD. PAYMENT. ALL THAT
REIMBURSE TO RENT HOUSING. AND
BUT CREDIT BUT THAT DOES NOT
EVEN L. UNTIL TWENTY TWO FOUR I
RESPECTFULLY THAT TOO LONG THE
TIME. FOR HOUSING OWNERS OF.
THE OWNERS WE WOULD KNOWLEDGE
THERE IS NO BILL TO SELL TRIED.
BUT YOU CAN ONLY SELL ONE AND
THE ARE CURRENTLY NO MARK FOR
THAT. WITHOUT THE ABILITY TO
HAVE A TAX CREDIT BUNDLED OR
RESULT IN DEATH. BUT THE- TO.
AND IS EVEN NOTED THE COMMITTEE.
WHICH STATE IT IS UNLIKELY THAT
THE- RETAIL PRICE OF TAX
CREDITS WILL. SEVENTY NINE ON
THE DOLLAR FOR CERTAIN
TAXPAYERS AND MAYBE MUCH LOWER
SO. ARCSECOND REQUEST WOULD BE
RESPECTFULLY TO- HAVE MORE
IMMEDIATE RELIEF FOR SMALL
OWNERS AND THAT THE DEFINITION
OF SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS
INCLUDE SMALL MULTI UNIT
OWNERS. I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS OF THE STORM
IMPORTANT APPRECIATE THE TIME
TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THEN WE ALSO
HAVE LISTED KAREEM TO RECIEVE
FROM THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF REALTORS. WHO TESTIFYING IN
OPPOSITION. ARE YOU ONLINE. I
GUESS MR J. OKAY GOOD MORNING
ONE MISTER. MEMBERS CREAM ON
THE CAL. SAYS HE OF REAL HERE
CAME OPPOSED CEMENT POSITION ON
SB FOURTEEN UNDER SB FOURTEEN
TEN HAS BEEN AS HAS BEEN
PREVIOUSLY NOTED- PROPERTY
OWNER NAY TENET NAY ENTER INTO
AN AGREEMENT THAT ALLOWS
ATTENDED TO DEFER ANY
BACKGROUND OR CREATED DURING
THE COLD NINETEEN STATE OF
EMERGENCY. AND NON SPECIFIED
NUMBER OF DAYS THEREAFTER. OVER
TEN YEARS BEGINNING IN TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR WHICH I MORE THAN
THREE YEARS FROM NOW. THE TEN
IT WOULD HAVE TO PAY THAT COPE
WITH NINETEEN BACKGROUND TO THE
STATE AND THE PROPERTY OWNER
WOULD GET IN TURN. TAX CREDITS
EQUAL TO THE AMOUNT OF THAT
COULD NINETEEN BACKGROUND.
UNFORTUNATELY SB FOURTEEN TEN
DOES NOT HELP MOM AND POP
HOUSING PROVIDERS. WE NEED
IMMEDIATE RELIEF. AND THE
RESOURCES TO PARTICIPATE IN
SUCH A COMPLICATED PROGRAM.
ADDITIONALLY THE BILL FAILS TO
ADDRESS THE IMMEDIATE CRISIS
AND THE PROGRAM IS NOT IN UNTIL
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. HUNDRED
FIFTEEN TEN YEARS BETWEEN NOW
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR SMALL
HOUSING PROVIDERS WILL BE
UNABLE TO CONTINUE PROVIDING
STATE HOUSE. THEY WILL HAVE NO
RENTAL PAYMENTS COMING IN AND
WILL BE UNABLE TO PROTECT
FAMILIES TO WHOM THEY ARE
PROVIDING SHELTER. FROM
NUISANCE TENANTS PROTECTION. C.
A. R. IS MINDFUL OF THE WORK IN
PROGRESS NATURE OF THIS MEASURE
AND LOOKS FOR TO ENGAGING IN
COLLABORATIVE DISCUSSIONS WITH
THE AUTHORS STAFF AND A COAL.
OUR HOPE IS. IT WILL BE
PROTECTED RESULT IN THEM IS
BEING INCORPORATED INTO THE
BILL THAT ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS.
HOWEVER IT'S CURRENTLY DRAFTED
YOU MUST RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
IN NO BUT. AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU. AND
ENDS THE DETAIL TEST IF ANY
ELSE ON THE LINE ON THE
TELEPHONES LIKE TO REGISTER
OPPOSITION GIVE US YOUR NAME
YOUR SOCIAIS ASIAN AND THAT YOU
OPPOSE. SENATE BILL FOURTEEN
TEN. AND PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
TO SHOW YOUR OPPOSITION OUR
FIRST LINE WILL COME FROM ONE
THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. FOR
NOW IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
I'M THIRTY ONE COULD YOU REPEAT
YOUR NAME PLEASE. BUT NO HOWARD
ON BEHALF OF THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA. NEXT WE WERE LINE
SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GRAND MARTIN
ON BEHALF OF THE AIDS
HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION WELL WE
APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS OF THE
AUTHORS WE ARE CURRENTLY
OPPOSED TO- TO THIS VERSION THE
BILL. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
FORTY NINE PLEASE ON MUTE YEAH.
YES GOOD MORNING SHARE AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE JACK
SCHWARTZ I'M SMALL PROPERTY
OWNER IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY IN
A MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
RENTAL HOUSING ASSOCIATION
THANK YOU ARE YOU POSING LESS
AMENDED FOR THE REASONS BY KATE
BELL. THANK SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
AT THE CHRIS WYSOCKI WITH
WESTERN MANUFACTURED HOUSING
COMMUNITIES ASSOCIATION AND I
APOLOGIZE FOR A LATE LETTER BUT
WE ARE IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. THANK YOU. ONE THIRTY SIX
EUROPEN. THIRTY SIX HELLO HELLO
YES HI MY NAME IS TO BUY THEM
FOR A LIST OF AND I'M WITH
LEADERSHIP CALPERS FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY WE WORK WITH
RESIDENTS AND THE CENTRAL
VALLEY COACHELLA VALLEY- AND WE
OPPOSE. THANK YOU. I FIFTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH
RICHARD SCHAEFER I'M RETIRED-
PROPERTY OWNER OF TWO
PROPERTIES DON'T MAKE MORE THAN
THIRTY THOUSAND A YEAR AND WE
WILL BE DEVASTATED IF SOMEONE
WERE TO DO THIS IT'S ALSO I'M
SORRY SIR I AM I'M SORRY NOT
TAKING ANY ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY
IF YOU COULD JUST REGISTER
OPPOSITE OPPOSITION THANK YOU
WE GET TO SPEAK LATER. NO THIS
IS NOT THE TESTIMONY IS
COMPLETE. THANK YOU. WE WILL
ALIGN FORTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD
HELLO ANASTASI OF ANNAPOLIS
THAT PRINCESS GO TENANTS UNION
THIS OFFERED NO SOLUTION TO
TENANTS OF THE LAND THAT CAN
REFUSE TO PARTICIPATE I THINK
YOU AND IT'S A LITTLE LESS
AMENDED. AND NEXT WE WILL GO TO
LINE FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YOUR FUTURE MEMBERS PAT MORAN
WITH ERIN READING ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL THANK YOU. AND LIKE
SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
CHAIRMAN MMBERS STEVE CARLSON
FOR THE APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
OF GREATER LOS ANGELES IN
OPPOSITION. AM I FORTY SIX YOU
ARE OPEN. I JUST WANT KINGSTON
REPRESENTING THREE REGIONAL
APARTMENT ASSOCIATIONS IN
ORANGE COUNTY EAST BAY. AND
SOUTHERN CITIES AS WELL AS THE
ESCROW INSTITUTED CALIFORNIA-
AND THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
MANAGEMENT ASSOCIATIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WE TWO ARE
IN OPPOSITION- THE BILL DO
WITH. DEDICATING IMPACT ON
SMALLER THANK THANK YOU. AND WE
WILL GO TO LIKE FIFTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. APOLOGIES
CHAIRED THE GROWING OUT OF
ORDER IF I COULD REGISTER
SUPPORT BECAUSE HE STANFORD
BRIDGE HOUSING IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO NOTED. AND WE
HAVE ONE MORE PRACTICE BUT WITH
AN OPERATOR ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
WE'LL GO TO LINE SEVENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SEVENTY FIVE
YOU ARE OPEN. I SEVENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH THIS IS
PETER RIGHTS FOR GOOD SMALL
PROPERTY OWNERS IN SAN
FRANCISCO IN OPPOSITION. MISTER
CHAIR THERE ARE NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP WE JUST
HAVE ONCE THE SKEWS ME ALKALINE
FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ON
BEHALF OF ARLENE FEDORENKO.
NINETY YEAR OLD THEIR- PROPERTY
OWNER OPPOSE. THERE ARE NO
OTHER PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT
THIS TIME. RIGHT IF ANYONE
WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER A
POSITIONING AND SAYS P.
FOURTEEN TEN AND YOU'RE ON THE
PHONES PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
I WILL ALIGN SEVENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
PETER RIGHTS SERVICE BALL
PROPERTY OWNERS IN SEPARATIST
CO IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. I
FIFTY SEVEN YOU ARE ALL BUT.
GARKO IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
THERE THERE'S NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME OKAY THEN. MODERATOR CLOSE
THE LINES FOR SB FOURTEEN TEN
AND WILL BRING IT BACK P TO
THE COMMITTEE AND CENTERS- I
WOULD APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT
YOU'VE DONE. ON THIS SO FAR AND
I DO AGREE THAT THERE IS QUITE
A BIT OF WORK LEFT TO BE DONE
AND I THINK WE- THREE STAFF IN
IN TALKING TO HAS EXPRESSED
SOME OF THAT. I WORRY THAT
THERE'S NOT ENOUGH HERE FOR THE
SMALLEST OF THE LANDLORDS. AND
I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE NOT SETTING UP SOMETHING
THAT WE SEEN ON THE FEDERAL
LEVEL WHERE THOSE WHO HAVE THE
MOST RESOURCES ARE GETTING THE
MOST OF. THE RELIEF MONEY THAT
THAT CANNOT BE THE MODEL. HERE
IN CALIFORNIA. AND SHE TAKEN
SOME OF THE AMENDMENTS OF THAT
WE PUT IN TO PROVIDE SOME
ADDITIONAL TENANT PROTECTIONS
BUT THERE'S AN ADDITIONAL BILL
THAT REALLY IS THE SAME SUBJECT
AND THAT'S MESSAGES BILL THAT'S
IN THE SENATE THAT THAT. NEEDS
TO BE. BROUGHT NECESSARILY TO
THIS BILL BUT NEEDS TO BE
CONSIDERED AT THE SAME TIME
BECAUSE IT IS WE'RE TRYING TO
PROTECT. LANDLORDS WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE WE'RE DOING
EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN FOR
FROM LOSING THEIR- THEIR
HOUSING I. I KNOW IN FROM YOUR
STATEMENTS THAT THE SHARED SOME
OF THOSE BUT THIS IS A- NEED TO
BE A MULTI FACETED APPROACH IT
IS A VERY COMPLEX APPROACH AND-
I THINK WE HAVE TO BE CAREFUL
AS WE MOVE FORWARD I'M GLAD THE
GOVERNOR'S ENGAGED IN THIS. YOU
MAY. NOT BE BUT HAD TO TRY AND
BRING. THE BROUGHT THE POLICIES
TOGETHER AND ENSURE THAT THAT
WE HAVE A PACKAGE THAT THIS
LEGISLATURE OVERALL CAN BE
PROUD OF THIS THAT THAT'S
REALLY THE GOAL LIKE I KNOW
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO INCREASE
TO CONVERSE. WE TRYING TO. SO
MISCONDUCTS. SENATOR I WANT TO
PREFACE THIS WITH- I KNOW YOU
WELL ENOUGH TO KNOW THIS IS
NOT- MY CONCERNS WITH THE BILL
ARE NOT YOUR INTENT WITH THE
BILL- AND SO I WANT TO MAKE
SURE BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY THE
THINGS I'M A SE- ARE A COMMON
CONCERN WITH OUR LATINO CAUCUS
AND I KNOW YOU KNOW THIS SO. I
ABSOLUTELY CANNOT. SUPPORT AND
F. THAT HAS OR SEEKS TO HELP A
SMALL PORTION OF TENANTS THAT
DON'T INCLUDE THOSE WITHOUT
DOCUMENTATION I JUST I CANNOT
AND WILL NOT DO THAT DOESN'T
MEAN I WON'T VOTE FOR TODAY TO
MOVE ON BECAUSE I KNOW THAT'S A
BIG CONCERN BUT WE ARE SEEN
SYSTEMATICALLY AS YOU KNOW- A
SECTION OF OUR COMMUNITY- E
ACTUALLY CALLED- ESSENTIAL
WORKERS WHO ARE BEING LEFT OUT
OF EVERY RELIEF PACKAGE THAT
COMES THROUGH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WHOSE FAMILIES ARE
BEING JEOPARDIZED- BY IT BY
THEIR EFFORTS IN OUR OWN- SOME
OF HIS FAMILY MEMBERS OF COURSE
MANY WHOSE. KIDS ARE GOING TO
BE U. S. CITIZENS. ANY PAY
TAXES IN DIFFERENT FORMS- I'M
OBVIOUSLY THERE ARE SOME TWEAKS
THAT I TEN FILERS MIGHT BE ABLE
TO. OPERATE UNDER THIS BUT- I
THINK IT'S A HARD LINE THAT
MANY OF US HAVE CHOSEN TO TAKE
WITHIN THE CAUCUS AT THIS POINT
BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN BANGING THE
DRUM FOR SO LONG AND IT SEEMS
LIKE. THESE PROPOSALS STILL-
NEGLECT THE DEEP AND
DISPROPORTIONATE EFFECT THAT
IT'S HAVING ON MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITY INCLUDING- THOSE WHO
ARE UNDOCUMENTED AND MIXED
STATUS HOUSEHOLDS- SO THAT'S A
STATEMENT BUT AGAIN YOU YOU
ADDRESSED IT AND I UNDERSTAND
THAT. YOU ADDRESS YOUR COMMENTS
THAT THAT WAS NOT YOUR YOUR
PURPOSE. I AM EQUALLY
CONCERNED- THAT IT WILL LEAVE
OUT THE POOREST OF OUR
COMMUNITY MEMBERS WHO DON'T
FILE TAXES. AND SO I SPENT A
LONG TIME TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
HOW. THIS WORKS- THAT THAT'S
ANOTHER CONCERN MY LIKE HOW
QUICKLY WE CAN GET THIS UP AND
RUNNING AND ACTUALLY UTILIZE
GIVEN THE COMPLEXITY OF IT. AND
THEN ON TOP OF THAT HOW WE
ADDRESS THESE POPULATIONS WHO-
DON'T HAVE A SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBER. I ALSO WANT TO WARN AS
WE MOVE FORWARD THAT IT WOULD
BE UNACCEPTABLE IN MY MIND TO
FORCE- TENANTS TO INFORM THEIR
LANDLORDS THAT ARE
UNDOCUMENTED- I HAPPEN TO. HAVE
LIVED THROUGH AN ERA IN SAN
DIEGO COUNTY- WHERE THERE WAS
EFFORTS TO. PENALIZE AT FIRST
FOR LANDLORDS TO. PARTICIPATE
IN IN THE EFFORTS TO INFORM-
AGENTS OF PEOPLE'S
DOCUMENTATION STATUS AND WE
HAVE A NUMBER OF. OF
INDIVIDUALS- I FEAR THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE WORRIED ABOUT
IMMIGRATION STATUS WILL LEAVE
THEIR RESIDENTS TO BECOME- WITH
THAT HOMELESS. RATHER THAN
SHARE THAT IN. WITH THEIR
FAMILY SO THOSE ARE MY CONCERNS
MOVING FORWARD- I THINK IT
MOVES IF IT MOVES TODAY IT
WOULD MOVE TO MIGHT COMMITTEE-
BUT I KNOW YOU CARE DEEPLY
ABOUT ALL. CALIFORNIANS
ESPECIALLY THOSE MOST
VULNERABLE AND SO. I'M GLAD
YOU'RE THE AUTHOR- BUT I'M I'M
VERY NERVOUS ABOUT THIS BILL.
AND ANY RELIEF IT SEEKS TO. IT
SEEKS TO HELP I DON'T THINK
IT'S BROAD ENOUGH I THINK
RENTAL RELIEF AND KEEPING
PEOPLE THEIR HOUSES CAN AND
SHOULD BE OUR NUMBER ONE
PRIORITY RIGHT NOW IN IN THIS
LEGISLATURE- IT IS THE ONE
THING WERE RESPONSIBLE FOR TO
KEEP PEOPLE HOUSED IN AND THEN
FED THOSE ARE THE TWO THINGS I
THINK AS WE MOVE INTO. A TIME
OF ECONOMIC CRISIS WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE TO FACE OUT SO THOSE
ARE MY COMMENTS- IF I PREFER
NOT TO EVEN VOTE FOR THIS IN
THIS FORM I WON'T BE THE REASON
THAT THAT'LL DIES- SO IF I NEED
TO VOTE FOR TO MOVE IT ON I
WILL BUT- I KNOW YOU TAKE THESE
ISSUES SERIOUSLY AND I HOPE WE
CAN WORK ON OVER THE NEXT. WEEK
TO GET INTO A POSITION WHERE WE
CAN CONTINUE TO MOVE. RIGHT IN
FRONT OF. OKAY. THIS OBERNOLTE
THAT IS. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN OF SENATOR- IS YOU
KNOW I'M VICE CHAIR OF ASSEMBLY
BUDGET AND I SAID- JAIL B. C.
AS WELL SO I TEND TO SEE POLICY
THROUGH BUDGETARY LANDS YEAH
AND MY FIRST THOUGHTS WHEN I
READ YOUR BILL WAS- INTERESTING
IDEA I WONDER WHAT THAT WILL
COST AND HOW WILL PAY FOR IT.
SO ACTUALLY FIGURE OUT WHAT IT
WOULD COST IS NOT A SIMPLE TASK
BECAUSE IT'S A VERY COMPLEX
ISSUE TO HAVE TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT PERCENTAGE OF ATTENDANCE
IN THE STATE WOULD TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THIS YOU HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT- BECAUSE THEIR TAX
CREDIT YOU HAVE TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT THE TAX SITUATION OF THE
LANDLORDS IS AND HOW MUCH FOR
BROWN REVENUE THE STATE WITH
THAT EXPERIENCE. AND THEN YOU
HAVE TO FIGURE OUT HOW MANY-
TEST LANDLORDS WOULD REQUEST
REFUNDABLE- REFUNDS OF THE TAX
CREDIT AND WHETHER OR NOT THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD APPROPRIATE
MONEY FOR HAT SINCE THAT'S A
SEPARATE PORTION OF THE BILL
SO- YOU KNOW IT'S A COMPLEX
ISSUE BUT CRUNCHING THE NUMBERS
IT SEEMS CLEAR THAT EVERYONE
AGREES THAT THE COST OF THIS
WOULD BE AT LEAST TWELVE
BILLION DOLLARS AND POTENTIALLY
SUBSTANTIALLY MORE THAN THAT
WOULD YOU AGREE WITH THAT. I
WOULD AGREE AND PART OF THE
CHALLENGE AND- HIS GETS TO THE
ISSUE THAT WAS THAT WAS JUST.
RAISED BY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ IS THAT- THERE.
ORIGINALLY THIS BILL BASICALLY
SAYS THE STATE IS GOING TO PONY
UP THE MONEY. THAT THAT WAS THE
ORIGINAL BILL WAS WAS TO SAY WE
GOT TO TAKE CARE OF THE
SITUATION GOT TO DO IT NOW. THE
PROBLEM WITH THAT IS THAT WE
DON'T HAVE THE MONEY. WE DON'T
HAVE IT NOW AND WE LOOK DOWN
THE ROAD WEHOPE THAT THE
ECONOMY STARTS TO PICK UP. AND
SO THE A NUMBER OF THINGS THAT
WE BEEN. BATTING AROUND IN
TERMS OR TO A BAR DISCUSSION OF
HOW. HOW DO WE DETERMINE WHO
REALLY NEEDS. THE RELIEF. AND
IF YOU'RE RENTING. A FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLAR A MONTH. CONDO
DO YOU EED THE RELIEF BECAUSE
YOU PROBABLY HAVE MONEY
SOMEWHERE ELSE YOU MAY NOT BE
MAKING IT TODAY BUT YOU'VE GOT
SOME KIND OF ASSETS AND
RESOURCES. BUT MAYBE THAT SEVEN
MAYBE SO THE NUMBER THE NUMBERS
BECOME REALLY IMPORTANT AND I.
I EXPECT I'M- I'M AN OPTIMIST
BUT I. IN TERMS OF WHEN I LOOK
AT NUMBERS. I AM VERY A REALIST
AND I DON'T THINK YOUR NUMBER
IS VERY FAR OFF IT PUT COULD
POTENTIALLY COST IS THAT DOWN
THE ROAD. AND A LOT OF THINGS.
IT DEPENDS ON HOW LONG WE LEAVE
THE WINDOW OPEN THE DATE IS
BLANK RIGHT NW. BECAUSE WE
WANT TO HAVE THE BEST. MEDICAL
INFORMATION ABOUT WHEN WE THINK
THAT PEOPLE ARE LIKELY TO GO
BACK TO WORK. ON OR THE ECONOMY
TO PICK UP A LITTLE BIT. AND
HELP WHETHER WE SET UP A MEANS
TEST. AND WHAT WE SEE HAPPENING
BECAUSE THE NUMBERS. THE
NUMBERS ARE FLUCTUATING IT'S
NOT IT'S NOT A IT'S NOT A
DOWNWARD TREND AND IT'S GOING
TO AND IT'LL BE IT WILL BE AT
UPSIDE DOWN IT WON'T BE A YOU
IN OTHER WORDS. IT'S PROBABLY
GOING TO BE IN FITS AND STARTS
AND SO OUR NUMBERS ARE ARE- I
THINK THE HIGHEST NUMBER I'VE
SEEN IS TWELVE BILLION DOLLARS
I'M HOPING IT'S LESS THAN THAT
BUT WE GOT TO BE PREPARED FOR
IT BEING SENT TO SUBSTANTIAL.
OKAY YEAH IT'S- I KNOW I'M NOT
SAYING ANYTHING THAT YOU
HAVEN'T ALREADY THOUGHT ABOUT.
BUT OBVIOUSLY TWELVE BILLION
DOLLARS IS THE SUBSTANTIAL
PORTION OF GENERAL FUND
SPENDING VERY MUCH DOWN TO. AT
LEAST FOR THIS FISCAL YEAR AND
NEXT FISCAL YEAR OUR BUDGET IS
YOU KNOW BALANCED IF YOU CAN
CALL A BALANCED. THROUGH USING
THE TOOLS OF SPENDING DEFERRALS
AND BORROWING SO IT'S NOT AS IF
AND WHEN RESERVES. YES USE ME
FOR INTERRUPTING CERTAINLY
AARON RESERVES BUT BUT MY POINT
IS THAT AS WE HOPEFULLY EMERGE
FROM THIS RECESSION WHICH YOU
KNOW PROBABLY FROM AN
EMPLOYMENT STANDPOINT IS NOT
GOING TO BE NEXT YEAR BUT
HOPEFULLY THE YEAR AFTER THAT.
WELL WE ARE STILL GOING TO HAVE
SEVERAL YEARS OF VERY DIFFICULT
BUDGETARY SITUATIONS IN THE
STATE BECAUSE OF THE DEFERRALS
IN THE BORROWING THAT WE'RE
USING TO BALANCE THE BUDGET NOW
AND MEET THIS NEED SO- I
THOUGHT IT WAS INTERESTING THAT
GOVERNOR NEWSOM AND HIS PRESS
CONFERENCE THIS WEEK. TALKED
ABOUT THE ABILITY OF THE STATE
TO USE STATE FUNDING TO PAY
LEAVE- THE STATE'S PORTION OF
THE- THE FEDERAL UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE SUPPLEMENT BECAUSE
THAT'S BEEN AS YOU KNOW A BIG
DEBATE IN CONGRESS OUT OF STONE
THAT. THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT I
MADE AN OFFER THIS LAST
WEEKEND- THROUGH AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER OF- THREE TO ONE MATCH
FOR STATE FUNDING SO OUR AT THE
STATE PUTS HIM HUNDRED DOLLARS
A WEEK AND FOR WHATEVER PURPOSE
IN THREE HUNDRED. AND GOVERNU
SOME SAID FLAT OUT THE STATE
ABSOLUTELY CAN'T AFFORD THAT
BUT INTERESTINGLY THE COST OF
THAT IS ACTUALLY FAR LESS THAN
THE COST OF WHAT YOU ARE
PROPOSING TO DO. SO I THINK
IT'S YOU BE IRRESPONSIBLE FOR
US TO TALK ABOUT THE MERITS. OF
THIS POLICY. WITHOUT AT THE
SAME TIME TALK ABOUT WE'RE
GOING TO PAY FOR IT BECAUSE OF
AN ISSUE NO WE DON'T HAVE THE
OPTION OF OUR OWN WITH THAT
MONEY HAS TO COME FROM
SOMEWHERE. MY GRANDMOTHER
BEFORE SHE PASSED USED TO TELL
ME THAT IF WISHES WERE FISHES
WE DAHLE CASTANETS. AND SO YOU
KNOW IT FORTUNATELY WISHES ARE
FISHES AND SO WE'RE GOING TO
PASS A POLICY LIKE THIS WITH A
SUBSTANTIAL COST I THINK I
THINK WE NEED TO TALK. AT THE
SAME TIME ABOUT WHERE THAT
MONEY COMES FROM THAT'S MY BIG
CONCERN. WITH THIS BILL RIGHT
NOW IS THAT WE'RE NOT HAVING
THAT DISCUSSION. INSTEAD. THANK
YOU THIS ISSUE GREAT THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN AB LET ME FIRST
START BY JUST REALLY THINKING
THE SENATE AUTHORS AND- THE
CENTERS FOR YOUR ENGAGEMENT ON
THIS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT TOPIC
AND- AND IF I COULD BE CLEAR TO
THE PUBLIC WE HAVE AS AS THOSE
OF US WERE AUTHORED BILLS IN
THE SPACE. VERY VERY LITTLE
TIME TO ADDRESS THIS THIS
CRISIS THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL HAD
INITIALLY BEEN LOOKING AT A
DEADLINE OF THIS FRIDAY TO LIFT
THEIR STATEWIDE TEMPERATURE
MORATORIUM- THAT IS HOPEFULLY
GOING TO BE MOVED TO SEPTEMBER
FIRST BUT AT BEST WE HAVE. TWO
AND A HALF WEEKS TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO AVERT A MASSIVE WAVE OF
EVICTIONS WHICH WOULD BE
INCREDIBLY CATASTROPHIC FOR
TENANTS HOMELESSNESS AND
COVERED SPREAD- OF THE
MAGNITUDE I THINK IT'S HARD FOR
ANY OF US TO COMPREHEND SO I
JUST WANNA FIRST THANKED THE
AUTHORS OF SB FOURTEEN TEN FOR
ALL THE WORK AND CREATIVE
THINKING. INTO THIS BILL THIS
IS HARD THIS IS REALLY HARD
AND- I THINK ONE IMPORTANT
ELEMENT FROM YOUR BILL THAT I
APPRECIATE IS THE IDEA THAT IF
THE FEDS ARE NOT GOING TO COME
TO THE RESCUE OF AMERICANS THAT
THE STATE OUGHT TO PUT MONEY
INTO THIS CRISIS I SUPPORT THAT
PREMISE ALL I WILL SAY THAT IF
I HAD TO STRUCTURE PROVIDING
TWELVE BILLION DOLLARS TO THE
PROBLEM I WOULD PROBABLY
SUGGEST. I WOULD I WOULD
PROPOSE DOING IT THROUGH DIRECT
RENTAL SUBSIDIES RATHER THAN
THROUGH TAX BREAKS TO THE
LANDLORD INDUSTRY APPRECIATE
PROKSCH IN AS OUR- CHAIRMAN
ALLUDED TO- HI OF AUTHORED AB
FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX AND ONE
FREESHIP WE HAVE TO TWENTY CO
AUTHORS IN THE BILL INCLUDING
FOR US THIS CAN. WHO THEN ARE
PROPOSES AN UPPER. AGAINST
INFECTIONS AND MORTGAGE FOR
BARRY PROTECTION. FOR PROPERTY
OWNER AND LANDLORDS ARE FOR
CLOSE. AND NOT PERSONALLY.
STRONGLY FEEL THAT THIS. THESE
IDEAS NEED TO BE PART OF AN
OVERALL SOLUTION- I WANT TO
JUST THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR AN
INCREDIBLY IN DEPTH ANALYSIS OF
THIS BILL. I'VE BEEN ON THIS
BILL FROM ITS INCEPTION AND-
JUST TO SUMMARIZE A FEW THE
CHALLENGES THAT BUT I THINK WE
HAVE SEEN- WE HEARD FROM OUR-
BUDGET VICE CHAIR THE PRICE
TAG. TWELVE BILLION DOLLARS AND
COUNTING- AND THE FACT THAT- IT
IT MAY NOT IT MEET THE
IMMEDIATE CRISIS FOR MANY
INDIVIDUALS. YOU ARE WELL AWARE
OF THE CONCERNS RAISED BY SMALL
MOM AND POP LANDLORDS- YOU'VE
HEARD FROM OUR PREPARATIONS
CHAIR ABOUT THE CHALLENGES FOR
IMMIGRANT FAMILIES PARTICULARLY
ARE VERY SIGNIFICANT. AND
STRUGGLING UNDOCUMENTED
COMMUNITY- REYES IN THE
ANALYSIS WERE THE CHALLENGES
AND HOW THIS BILL WOULD
PREVENTIVE ACTIONS. CONDUCTED
BY OTHER MEANS- THE
POSSIBILITIES OF A FRAUD
INVOLVING THIS NEW TAX CREDIT
SYSTEM AND THEN. MANY QUESTIONS
ABOUT HOW THE TAX AUTHORITIES
WILL TREAT THESE CREDITS AND
WHAT THE- FUTURE TAX COURT
MARKET WOULD LOOK LIKE. WE
COULD PROBABLY SPEND A LOT OF
TIME TALKING ABOUT THIS BUT
WHAT I'D LOVE TO DO WE'VE
ALREADY STARTED SOME
CONVERSATIONS IS JUST
UNDERSTAND YOUR RESPONSE TO THE
ISSUES THAT ARE RAISED IN THE
ANALYSIS. I THINK FUNDAMENTALLY
FOR ME. AND WE'VE HEARD THIS
FROM THE TECH COMMUNITY ALL
OVER THE STATE. THE CHALLENGE I
HAVE WITH THIS PROPOSAL IS IT
PUTS THE LANDLORD IN THE DRIVER
SEAT AND THERE ARE STILL. TOO
MANY VOLUNTARY ASPECTS OF THIS
PROPOSAL THAT DON'T PROVIDE
TENANTS. THE PROTECTIONS THAT
THAT I BELIEVE THEY NEED- I'VE
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
PERSPECTIVE OF THE LANDLORD
INDUSTRY PARTICULARLY- THE
LARGER LANDLORDS- PLAYERS BUT
WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT TENANTS.
HOMEOWNERS AND SMALLER PROPERTY
OWNERS ARE GOING TO RECEIVE THE
PROTECTIONS THAT THEY NEED. IF
THIS WERE THE ONLY BILL IN THE
WORKS I WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT IT AS THE SOLE SOLUTION
TO BUILDING CRISIS AND WE HAVE.
BUT I DO THINK THAT THE
APPROACH OF THIS BILL COULD BE
AN IMPORTANT COMPLEMENT FOR
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO- CENTER
I HAVE SPOKEN AND BOTH OF US-
HAVE HAD ALONG WITH OUR
COLLISIONS ON GOING
CONVERSATIONS WITH LEADERSHIP
AND WITH THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE.
AND IF IT'S FAIR TO SAY THAT-
TO GET CENTER AND I THINK IT IS
OUR RESPECTIVE HOPES AND
EXPECTATIONS THAT. THIS BILL
AND A. B. FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX
WILL CONTINUE THROUGH THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. AND
HOPEFULLY SHORTLY THERE WILL BE
A LARGER AGREEMENT BETWEEN OUR
TWO HOUSES AND THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE AND MY PROFOUND HOPE IS
THAT THESE BILLS WLL REFLECT A
BALANCED. COMPREHENSIVE PACKAGE
TO PREVENT COVER TENET PROTECT
EVICTIONS AND ADDRESS THE NEEDS
OF STRUGGLING PROPERTY OWNERS
AND LANDLORS SO- WITH THAT I
DO PLAN TO SUPPORT TODAY-
OBVIOUSLY YOU YOU AND I HAVE A
LOT OF WORK TO DO IN THE NEXT
COUPLE WEEKS BUT- LOOKING FOR
THOSE LATE NIGHTS AND WE HAVE
TO GET THIS DONE SO. SO THANK
YOU FOR THAT. THANK YOU. MR
GALLAGHER. THANK YOU- SO I
APPRECIATE THE AUTHORS- TRYING
TO COME UP WITH A CREATIVE
SOLUTION- TO AN IMPORTANT
ISSUE- BUT I THINK THE
DISSOLUTION THERE'S SOME BIG
PROBLEMS- NUMBER ONE I YOU KNOW
THE EVICTION SUSPENSION IS VERY
BROAD AN INDEFINITE AT THIS
POINT LIKE AT LEAST WITH
JUDICIAL COUNCIL WE HAVE A
CLEAR TIMELINE FOR WHEN THIS
EVICTION SUSPENSION IS GOING TO
BE IN PLACE- WE DON'T HAVE THAT
IN THIS BILL IT'S IT HASN'T
BEEN DEFINED- WE ALSO IS VERY
BROAD I MEAN WHAT ABOUT TENANTS
WHO MAYBE YOU'RE IN A SITUATION
WHERE. A NEIGHBORING TENANT IS
A NUISANCE WE'RE NEED TO WEAR A
OR A LANDLORD WE HAVE SOMEONE
WHO'S IN A SUBSTANTIAL BREACH
OF THE LEAST FOR SOME OTHER
REASON OTHER THAN RENT I MEAN
IT'S CAUSING A PROBLEM FOR THE
COMPLEX AS A WHOLE. THERE WOULD
BE NO NO WAY TO GO FOR WITH AN
ELECTION YOU KNOW AND SO THAT'S
NOT ADDRESS IN HERE SO I THINK
THAT'S A BIG PROBLEM. ALSO WE
GO TO AND WE HEARD IT VERY
CLEARLY SMALL MOM AND POPS.
LANDLORDS HOW IN THE WORLD IS
OF A TAX CREDIT FOR YEARS FROM
NOW. GOING TO HELP THEM PAY
THEIR MORTGAGE TODAY. ANOTHER
THING I THINK IS OFTEN
FORGOTTEN IS A LOT OF THESE
FOLKS ARE ACTUALLY WORKING WITH
TENNIS RIGHT NOW. AND ARE
WORKING THROUGH THIS BECAUSE
NOBODY WANTS TO A BIG SOMEONE
NO WANT TO BE PUT IN THAT IN
THAT SITUATION ANOTHER THE
TENANT OR THE LANDLORD- AND SO
THEY'RE ALREADY WORKING WITH
PEOPLE BUT THEY ALSO HAVE
MORTGAGES. THAT THEY HAVE TO
PAY TODAY AND I'LL TELL YOU
WHO'S NOT GOING TO WAIT
INDEFINITELY- BEFORE FOR
CLOSING AND THAT'S THE BANKS
AND SOME OF ALL ENTIRELY AGREED
TO DO DEFERMENTS. BUT THERE'S
NO MANDATE THAT'S GONNA HAPPEN
NOR DO I THINK THAT THAT WOULD
BE GOOD POLICY. TO DO THAT IN
THE FIRST PLACE BUT YOU'RE
PUTTING THE SMALL MOM AND POPS.
IN A VERY BAD PLACE SO. I JUST
FEEL LIKE THERE'S SOME REALLY
BIG HOLES. IN THE SOLUTION BUT
THE BIGGER PROBLEM IS I THINK
THIS IS KIND OF AVOIDING. THE
GREATER QUESTION. WHICH IS WHY
ARE PEOPLE NOT ABLE TO PAY RENT
RIGHT NOW ONE OF THE BIG
REASONS IS BECAUSE WE TOOK
THEIR JOBS AWAY. AND YOU MIGHT
SAY WELL HEY THAT WAS DOLLARS
FOR SAFETY PURPOSES. GOOD OKAY.
BUT THEN WE FAILED TO PAY THEIR
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE. AND WE
HAVE AN EIGHTY DISS FAILED TO
DO ITS JOB AND MAKE SURE THE
PEOPLE HAVE THE BENEFITS THAT
THEY NEED THAT MAYBE WHAT LET
THEM. PAY RENT THAT'S ONE OF
THE BIGGEST PROBLEMS OF WHY
WE'RE HAVING THIS SITUATION.
AND YES MANY OF US HAVE TALKED
ABOUT THIS BUT THE PROBLEM
HASN'T BEEN FIXED YET. YOU
KNOW. THE OTHER PROBLEM IS HIGH
COST OF LIVING RIGHT KILEY HIGH
COST OF RENTS AND HOUSING WE
COULD DO SOMETHING ABOUT THAT.
BY PASSING LEGISLATION WHICH
WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO DO FOR
YEARS TO REFORM SEQUEL. MISTER
YOU'RE GETTING A RATHER BIT OFF
TOPIC I WAS VERY MUCH ON TOP OF
MR CHAIRMAN THAT'S EXPOSITORY
AND IT'S NOT THESE ARE NOT
ISSUES BEING ADDRESSED BY THIS
BILL. THOSE ARE POLICIES THAT
YOU'RE WELCOME TO. INTRODUCE
YOUR OWN BILLS AND EXPOSE
DISCUSS SO THAT YOU WANT BY THE
DENTIST AND THEY'RE RELEVANT TO
THIS TOPIC AND I'M A MEMBER OF
THIS LEGISLATURE AND I WILL
GIVE THE REASONS FOR WHY. I
SUPPORTER DON'T SUPPORT THIS
POLICY IN THIS BILL THAT IS
BEFORE US. AND WHAT I'M SAYING
IS IT DOESN'T ADDRESS THE
UNDERLYING PROBLEM OF A LACK OF
HOUSING WE'VE LIMITED OUR
HOUSING WE'RE NOT WE'RE NOT
KEEPING UP AND THAT'S WHY RENTS
ARE SO HIGH. THAT'S WHY COST OF
HOUSING IS SO HIGH BECAUSE THIS
LEGISLATORS REFUSED TO DO
ANYTHING ABOUT IT. WE'VE ALSO
ADDED TO THE HIGH COST OF
LIVING AND I KNOW THE GOOD
SENATOR. HAS TALKED ABOUT THIS
IN HER DISTRICT BECAUSE THE
POLICIES THAT WE PASS. THROUGH
THIS LEGISLATURE ARE WHAT IS
DRIVING UP THE COST OF
ELECTRICITY FOR EXAMPLE. IN HIS
WAS DRIVING UP THE COST OF GAS
TO GET. TO A JOB YOU DON'T HAVE
ANYMORE UNFORTUNATELY- SO. ALL
THESE THINGS WE KIND OF AVOID
TALKING ABOUT IT BECAUSE IT
WOULD MEAN THAT THE MAJORITY
PARTY WOULD HAVE TO OWN UP. TO
THE POLICY MISTAKES THAT THEY
HAVE MADE. THAT HAVE LED TO
THIS ISSUE. YOU KNOW INSTEAD WE
WANT TO PASS THE BUCK AWESOME
UP SOMEHOW AND LANDLORDS
THEY'RE STRUGGLING JUST AS MUCH
AS EVERYBODY ELSE. DURING THIS
PANDEMIC. YOU KNOW AND SO TO ME
I JUST THINK THAT WE'RE MISSING
THE BIGGER POINT HERE WE'RE
MISSING THE BIG THE LARGER
POINT IS A CALIFORNIA. HAS
CREATED A LOT OF PROBLEMS WITH
PEOPLE WITH BAD POLICIES AND
BAD GOVERNMENT. AND SO THAT'S
WHY I CAN'T SUPPORT THIS TODAY.
AND I REALLY THINK WE SHOULD BE
FOCUSING ON THOSE THINGS I JUST
TALKED ABOUT LET'S HONE IN ON
THOSE THINGS AND MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE ARE CORRECTED. AND
THEY'LL DO A WHOLE LOT MORE TO
HELP TENANTS AND EVERYBODY. IN
THE STATE AS ARE MOVING THROUGH
THIS VERY TOUGH- AND TUMULTUOUS
TIMES THANK YOU. IS THE MOST.
THANK YOU. SO FIRST I ACTUALLY
WANT TO THINK AND THE AUTHOR IN
AUTHORS- FOR BRINGING THIS TO
OUR ATTENTION THIS IS A
CRITICAL CONVERSATION- IN OUR
STATE AND WE DO HAVE A LOOMING
EVICTION CRISIS IN OUR STATE. I
CERTAINLY WE CAN SPEND A LOT OF
TIME LOOKING AT ROOT CAUSES-
BUT WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH THE
SITUATION THAT IS IN FRONT OF
US- AND I THINK IT'S A- VERY
THE HOUSING CRISIS NO DOUBT. IS
AMONG THE MOST IMPORTANT ISSUES
THAT WE WERE ADDRESSING PRIOR
TO COBIT. AND CERTAINLY DURING
THE WHOLE OF IT- I THINK THAT.
MOST OF US AGREE THAT THE
PROBLEM- THIS IS A PROBLEM THAT
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED IN THE
LEGISLATURE. AT AND I A THINK
THAT THAT'S- A DIFFICULT
CONVERSATION YOU'VE BEEN
ENGAGED IN LEADING- A DIFFICULT
CONVERSATION BUT THEY- THEY
NEED TO HAPPEN- FOR THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA. AND I KNOW THAT
TO THIS IS ONE OF A YOU KNOW
DIFFERENT APPROACHES THAT ARE
THAT ARE THAT. ARE PART IN
DIFFERENT DISCUSSIONS AT THIS
PARTICULAR MOMENT. I THINK I
WANT TO ECHO JUST A COUPLE
THINGS THAT SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES- HAVE ECHOED. WHICH
IS AT FIRST THE ISSUE RELATED
TO- ELIGIBILITY FOR
UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIANS- I
THINK THAT YOU KNOW AS A MEMBER
OF THE LATINO CAUCUS WE'VE
TALKED SO MUCH AT LENGTH ABOUT
THE DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT ON
KOBE IT. NOT JUST ON THE HEALTH
SIDE ON THE EDUCATION SIDE ON
THE HOUSING SIDE. ON EVERY
SIDE- AND- I THINK IT'S
SOMETHING THAT CONTINUES. TO BE
AN ISSUE FOR ME AND I THINK
THAT IT'S IMPORTANT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT. WE HAVE TO TRY
TO FIND A WAY. TO HELP ALL
MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY AND
PERHAPS THIS IS A PART OF A
BIGGER SOLUTION RIGHT- THAT. IN
TERMS OF WHERE WE END UP ON ON
THE HOUSING ISSUE- BUT
CERTAINLY. AG IT MAKES ME AT
YOUKNOW CRINGE TO THINK THAT
WE COULD LEAVE ANYONE WHO CAN'T
PROVIDE AND I TENER SOCIAL
SECURITY OUT. OF A SOLUTION
WHEN THEY ARE ARE ESSENTIAL
WORKERS WHERE THEY ARE. THE
PEOPLE THAT WE NEED. TO BE ON
THE FRONT LINES BUT WE CAN'T
FIND A WAY TO PROTECT THEM SO.
I IN YOU ARE DEVOTED RESTING.
THINKING ABOUT IT. I'M AT THE
THAT'S DEFINITELY ONE OF THE
CONCERN THAT THAT I HAVE. AND
THE OTHER IS RELATED TO. THE
ADMINISTRATION OF TAX CREDIT
SYSTEM. I THINK THE ANALYSIS
FROM THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD
RAISE SOME SERIOUS CONCERNS
ABOUT IMPLEMENTATION. AND
WHETHER OR NOT- THERE WOULD BE
A LOT OF. WHETHER OR NOT THIS
CAN ACTUALLY BE IMPLEMENTED. I
THINK THE SYSTEM- OF LANDLORDS
AND GREEN TO THE F. T. B. AND
IF TO BE TRACKING TAX CREDITS-
IS. IN RESOURCE INTENSIVE
SYSTEM. AND CERTAINLY I EXPECT
THAT THAT WOULD REQUIRE A
SIGNIFICANT IT SYSTEM OVERHAUL
TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT. AT
TRACKING AND- YOU KNOW I'M
CONCERNED THAT. THE FRANCHISE
TAX BOARD HAS ALREADY SAID THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE
DIFFICULTIES THAT THEY'RE GOING
TO IT DOES IT DOES CONCERNS.
AND WHETHER OR NOT WE CAN DO
THIS RIGHT AT THIS PARTICULAR
TIME CREATE BUT I KNOW AGAIN
THAT THAT'S BEING ADDRESSED-
AND EVEN I THINK. AS WE LOOK AT
THESE TWO ISSUES- JUST YOU KNOW
THE OVERALL. ISSUES OF WHETHER
OR NOT WE WILL HAVE AT
LANDLORDS- WORK WITH THEIR
TENANTS IN GOOD FAITH OR WILL
YOU KNOW THIS RESORT TO SOME
OTHER TYPES OF TACTICS THAT CAN
SCARE. TENANTS FROM MOVING OUT-
I KNOW THAT. THIS IS AGAIN ONE
APPROACH I WANT TO JUST
HIGHLIGHT THAT ACCORDING TO OUR
LAST CENSUS 55% OF CALIFORNIANS
LIVED IN A HOME THAT THE
ACTUALLY OWNED- AND- THAT IS A
DIFFERENT TYPE OF STREAM. AND
THIS PARTICULAR SOLUTION
DOESN'T SOLVE FOR THAT BUT I DO
HOPE THAT THE CONVERSATIONS AT
THE STATEWIDE LEVEL ALSO
ACCOUNT FOR THE 55% OF
CALIFORNIANS. THAT ARE NOT
RENTING- BUT THAT LIVE IN A
HOME AND I THINK IT'S BEEN
ALLUDED TO- YOU KNOW WHAT WOULD
BE THE ROLE OF THE STATE IN
TERMS OF MORTGAGES. AND WHAT
KINDS OF ROLES AND THAT'S NOT
THIS PARTICULAR BILL BUT IT IS
PART OF A COMPREHENSIVE
SOLUTION SO I THINK MY
COMMENTS- ARE. ARE DEFINITELY
OF. RECOGNIZING THIS IS ONE
PART OF THE SOLUTION IT'S A
DIFFICULT ONE I. BELIEVE WE
THINK THIS. IS A SECONDING YOU
HAPPEN. I'M NOT BILL. BUT I
THAT WE CAN WORK THROUGH SOME
OF THE THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED
BY COLLEAGUES WE WILL TO GET
THIS RIGHT AND I KNOW YOU DO
TOO AS WELL SO THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU HERE COMES. THIS
PRESS. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
SENATOR THANK YOU FOR BRING IN
THE BILL THIS IS SUCH A SERIOUS
SERIOUS ISSUE AND I THINK WHAT
I APPRECIATE THE MOST IS THE
FACT THAT WE HAVE THE
ADMINISTRATION THE SUMMIT IN
THE ASSEMBLY. ABSOLUTELY
WORKING TOGETHER TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE FIND A SOLUTION WE
CANNOT LEAVE AT THE END OF
SEPTEMBER OR THE END OF AUGUST
WITHOUT HAVING FOUND A SOLUTION
SO THE FACT THAT WE HAVE SO
MANY ON BOTH IN BOTH HOUSES
PLUS THE ADMINISTRATION WORKING
TO FIND THE BEST SOLUTION MEET
NONE OF WHAT I HAVE READ IS THE
PERFECT SOLUTION NOT HERE NOT
IN ANY OTHER PROPOSAL. BUT I
THINK THAT THE FACT THAT SO
MANY PEOPLE ARE WORKING ON THIS
REMINDS US THAT THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE HERE FOR. I APPRECIATE SO
MUCH THAT. WE NEED A HOUSE IS
JUST COMPLAINING IT'S SO EASY
TO COMPLAIN AND TO COMPLAIN AT
THE PONTIFICATE ABOUT THE
ISSUES. IT IS MORE DIFFICULT TO
ACTUALLY SPEND THE TIME TO WORK
ON THE SOLUTION. THAT'S WHAT
YOU'RE DOING THAT'S WHAT THE
ASSEMBLY IS DOING WITH THE AB
FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX AS WELL. I
WANT TO ECHO THE COMMENTS THAT
HAVE BEEN MADE AND I KNOW THAT
YOU AS A MEMBER OF THE LATINO
CAUCUS HAVE ALSO CONSIDERED
THIS. WE HAVE GOT TO FIND A WAY
TO MAKE SURE THAT AE
UNDOCUMENTED. RESIDENTS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA FIND
PROTECTION AS TENANTS AS WELL.
WE PRAISE THEM AS HEROES
BECAUSE THERE ARE FRONT LINE
WORKERS ESSENTIAL WORKERS WE DO
EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN TO
UPLIFT THEM. BECAUSE THEY'RE
PUTTING THEIR LIFE ON THE LINE
AND GET WHEN WE'RE LOOKING FOR
SOLUTIONS TO SOMETHING THAT IS.
MOVING THESE EVICTIONS THAT ARE
COMING OUR WAY WE'VE GOT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE
INCLUDED. I APPRECIATE VERY
MUCH THAT EVERY SOLUTION THAT-IS BEING LOOKED AT IS WHAT IS
CONSIDERING PROTECTING THE
TENANTS WHICH WE ABSOLUTELY
HAVE TO OTHERWISE WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE TO DEAL WITH IT. WITH
THE INCREASED HOMELESSNESS.
THIS IS THE BEST WAY IS TO MAKE
SURE WE KEEP PEOPLE IN THEIR
HOMES AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE. BUT
I ALSO APPRECIATE THAT WE'RE
NOT FORGETTING THE LANDLORDS.
THE VIRUS THAT IS AFFECTING ALL
OF US. SHOULD NOT BE THAT THE
COST OF IT SHOULD NOT BE BORNE
BY LANDLORDS MANY OF WHOM HAVE
INVESTED THEIR LIFE SAVINGS TO
PURCHASE THESE RENTALS- THEY
SHOULD NOT BE THE ONES THAT
HAVE TO SUFFER THE MOST. THE
STATE NEEDS TO TAKE CARE OF
THEM. AND SO I APPRECIATE THAT
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT IS BEING
CONSIDERED IN IN ALL OF THESE
PROPOSALS IT HAS TO BE-
LANDLORDS ARE NOT RESPONSIBLE
FOR ALL OF THE- FOR ALL ALL OF
THE DEALS THAT ARE HAPPENING.
IN CALIFORNIA- SO AGAIN I JUST
I WANT TO THANK YOU AND ALL OF
THE OTHERS- MY COLLEAGUES AS
WELL ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOOSE
SIMPLY MEMBERS LIMóN AND THE
OTHERS. WHO ARE WORKING ON
SOLUTIONS- THANK YOU IT'S THE
HARD WORK THAT IN THE END IS
GOING TO PROVIDE THE PROTECTION
THAT CALIFORNIANS NEED. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT SENATOR YOU MAY
CLOSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH- LET
ME. JUST SAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE- FOR THE DIALOGUE
AND THE EXPRESSED CONCERNS
WE'VE TAKEN COPIOUS NOTES ON
ALL OF THIS. THIS TICKET AND
YOU CAN KEEP YOUR COMMENTS-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IS REALLY THE
BEST WAY TO END IT IS THIS IS A
REALLY COMPLICATED ISSUE AND
PART OF THE CHALLENGE IS THAT
YOU KNOW WE'RE TRYING TO GET
GOOD DATA- IN TERMS OF WHAT'S
REALLY HAPPENING ON THE GROUND
IN A LOT OF THE DATA COMES TO
US FROM. NATIONAL ORGANIZATIONS
BUT THE- THE INFORMATION SHOWS
THAT PEOPLE HAVE BEEN PAYING
PART OF THE RENT IT'S NOT THAT
THEY PAY THE RENT AT ALL IT'S
THAT THEY'RE MAKING PAYMENTS ON
IT AND- AND WHAT WHAT'S
COMPLICATED ABOUT THAT IS YOU
DON'T WANT TO SET UP A SYSTEM
WHERE PEOPLE CAN JUST WALK AWAY
NOT TO PAY RENT ANYMORE IF YOU
WANT THEM TO WORKING COOPERATE
WITH THE LANDLORD BECAUSE
THAT'S HOW THE LANDLORD. IS
MAKING THOSE PAYMENTS RIGHT THE
MORTGAGE PAYMENTS ESPECIALLY
THE MOM AND POP LANDLORDS AND
THERE ARE MORE THAN WE REALIZE-
YEAH AND SO WHAT WHAT THE DATA
SHOWS IN APRIL 24% OF THAT THE
TENANTS. FAILED TO PAY ON TIME
4% MADE NO PAYMENTS 212% MADE
PARTIAL PAYMENTS AND THAT SO
THAT'S PRETTY GOOD. 30% 31%
THEY ENTER 1% IN JUNE AND-
WE'RE REALLY TRYING. AND WE TO
REWARD THAT IT WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE- DISTANCE.
ICING THEM WORK TRYING TO WORK
THINGS OUT WITH THEIR WITH
THEIR LANDLORDS SO. LET ME DO
THAT LET ME JUST WRAP UP BY
SAYING- THE GOVERNOR THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE HAS BEEN VERY
CLEAR THAT AN FTP SOLUTION IS
DIFFICULT BECAUSE IT. IT STARTS
TO SET UP THIS BIG BUREAUCRACY
AND IN REALITY. THE CHALLENGE
BECOMES AS WE LOOK AT THIS
ISSUE. IS WHO WHERE DOES THE
MONEY COME FROM. READ BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY THAT THAT THE PURPOSE
OF THIS BILL IS TO KEEP TENANTS
IN THEIR CURRENT RESIDENCES SO
THAT THEY'RE NOT ON THE STREETS
AND FOR NON PAYMENT OF RENT
NUMBER TWO THAT TO HELP.
LANDLORDS MAKE THEIR MORTGAGE
PAYMENTS SO THAT WE DON'T END
UP WITH THE WHOLE RUSSIA OF
MORTGAGE DEFAULTS BECAUSE THAT
DOESN'T HELP US EITHER BECAUSE
QUITE FRANKLY IT'S REALLY EASY
TO GET RID OF A TENANT IF THIS
IF THE- THE UNIT HAS SOLD IT
BECOMES A LOT EASIER- AS A
GENERAL RULE. AND SO WE WANT TO
KEEP. LANDLORDS HOLE. AND WE
WANT TO PROTECT THE FISC OF THE
STATE WE DON'T WANT TO SET UP
THIS HUGE LIABILITY SO THAT WE-
WE THEN HAVE TO GO TURN AROUND
AND FIGURE OUT WHAT. BUT WHAT
RESOURCES WERE CUTTING FROM OUR
STATE BUDGET BECAUSE WE'VE
ASSUMED A HUGE RESPONSIBILITY
SO THAT WAS PART OF THE REASON
WITH WITH DOING A TAX CREDIT IS
TO PUSH. SOME OF THE STATE
LIGHT BURKE THE STATE IN
GAUGING IN THIS PROCESS
LIABILITY DOWN. DOWN THE ROAD
AND GIVE US A CHANCE TO RECOVER
A LITTLE BIT SO. SO AS AS WE O
THROUGH THIS WE WANT TO MAKE IT
A SIMPLE PROCESS AND OBVIOUSLY
THIS IS NOT A SIMPLE PROCESS-
BUT IT WAS ONE OF THE WAYS FOR
US TO FIGURE OUT. HOW TO WEEK
BE ABLE TO CREATE A COMMITMENT.
TO KEEP PEOPLE IN THEIR IN THE
RESIDENCE IS INSTALLED IT TOO I
SYSTEM. TENANTS AS WELL I THINK
ONE OF THE THINGS WE'VE WE'VE
WE'VE FOUND IS THAT THE TAX
CREDIT SYSTEM IS- IS DIFFICULT
WITH A LOT OF TIME YOU CAN SET
UP THE INFRASTRUCTURE RIGHT. WE
DON'T HAVE A LOT OF TIME WE'RE
TRYING TO DO THIS KIND OF AS
WERE. THE TWO THAT BUTTON THAT.
IS BEING BUILT AS AS YOU KNOW
WERE CRASHING OR SOMETHING I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE ANALOGY IS
BUT ANYWAY IN ANY CASE- WE'RE
ALL WORKING. ON THIS. KATE ALL
THE- WE WANT TO GET THIS RIGHT
AND WE WANT TO GET A RIDE SO
THAT PEOPLE. AS WE DEAL WITH
THIS CORONA VIRUS ANDEMIC
WHERE THERE IS SO MUCH UNKNOWN
OUT THERE THAT THERE'S SOME
SOME KNOWN THAT THEY CAN STAY
IN THEIR PLACES. THEY DON'T
HAVE TO WORRY AND WE THEY CAN
SHELTER IN PLACE AND THEY HAVE
THE SHELTER SO. APPRECIATE ALL
YOUR COMMENTS AND KNOW THAT
WE'RE WORKING HARD AND I'M
GONNA BE WORKING- ALONG SIDE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE GET IT RIGHT WITH TE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND- MY
COMMITMENT TO YOU IS TO TAKE
CARE OF- BOB WHAT LET ME JUST
SAY THAT. THAT I THINK PART OF
THE CHALLENGE IT MANAGING
EXPECTATIONS. BECAUSE THIS BILL
WILL NOT SOLVE ALL THE DEALS
THAT WE HAVE AROUND HOUSING
AND- AFFORDABILITY AND ALL THAT
OTHER STUFF AT THE SAME TIME.
AND SO- THAT I THINK THE CLOSER
WE GET TO BEING ABLE TO ACHIEVE
THE GOALS I THINK THAT. THAT WE
ALL HAD WHEN WE STARTED THIS
PROCESS- IT'S- THE BETTER WILL
BE SO I GET RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY TO KEEP
THE PROCESS MOVING. AND MY
COMMITMENT TO YOU IS THAT I'M
IN A- WE'RE GOING TO WE'RE
GOING TO GET THIS RIGHT I AM
AND WILL WILL DO IT WITH THE
COOPERATION THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE THE ASSEMBLY AND THIS.
THANK SAID BRADFORD DID YOU.
WANT UP I'LL BE BRIEF I JUST
WANNA OF COLD MUCH OF WHAT IS
BEEN SAID BUT I THINK THAT
THERE'S- ANY TAKEAWAY THAT WE
CANNOT LEAVE HERE WITH THE
DATE. WE'RE ALL COMMITTED TO
THIS ISSUE. AND WHEN WE STARTED
WORKING ON THIS- MEASURE FIVE
MONTHS AGO. LANDLORDS WORD. AT
THE CENTER OF THIS DISCUSSION
JUST AS MUCH AS TENANTS.
BECAUSE WE UNDERSTAND. MANY OF
THOSE SMALL LANDLORDS. ARE SOME
MORE MEMBERS OF THIS
INSTITUTION AS WELL. MANY OF
THE MOM AND POP LANDLORDS ARE
MEMBERS OF THIS INSTITUTION.
MANY OF WHOM LIVE IT
CONVERSATIONS WITH AND- THEY'VE
EXPRESSED THEIR CONCERNS ABOUT
WHAT IT TAX CREDIT. MEANS TO ME
TODAY ONE I HAVE TO PAY MY
MORTGAGE. AND SO WORKING ON
THAT WE UNDERSTAND WE SAT DOWN
WITH THE FRANCHISE THAT. WE SEE
DOWN WITH BREAKING IT AND
INDUSTRY WEALTH THE SEE HOW WE
CAN MAKE THIS. MONETIZE THEM
AND MAKE A WE SAT DOWN WITH TO
TREASURE. ALSO TO SEE IF THERE
WAS SOME SECURITIZATION THAT
WOULD BE USED. AND THESE TAX
CREDITS WE'VE LOOKED AT ALL
THESE THINGS IS IT PERFECT NOW.
AND SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT ARE
ASSUMING GALLAGHER MENTIONED
THAT HAS IMPEDED US FROM
BUILDING FORMA HOUSING BILLS
ARE TRUE WE DO NEED TO BUILD
MORE INFRASTRUCTURE BUT AGAIN
THIS IS NOT WHAT THIS BILL IS
ABOUT. BUT SOME OF THOSE THINGS
ARE NIMBYISM ALSO IF MANY
MEMBERS IN THEIR DISTRICT DON'T
WANT TO FOR AWHILE THEN IT AND
THERE DISTRICTS SO THAT ADDS TO
THE PROBLEM AS WELL. SO I THINK
WE CAN AWAY FROM ANYTHING ARE
OFTEN. THE GOVERNOR'S
COMMITMENT. WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS
MEASURE. I'LL JUST LEAVE YOU. I
LOGIC CUMMINGS. STATED AND HE
SAYS THE BILL NOTHING ISN'T
NOTHING. THAT'S WE FIND
OURSELVES TODAY MEMBERS WE
CANNOT AFFORD TO DO NOTHING I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR UNCLE.
THANK YOU LOOKING FOR A MOTION
MOTION IS SOME OF THANK YOU WE
DO HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
THE MOTION IS TO PASS. TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CULTURAL
PLEASE. STONE HI STONE AYE
GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER NO SHOW.
CHIU HI CHIU HI GOOD. HOLDEN
KALRA. HI EARLY NO AMONG I LOAN
I OVER. OBERNOLTE NO REYES FIVE
RAILS I. THAT HAS FOUR VOTES
THANK YOU WILL THE BILL ON CALL
MEMBERS. SENATOR US ALL RIGHT
I'M NUMBER WE IS SENATE BILL
ELEVEN. OPERATOR FOR WHO LIKE
TO CALL IN THIS TO BE A TIME
CALL A ON SENATE BILL ELEVEN
NINE. IF YOU WANT TO. TESTIFY
OR SUPPORTER OPPOSE. SENATE
BILL ELEVEN NINE. SO WE WILL
START THE WITH THE OPENING
STATEMENT SENATOR MAY BEGIN.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE IN
THIS OF THINGS AND- BECAUSE
THIS PREVIOUS THAT YOU'RE
LISTENING THIS. ALMOST SMALL
VERSION OF BUT OF VERY PART OF
WHAT MANY FAMILIES ARE GOING
THROUGH I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR
COMPREHENSIVE. GIVEN THE
ECONOMIC HARDSHIPS AND THE
PUBLIC HEALTH DANGERS CAUSED BY
GROUP IN NINETEEN THE STATE-
SHOULD FOCUS ON KEEPING
CALIFORNIANS IN THE HOME BUT IN
A SAFE HOME. I AM PROPOSING TO
AND STABILIZATION PROVISIONS
FOR TENANTS EXPERIENCING THE
MOST VULNERABLE CIRCUMSTANCES
THAT IS BEING A BIT OF A
VIOLENT CRIME. UNFORTUNATELY WE
KNOW THAT NOT EVERY HOME IS
SAFE THE WORLD HAS SEEN HOW THE
COOPER NINETEEN TERM PLACE
PROTECT HAVE LED TO AN INCRESE
IN INTERPERSONAL VIOLENCE
VICTIMS AY LIVE WITH OR LIVE
NEAR THEIR PERPETRATORS. FOR
THE MORE. LOW YOUNG. AT THE
MUSICAL BEAR THE- OF. XP DURING
A TIME OF EXACERBATED FINANCIAL
AND HOUSING AND SECURITY. AND
INCREASE VULNERABILITY FOR MANY
VICTIMS OF VIOLENCE THESE
PROTECTIONS ARE MORE URGENT NOW
THAN EVER.CALIFORNIA LAW
INSURERS TODAY THE VICTIMS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SEXUAL
ASSAULT. STALKING HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AND ABUSE OF AN
ELDER OR DEPENDENT ADULT AND
FAMILY MEMBERS. FOR THEIR
HOUSEHOLD CAN TERMINATE A LEASE
WITHOUT PENALTY FOLLOWING THE
VICTIMIZATION. SB ELEVEN NINETY
WOULD EXPAND THESE TENANT-
THESE EXISTING TENNIS
STABILIZATION PROTECTIONS. TO
VICTIMS OF VIOLENT CRIMES LIKE
VICTIMS OF GUN VIOLENCE ARMED
HOME INVASION OR CALL VICTIMS
OF HOMICIDE. VICTIMS OF VIOLENT
CRIMES AND THEIR FAMILIES
HOUSEHOLD MEMBERS CAN TERMINATE
AND- WITHOUT T. WITHIN A
HUNDRED DAYS FOLLOW THE CRIME.
SB ELEVEN NINETY WILL ENSURE
THAT LAND DID NOT DISCLOSE
AGAINST TENANTS. BY REFUSING TO
RENT TO TENANTS. FOR BREAKING
THE LEASE SUBJECT TO RIGHTS THE
BILL ALSO EXPANDS APPROVAL TO
IMMEDIATE FAMILY MEMBERS
OUTSIDE OF THE HOUSEHOLD. THIS
IS IMPORTANT FOR URGENT
SITUATIONS LIKE WHEN THE VICTIM
IS SEVERELY INJURED AND NEEDS
ROUND THE CLOCK CARE FOR AN
EXTENDED PERIOD AND AN
IMMEDIATE FAMILY MEMBER MUST
RELOCATE TO PROVIDE THE VICTIM
WITH CARE. ANOTHER EXAMPLE IS
WHEN ATTENDING CAN NO LONGER
AFFORD THE RENT AFTER PAYING
FOR FUNERAL OR BURIAL EXPENSES
OF A FAMILY MEMBER WHO IS A
HOMICIDE VICTIM. I WANT TO BE
CLEAR THIS TENNIS STABILIZATION
PROVISION HAS IT EXISTING
RIGOROUS CERTIFICATION AND
DOCUMENTED DOCUMENTATION
PROCESS. THE TENANT MUST
PROVIDE THIRD PARTY VERIFIED
DOCUMENTATION TO THE LANDLORD
WITHIN A HUNDRED EIGHTY DAYS
FOLLOWING THE CRIME THIS COULD
BE A RESTRAINING ORDER POLICE
REPORT- MEDICAL REPORT. ARE YOU
TO SUPPORT THE HOUSING SECURITY
OF TENANTS IT'S RAISING THE
MOST VULNERABLE CIRCUMSTANCES
WITH THE NEWEST SET OF
AMENDMENTS THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION HAS
REMOVED ITS OPPOSITION AND NOW
HAS A NEUTRAL POSITION. FOR
THESE REASONS I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY BRING SB ELEVEN
NINETY BEFORE YOU I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. UP
MY WITNESSES TODAY AREN'T MISSY
REYES MY LETTER AND RESUME.
FROM CRIMES WERE FOR SAY AND
ESTAS AND I WILL HAVE A- CANCER.
HUNDRED FROM CALIFORNIA FOR
SAFE AND JUST. THANK YOU WE DO
HAVE A- AND A- SO I'M TOLD
MISTY RAIN THERE MAY NOT BE
WITH US. THE YOU'RE A REGULAR
ARE YOU ON THE LINE. K. MISTER.
SORRY. SOMETHING I SAID MUST
HAVE. HER A LOT I LUIS MORA ARE
YOU A THE LINE. GOOD MORNING
GOOD MORNING. PLEASE PROCEED
YES- YES YES HOPING EVERYBODY
YOUR TIME AND I JUST WANT TO
THE OVERALL IN OF THESE
BUILDING AND WHAT YOU KNOW
STANDS TO BE. HERE IT IS AS
WELL AS WHAT'S THE TO BE A PART
OF NOT PASSED AND SO OBVIOUSLY
YOU KNOW WHEN ARE GOING. COME
SUCH YOU KNOW IS THIS BILL
WOULD OPEN A THAT KIND OF
WAIVER FOR OTHER PEOPLE TO BE
ABLE TO ACCESS RESOURCES THAT
WERE ONLY KIND OF LIMITED TO
CERTAIN SURVIVORS OF CERTAIN
CRIMES YES SO WHEN YOU OPEN
THAT UP TO FOCUS WHILE STILL
YOU KNOW PROVIDING
DOCUMENTATION WHICH I'M VERY
GLAD WAS MENTIONED IT ALLOWS
PEOPLE TO YOU KNOW TO HOPEFULLY
CIRCUMVENT AN ADDITIONAL CYCLE
OF TRAUMA FROM CONTINUING
BECAUSE- IT'S ALREADY A
DRAMATIC SITUATION TO BE IN
WANT ONE SOMEBODY A VICTIM. OR
A SURVIVOR PRIME AND THEN YOU
ADD ON THE ADDITION YOU KNOW
OUR STREETS THAT A LONG WAY
THAT WHAT THEY'RE THE HOUSE IS
TO BE OR IT'S- THE ECONOMIC YOU
KNOW ARE ALREADY IN IN A LOT OF
WORK TO ARE ONLY GOING TO EXACT
IF YOU KNOW IF NOT A I'LL TO.
BREAK OUT OF THEIR FOR THEIR
SAFETY RIGHT IT'S LIKE IT'S BE
PROMOTED AS JUST LIKE A OF SAVE
GOING ALONG WANT TO YOUR RENT
AMIDA SOMETHING THAT IS MAY TO
AND YOU DON'T PROVIDE A SAFETY
NET FOR THAT ARE OVER DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH NET YOU KNOW WHICH
WHICH IS YOU KNOW OUR
COMMUNITIES ALL ARE IN THAT
NEED OF A RESTORE. AND SO I TO
THE NINE BE THREE. ARE TO BE EX
IT SO CRIME OF ALL CRIMES AS
OPPOSED TO WHAT THEY WERE TO. A
WE ARE YOU KNOW WILL AND NOW
LEAN ON. ALLOWING USED CYCLES
OF YOU KNOW STRAIGHT AND TRAUMA
TO CONTINUE ENACT ALSO TO A
PATTERN OF. CRIME BEHAVE. URGE
LOWS THAT CAN MAKE THESE
DECISIONS CHIU TO CHOOSE OUR TO
PASS THIS BILL BECAUSE AGAIN
YOU'LL HAVE THE INFORMATION IN
FRONT OF YOU THERE'S ALREADY
ALREADY IN THE GREGIS AMOUNT OF
MONEY THAT SPENT ON THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM AND-
YOU KNOW IT'S JUST SOME OF
THOSE MONIES OR OR THE MONEY
THAT CAN BE REDIRECTED
SUPPORTING SURVIVORS ARE DONE
SO- BIG STAND IN THE LONG RUN-
TO CIRCUMVENT OR CURTAIL THIS
OP PATTERN OF CRIME AND
HOPEFULLY IT'LL CONTINUE AND-
HEALTHY YOU KNOW CYCLE OF
INTERGENERATIONAL- HEALING. AS
WELL SO- WITHOUT AYE AYE I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND.
AND THAT CONCLUDES MY PORTION.
THANK YOU AND I UNDERSTAND WE
ALSO HAVE. UNTIL ON THE LINE
FOR TECHNICAL QUESTIONS IS THAT
TRUE THAT'S TRUE THANK YOU OKAY.
ALL RIGHT- THAT IS THERE WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO THE WITNESS
VIDEO ROOM REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATIONS AS ANYONE IN THE-
WITNESS VIDEO ROOM WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
REGISTER YOUR SUPPORT FOR SB.
ELEVEN NINETY. SEEING NONE
ANYONE OF THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION. SEEING NONE. ANYONE ON
THE TELEPHONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
GIVE US YOUR NAME YOUR
ASSOCIATION AND THAT YOU
SUPPORT SB ELEVEN NINETY
OPERATOR COULD YOU GIVE
INSTRUCTIONS PLEASE. THANK YOU
IF YOU'D LIKE TO SHOW YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL ME PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO USING YOUR
TELEPHONE. THAT ONE THEN ZERO
WE DO HAVE SEVERAL IN Q.
ALREADY. WILL GO FIRST TO LINE
TWENTY TWO TWO TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS GREGORY KRAMER ON
BEHALF OF DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
YOU LINE NINETY NINE ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. LINE NINETY NINE
ZERO YOU MAY BE ON MUTE. BOB
BAKKEN GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU LINE NINETY ONE NINE
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GENERAL
AND STAPLETON PUBLIC POLICY
OFFICER ON BEHALF OF THE
HOLLYWOOD CHAPTER OF THE
NATIONAL ORGANIZATION FOR WOMEN
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF S. B.
ELEVEN NINETY. ONE TWENTY ONE
TO ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE
MORNING CARE NUMBERS. RIGHT
HERE I'LL AND I'LL BE HAPPY
WILL COSPONSORED. APPLE
INTERESTED INVESTIGATING CRIMES
ARE NOT AS YOU SAID YOU GOT
THIS PROBLEM SPONSORSHIP. THE
DRIVE THANK YOU. LINE EIGHTY
NINE EIGHT NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU .COM WE OF LOS
ANGELES CITY ATTORNEY MIKE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOUNG. LINE
NINETY THREE NINE THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING THIS
IS GERMAN BURKE ON BEHALF OF
THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION THAT CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK. NINE EIGHTY
SEVEN EIGHT SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MARK MARK MY NAME IS TO
COMMIT TO OUR MATURITY ON
BEHALF OF THE POLITICIANS OUR
LIVES ARE FULL TOMORROW GROUP
FROM SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE
EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING AND
THANK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIPS AND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IN SUPPORT.
LINE NINETY TWO NINE TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING ON A
LAWLER ON BEHALF OF THE WESTERN
PHENOMENON POVERTY AND THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION AND PART.
IF THERE ARE OTHERS YOU MAY
ALSO PRESS ONE ZERO WE'LL GO TO
LINE EIGHTY EIGHT ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HE WE DO HAVE ONE
MORE LINE IN Q. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE.
NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN NINETY FIVE YOU MAY NOT
HAVE BEEN PROVIDED YOUR LINE.
ONE MOMENT NINETY FIVE YOU CAN
IN OUR LINE NUMBER. NINETY FIVE
MAIN ST POSITION. GOOD MORNING-
IT IS THE TIME TO ASK QUESTIONS
ABOUT THIS BILL OR NO IT'S NO
IT'S NOT THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY
TO IDENTIFY YOURSELF YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND SAY THAT YOU
SUPPORT THE BILL. OKAY I I'M
NOT WITH AN ORGANIZATION I'M A
PROPERTY OWNER- WHEN WE ASK
QUESTIONS- YOU'RE WELCOME TO
ASK QUESTIONS OF. IN WRITING OF
THE COMMITTEE OR OF THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE BUT THIS IS NOT
THAT TIME. ANYONE ELSE WILLING
OKAY. THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE
WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER SUPPORT
FOR SBELEVEN NINETY. NO ONE
ELSE CAN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
MISTER CHAIR. OKAY THANK YOU WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO OPPOSITION I
HAVE. TWO PRIMARY WINS IS AN
OPPOSITION RUN KINGSTON AND
CREAM THREE C. SIX ARE YOU MR
KING SAID MR TRACY ON THE LINE.
YES SIR MR CARE THE MORNING
AGAIN- MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- CLEAN GREASY ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
pOPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
ON SB ELEVEN NINETY- EXISTING
LAW ASPECTS BY CRIME VICTIMS TO
BREAK THEIR LEASES THAT THEY
PROVIDE SPECIFIED DOCUMENTATION
OF THE CRIME OCCURRED- THIS IS
MENTIONED PREVIOUSLY IN THE
OPENING REMARKS ABOUT AN INCH-
SUCH THINGS THAT A COPY OF THE
POLICE REPORTED CETERA- JUST
LONGSTANDING DOCUMENTATION
REQUIREMENTS PROVIDES CERTAINTY
TO HOUSING PROVIDERS AND
TENANTS REGARDING WHAT IS AN.
ACCEPTABLE FORM OF
DOCUMENTATION. HELLO SB ELEVEN
NINETY DRAMATIC EXPAND. THIS
BREAK PLEASE MECHANISM IN
CANTER WAYS INCLUDING-
SUBDIVISION BE PARAGRAPH WHICH
STATE THAT ANY OTHER FORM OF
DOCUMENTATION POLITICAL CAN BE
USED- UNFORTUNATELY THIS
LANGUAGE IS THE MORTGAGE AND
WILL LEAD TO INCREASED
LITIGATION AT THE DOES NOT
PROVIDE CERTAINTY TO HOUSING
PROVIDERS AND TENANTS.
REGARDING WHAT IS AN ACCEPTABLE
FORM OF DOCUMENTATION- FOR
EXAMPLE UNDER SB ELEVEN NINETY
AT THAT AFTER SPEAKING TO ABUSE
THIS MECHANISM. HE PROVIDED NO
TO THEIR HOUSING PROVIDERS THAT
THEY HAVE TO BREAK THE LEASE
AND PROVIDE SCREENSHOT BIG
SOCIAL MEDIA POSTS OR FAKE TEXT
MESSAGES. AT SO CALLED
DOCUMENTATION. THE SOCIAL MEDIA
MESSAGE GENERATE HAVE BECOME
PRESS OVER THE DECADE. YOU CAN
BE READILY USED WITH JUST THE
TOUCH OF A BUTTON IT CREATED IN
A MATTER OF SECONDS. SB ELEVEN
NINETY ENCOURAGES BAD ACTORS TO
ABUSE THE VERY MECHANISM THAT
IS MEANT TO HELP THOSE IN NEED.
UNTIL SUCH TIME AS BILLS
AMENDED TO CLOSE THIS
PARTICULAR LOOPHOLE C. R.
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST A NO VOTE
ON SB ELEVEN NINETY. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU MISTER KING
ST ARE YOU ONLINE. YES I AM
MISTER CHAIRMAN. JUST READ. I'M
GONNA LIVE IN TWO TO THREE
MINUTES PLEASE. OKAY THANK YOU.
FOR THIS OFFICE HAS BEEN VERY
VERY INVOLVED AND CAN HEAVILY
CONTRIBUTED IN THE CRAFTING OF-
ALL THE LAWS THAT WE HAVE TODAY
IT'S A VERY VERY NEAR AND DEAR
ISSUE FOR US- THIS ILL ARE
HOWEVER CREATE SOME UNINTENDED
AND UNFORESEEN CONSEQUENCES AND
OUR JUDGMENT MOST NOTABLY TO
BREAK A LEAST BECOMES EXTREMELY
EASY NOW ARE WITH THIS BILL.
BECAUSE YOU CAN BE ALLEGE THAT
IMMEDIATE FAMILY MEMBER
ANYWHERE LET'S SAY IN THE
UNITED STATES- IS A VICTIM. AND
THERE'S NO PROOF UP OR THERE'S
NO DOCUMENTATION THAT IS SHE-
IS TO BE PROVIDED TO THE
LANDLORD OTHER THAN THEY WANT
TO BREAK THE EASE TERMINATE
THE LEASE IF. SO JUST BECAUSE
THAT IMMEDIATE FAMILY MEMBER OR
ANY OTHER PERSON THAT IS LIKE
AS A FAMILY MEMBER ARE IS
AFFECTED AND FACTORED IN
FINALLY- THE BILL ACTUALLY HAS
A PROVISION IN HERE. THAT YOU
CAN BREAK A LEASE IF IT IS FOR
THAT THE NON VICTIM BUT I
TENANTS WHO IS EMOTIONALLY
AFFECTED OR PSYCHOLOGICALLY
AFFECTED BY A FAMILY MEMBER
SOMEWHERE ELSE- THAT HAPPENED
IN THE UNITED STATES WE DON'T
UNDERSTAND. THE PURPOSE OF BY
DOING THIS AND- AFTER THAT THE
BILL BE AMENDED. YOU ARE CAREER
THE ARE. THIS DIRECTION WITH
THAT WE WOULD REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
RIGHT NOW WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
IS THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM.
SEEING NONE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION IN THE WITNESS VIDEO
ROOM. SEEING NONE ABOUT THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION. THANK
YOU OPERATOR WILL NOW TAKE
TELEPHONE ANYONE ON THE
TELEPHONES WHO WOULD LIKE TO
GIVE US YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND THAT YOU
OPPOSE S. B. ELEVEN NINETY. Q.
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD IF THAT
IS YOUR CURRENT POSITION
TOWARDS THIS BILL. WE'LL GO
FIRST TIMELINE FIFTY SIX FIVE
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GET YOUR
CARE MEMBERS PARTNERING WITH
THEIR AND READING ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION WE HAVE AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION AND
AMENDMENTS ARE REFLECTED ON
PAGE EIGHT OF THE HOUSES THANK
YOU. AT THIS TIME THERE ARE NO
FURTHER LINES IN Q. ALL RIGHT
GIVE ME JUST A MINUTE IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
S. B. ELEVEN NINETY AND YOU'RE
ON THE TELEPHONE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO. OPERATED THAT BRING
ANYBODY ELSE IN. DID NOT OKAY.
THANK YOU WE'RE GOING TO OFFER
YOU MAY CLOSE ALLIANCE FOR
SENATE BILL ELEVEN NINETY BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS. RIGHT
SEEING NONE SENATOR YOU MAKE
CLOTHES.I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND
SECOND THAT MOTION IS DUE
PASSED CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
STONE HI STONE HI GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NO CHAU. CHIU CHU AYE
GONZALEZ. HOLDEN KALRA. KILEY.
HIGHLY NO MON MON I OBERNOLTE
OBERNOLTE NO RESPONSE REYES AYE
THE BILL HAS FOR VOTES FOR
VOTES RIGHT THANK YOU CENTER
WILL PUT THAT BELONG CALL THANK
YOU FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU CENTER SKINNER THIS
NOW BRINGS US TO ITEM NUMBER
FOR SENATE BILL. TEN SEVENTY
NINE. IN A SHE MAKES HER WAY UP
HERE I'LL TAKE A MOTION ON THE
CONSENT AGENDA. HEY WE DO HAVE
A MOTION AND A SECOND ON THE
CONSENT AGENDA. CALL THE ROLL
IS. STONE HI STONE AYE
GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER I SHALL
TWO FIVE CHUGAI GONZALEZ HOLDEN
KALRA KILEY KILEY II LIMóN AYE
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE I READ.
REYES HI. THAT HAS SEVEN SEVEN
THE TO THE CONSENT AGENDA IS
APPROVED THAT IS S. B. TEN-
THREE BY JONES SB ELEVEN FORTY
ONE BY RUBIO SB ELEVEN FORTY
EIGHT BY JONES SB THIRTEEN OH
FIVE BY ROTH SB THIRTEEN
SEVENTY ONE WHICH IS THE SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE BILL SB
FOURTEEN FORTY SEVEN BY BRAD
FOR AND I WILL NOTE THAT FOR
SENATE BILL ELEVEN FORTY EIGHT
BY JONES THAT MOTION IS SENDING
IT TO THE FLOOR FOR CHAPTER
RING. AMENDMENTS WE WILL NOT BE
ON CONSENT IN THE SENATE. BOB
SORRY ON OUR FLOOR. IN THE
ASSEMBLY RIGHT SENATOR SKINNER
SENATE BILL TEN SEVENTY NINE
THE COMMISSION WITH THIS BILL
I'LL BE BACK SO WE DO HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND ON THIS
BILL AND SO IF ANYONE WANTS TO.
BE A WITNESS OR GIVE US AN
OPINION ON SENATE BILL TEN
SEVENTY NINE THIS IS THE TIME
TO CALL IN. SENATOR YOU MAY
OPEN THANK YOU SO MUCH I WANT
TO JUST- APPRECIATE THE MOTION
BUT I WANTED TO INDICATE THAT I
AM ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS THAT REPLACE THE
FIRST LOOK WITH THE FORTY FIVE
DAY WINDOW THANK YOU- WHICH IS
A GOOD VERY GOOD AMENDMENT I
REALLY WANT TO FREE US TO
EXPRESS MY APPRECIATION TO
COMMITTEE STAFF BECAUSE THEY
WORKED HARD WITH MY STAFF ON
THIS BILL. AND I WILL ALLOW MY-
WITNESS TO SPEAK BUT I THINK
THIS BILL IS VERY IMPORTANT NOW
GIVEN THAT WE ARE ONCE AGAIN IN
A- ECONOMIC DOWNTURN AND WE-HAVE THE POSSIBILITY OF MANY
CALIFORNIANS BEING FACED WITH
FORECLOSURE WELL THIS BILL DOES
NOT PREVENT FORECLOSURE SOMEONE
TO BE CLEAR WILL NOT PREVENT
THEM WE WILL HAVE MUCH TO DO
OTHER THINGS TO TRY TO PREVENT
THOSE. BUT WHAT IT IS AIMED AT
IS RIPPER VETTING THE SCENARIO
THAT WE EXPERIENCED IN THE LAST
RECESSION WHERE A HANDFUL OF
LARGE CORPORATIONS SNATCHED UP
MANY MANY CALIFORNIA SINGLE
FAMILY HOMES AT AUCTION IN
BOTH. PLEASE PAYING CASH AND
THEN EITHER LEFT THEM VACANT IN
CERTAIN NEIGHBORHOODS OR
CREATED A NEW ASSET CLASS OF
SINGLE FAMILY HOME RENTALS WITH
REALLY EGREGIOUS PLEASE PRESS
PROVISIONS- I WILL LEAVE IT AT
THAT I CAN EXPLAIN ALL THE
DETAILS BUT I ALLOW MY WITNESS
IN SUPPORT. AND OTHER PEOPLE TO
SPEAK THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU
I HAVE ONE WITNESS LISTED IN
SUPPORT ROBERT APODACA FROM THE.
TWO HUNDRED MISTER PRODUK ARE
YOU ON THE LINE. YEAH RIGHT
PLEASE. PROCEED BUT GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN STONE AND
MEMBERS OF THE JUDICIARY-
COMMITTEE- ROBERT PAPA DOC A CO
FOUNDER OF CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
BUILDERS AND VICE CHAIRMAN OF
THE TWO HUNDRED OF OUR MISSION
IS TO ERADICATE POVERTY AND
NARAL THE BALK UP OF UNDER
REPRESENTED COMMUNITIES THROUGH
HOMEOWNERSHIP- MANY MEMBERS OF
OUR LEADERSHIP COUNCIL OR ARE
FAMILIAR TO YOU- ON A DAY ARE
FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER JO KOTAL
FORMER SENATOR- DON COLLADO. A
FORMER CABINET MEMBER SENT BACK
PEAK JOHN CAMPBELL WHO IS THE
CO FOUNDER OF CALIFORNIA-
COMMITTEE BUILDERS- AND HERMAN
GUY EAGLES OF WHO IS THE
FOUNDER OF THE NATIONAL COUNCIL
ABOUT THE NON OWNERS. WHO NEED
THIS US. I'M MORE DWELL ON WHAT
KOBE BECAUSE IS DOING TO CAL.
ARE WITH OTHERS AND COUNTRY BUT
FOR SURE IT'S GOING TO RESULT
IN A LOT OF MANY HOMES.
FORECLOSURES SIMILAR TO THE
FORECLOSURE CRISIS AND THE
GREAT RECESSION- JUST AS A
REMINDER- THERE'S OUT OF THERE
THERE HAS BEEN A- SEVERE
REDUCTION HOMEOWNERSHIP AMONG
BLACK AND LATINOS SINCE THE
GREAT RECESSION. M. RIGHT NOW
CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO INCREASE
THE HOMEOWNERSHIP AMONG
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. BOB IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THE
LATEST UPDATED THAT'S AVAILABLE
OF LATINOS HOMEOWNERSHIP RATE
WAS FORTY THREE POINT NINE
PERCENT. WHICH IS FOUR POINT 5%
IN THE HEIGHT OF THE OWNERSHIP
AND TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN SO
BUT YOU KNOW PROBABLY NOT.
FULLY RECOVERED. GREAT RISK.
FROM THE LOSS OF MOBILE HOMES.
SIMILARLY OF BLACKS IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN OH
HOMEOWNERSHIP RATE WAS THIRTY
FOUR POINT 4% WHICH IS FIVE
POINT 6% LESS THAN THE HEIGHT
OF THE HOMEOWNERSHIP AND THREE
TWO THOUSAND SOME TEAM- BY
COMPARISONS. HOMEOWNERSHIP
RIGHT NOW IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN TO SIXTY THREE POINT
FOUR PERCENT. AND THEY HAVE I
HAVE ALMOST RECOVERED OF THE
OTHER LOSSES. THAT THEY STILL
LAGGING. BY ONE POINT 6% SO ON
PORT AT A WHEN WE'RE TO SEE
FOR. BANKS ARE ALL TRYING UP
THE LENDING QUITE. THAT WILL
FURTHER HURT HOMEOWNERSHIP
PROSPECTS FOR PEOPLE WHO MOST
DESERVE THE RIGHT TO
HOMEOWNERSHIP. FIRST TIME HOME
BUYERS CANNOT COMPETE WITH
CORPORATE BUYERS. SB TEN
SEVENTY NINE IS DESIGNED TO
PREVENT CORPORATIONS FROM THE
BUNDLED PURCHASE OF A HOME OF
OUR THUNDER CHRISTOPHER
DESCRIBED AND THEN CONVERT THEM
TO RENTALS- CALIFORNIA NEEDS
MORE- INCREASE HOMEOWNERSHIP.
PARTICULAR AMONG PEOPLE OF
COLOR AND NOW IT'S TIME TO DO
THAT WE STRONGLY SUPPORT SB TEN
SEVENTY NINE AND I ASK FOR YOUR
I. BOATS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THAT'S THE ONLY WITNESS THAT I
HAVE LISTED IS THERE ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO INDICATE. SUPPORT
FOR THIS BILL IN THE WITNESS
VIDEO ROOM. SEEING NONE. THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION. C.
NONE ANYONE IN THIS HEARING
ROOM. GREAT SEEING NONE
OPERATOR WOULD YOU GIVE
INSTRUCTIONS FOR ANYONE ON THE
TELEPHONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
GIVE US THEIR NAME THEIR
AFFILIATION AND THAT THEY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. TELL ME IF
THAT IS YOUR POSITION AT THIS
TIME YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AGAIN THE COMMANDOS ONES
ARE ALL USING YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. INTO A FEW LINES IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME WE'LL GO
FIRST TO LINE SEVENTY NINE.
SEVEN NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BUT TURN NUMBER CATALINA
SANCHEZ LET CORBENIC EITHER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LOW
INCOME CONSUMER COALITION AND
SUPPORT THANK YOUNG THANK YOU.
NINE NINETY NINE NINE NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
ANYA LAWLER ON BEHALF OF THE
WESTERN CENTER MOM POVERTY AND
THE CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION AND
SUPPORT. NINE SEVENTY THREE
SEVEN THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING CARDMEMBER ERICA
THIRTIES ON BEHALF OF THE
NEIGHBOR SERVICES I AM TRUMP
SUPPORT OF UP THE BILL. THANK
YOU. LINE NINETY FOUR NINE FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU HI.
PLEASE GO HEAD. HI I AM JOE
THROUGH BALA WITH THE
CALIFORNIA REINVESTMENT
COALITION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK. FIND SIXTY TO SIXTY TWO.
THANK YOUNG HELLO THIS IS DR
YES AN THEY ESPERANDO COMMUNITY
HOUSING CORPORATION AND WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU
LINE NINETY EIGHT NINE NINE
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS LAMAR HATE
THAT PRESIDENT OF THE ASIAN
CORPORATE WERE PAID FOR
TACTICAL MEMBERS ABOUT
HOMEOWNERSHIP AT THAT ALSO
MEMBER THE CALIFORNIA
REINVESTMENT COALITION WE'RE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
LEGISLATION SENATE BILL TEN
SEVENTY NINE. THANK YOU. NINE
NINETY SEVEN NINE SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. CATHERINE PEOPLE
TO MAKE IT ALL PRESIDENT AND
FOUNDER OF ATP CARE THE HOW TO
PUT PROBABLY COUNTY AGENCY ALSO
A MEMBER OF CALIFORNIA
REINVESTMENT COALITION AND WE
ARE IN FULL SUPPORT. OF THIS.
THANK YOU NINE ONE ONE- NINE
ONE ZERO NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BUT. NINE SIXTY SIXTY TWO. NINE
ONE ONE NINETY ONE AND YOU YOUR
YOUR VIDEO AND PUT YOUR PHONE
LINE IS OPEN. BECAUSE THEY
SHOULDN'T. OF EIGHT ZERO MIND
NINETY EIGHT NINE NINE EIGHT
IT'S GOING TO. THE MARKET IS
THAT RIGHT HE- WOULD BE ACTED
BILL MEMBERS OF THE HOLDER THAT
THAT AT. OPERATOR NOT SURE
WHAT'S HAPPENING. EIGHT THEIR
PHONE LINE WAS PRODUCING A
DELAYED- WEB AND SINCE THEY'VE
DISCONNECTED AT THIS TIME NO
ONE ELSE IS IN Q. OKAY GIVE ME
JUST A SECOND ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. WE DO HAVE
ANOTHER LINE I'LL BE JUST A
MOMENT PLEASE. LINE NINETY
EIGHT NINE EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN AT THIS TIME. HELLO AGAIN
THAT LAMAR HIGH TECH WITH ASIAN
CORPORATE ABATE THE TAXES
COLLECTED MY REMARKS EARLIER
BUT I WANT TO REITERATE THAT I
JOIN. CALIFORNIA REINVESTMENT
COALITION HOMEOWNERSHIP ACT
THAT SUPPORTING THE LEGISLATION
WE ARE A HARD APPROVED LOCAL
HOUSING COUNSELING AGENCY THANK
YOU THANK YOU. LINE ONE ELEVEN
ONE ONE ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YOUR YES. GREAT THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON READY BUT WOULD NEED
ECONOMICS WOMEN A LOCAL HAD
APPROVED HOUSING COUNSELING
AGENCY AND BOTH THE BOARD OF SB
TEND TO BE. THANK YOU KNOW ONE
IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME MISTER
CHAIR ALL RIGHT THANK YOU WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO. OPPOSITION I
HAVE ONE LISTED OPPOSITION ON
THE TELEPHONE JIM LIGHTS OF THE
NATIONAL RENTAL HOME COUNCIL.
ARE YOU ON THE LINE. I AM HERE
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN JIM LIKE ON BEHALF OF
THE NATIONAL RENTAL HOME
COUNCIL AND- WE APPRECIATE THE
MOST RECENT AMENDMENTS TO THE
BILL- BILL ONE OF OUR MEMBER
COMPANIES IS REFERENCED IN THE
ANALYSIS I DID WANT TO NOTE
THAT SOME OF THE CONCERNS
RAISED IN THE ANALYSIS ABOUT
LANDLORD PRACTICES DO NOT
HAPPEN TO BE HOW SOME OF OUR
ASSOCIATION MEMBER COMPANIES.
OPERATE PERSONALLY ALL THE
COMPANIES HAVE A PROGRAM THAT
IF THEY DECIDE TO SELL A HOME
GIVES THE CURRENT TENET THE
FIRST RIGHTOF REFUSAL TO
PURCHASE THAT HOME AND THAT
INCLUDES CREDITING THE SECURITY
DEPOSIT TOWARDS THE DOWN
PAYMENT WE ALSO UNLIKE THE
OAKLEY MALL. SITUATION DO NOT
HOLD WITH IT KEPT ARE TYPICAL
OCCUPANCY RATE OF 95% HAS GROWN
COLD CRISIS THE PMR HAS BEGUN.
1178% ALL OF THE COMPANIES HAVE
CREATED APPS FOR YOUR IF YOU
NEED REPAIR BECAUSE HAVE.
THEY'VE ALL HIGHER KING KNOW
FORM WITH PEER CREWS. THAT COME
IN AND GET REPAIR DONE AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE WITH REGARD
TO THE PROVISIONS THAT WOULD
PREVENT BUNDLING IN A TRUSTEE
SALE NOT ALL OF OUR COMPANIES
BUY IN BULK. TO BEGIN WITH BUT
WE THINK GENERALLY THAT THAT
EFFORT TO DISCOURAGE- CORPORATE
CAPITAL FROM BRINGING THESE
HOMES BACK TO THE MARKET- IF WE
FIND OURSELVES IN A FORECLOSURE
CRISIS. IN THE NEXT YEAR OR TWO.
IT ACTUALLY SO. THE SALE
PROCESS AND THEN THE REPAIRS
RENOVATION AND RETURNING THOSE
HOMES TO THE MARKET PLACE FOR
SALE OR FOR RENT AND WE SIMPLY
THINK THAT THAT PROVISION WOULD
HAVE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
AND SHOULD BE RETHOUGHT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. HANK YOU. RIGHT
IS THERE ANYONE IN THE WITNESS
VIDEO. IN THE WITNESS VIDEO
ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION. C. NONE ABOUT
THE REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION.
RIGHT SEEING NONE ANYONE ON THE
TELEPHONE WHO WOULD. LIKE TO
REGISTER OPPOSITION TO SENATE
BILL TEN SEVENTY NINE OPERATOR
YOU CAN GO TO THOSE LINES. Q.
AND AGAIN THE COMMAND TO QUEUE
UP FOR THAT IS TO PRESS ONE AND
THEN LITERALLY USING YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD WE'LL GO TO
LINE ONE THIRTEEN ONE ONE THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS JIM WEINBERG WITH THE
FRENCH COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION- CALIFORNIA WITH
APOLOGIES WORK IN THE LONG
CREWS BUT WE WOULD ACTUALLY
LIKE TO REGISTER OUR SUPPORT
FOR THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK
YOU THAT IS SO NOTED. NINE ONE
FOURTEEN ONE ONE FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI THIS IS PAT EVAN
LOW CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MORTAGE BANKERS
ASSOCIATION AND THEY ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. THANK
YOU. ONE HUNDRED ONE ZERO ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER CARE
NUMBERS KEVIN GOLD OF THE
CALIFORNIA BANKERS ASSOCIATION
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK
YOU. ONE ONE ZERO TWO ONE OH
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MISTER
KERR BIRDS PROBLEMS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CREDIT UNION LEAGUE
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU. LINE
ONE ALL ONE ONE ZERO ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MISTER
MEMBERS ANTHONY UPTON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LAND TITLE
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION DUE
TO CONCERNS THAT THE BILL WILL
HAVE A CHILLING EFFECT ON
FORECLOSURE SALES AND
CONTRIBUTE TO YOUR COMMUNITY
LIKE. THANK YOU. NINE ONE OH
SIX ONE ZERO SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SALARY NARAL FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
WE ARE IN OPPOSITION TO
CAMPAIGN IN THE NINE. AS A
REMINDER YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO IF THIS IS YOUR
POSITION ON THIS BILL LINE ONE
FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BRING RAMOS HEY KAREN I'M I'M A
REAL ESTATE AGENT AND- PROPERTY
MANAGER- BUT HAVING BEEN
THROUGH- THE FORECLOSURE CRISIS
IN 200-016-2000 AND SEVEN I'M
SORRY CERVANTES REGISTERING
SUPPORT AND IN OPPOSITION. NOT
TAKING ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY IF
YOU COULD JUST GIVE US YOUR
NAME WHICH YOU DID AND THEN
DOES YOUR POST THE BILL. THAT
WOULD BE SUFFICIENT THANK YOU.
FIVE YES I AM- ADAMANTLY
OPPOSED TO THE BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. AND AT THIS TIME
THERE AND OFFERED ONLINE CAN
QUEUE THANK YOU IS MISTER BELOW
IT ON THE LINE. I AM MR THANK
YOU THANK YOU I UNDERSTAND YOU
WERE SUPPOSED TO BE ON OUR LIST
BUT AS OPPOSITION VOTE WERE.
WAS NOT LISTED SO I'M GOING TO
ALLOW YOU TO REGISTER YOUR-
OPPOSITION. YOU CAN HAVE THREE
MINUTES. THANK YOU I AM
APPRECIATE YOUR KINDNESS- A
COUPLE OF QUICK CUTS THIS IS
MIKE BELOW ON BEHALF OF THE
UNITED TRUSTEES ASSOCIATION
COUPLE QUICK. PRELIMINARY
COMMENTS FIRST WE UNDERSTAND.
AND APPRECIATE SENATOR
SKINNER'S- OBJECTIVES TO
ENCOURAGE OWNER OCCUPANCY OF
NEIGHBORHOODS AND SECONDLY. YOU
KNOW SHE AND HER STAFF AND MR
MAGNATE. HAVE BEEN INCREDIBLY
GENEROUS WITH THEIR TIME AND
TALKING THROUGH THE ISSUES IN
THE BILL- YOUR CONCERNED ABOUT
A FORTY FIVE DAY A PROVISION
WHICH HAS BEEN AMENDED INTO THE
BILL AS OF TODAY. WE HAVE
CLEARLY VERY SIGNIFICANT POLICY
ISSUE FACING THE LEGISLATURE ON
THOSE SINCE THE CREATION OF NON
JUDICIAL FORECLOSURE IN THE
THIRTIES- THE WHOLE POINT OF
THE TRUSTEE'S SALE WAS TO
MAXIMIZE THE SALE PRICE OF THE
HOUSE THAT WAY WE DO
PUBLICATION OF NOTICES POSTING
OF THE PROPERTY NOTICES TO
VARIOUS PERSONS AND IT'S REALLY
NOT FOR THE LENDER THE LENDER
IS GOING TO GET THEIR
INDEBTEDNESS RECOVERED IN THE
FORECLOSURE SALE IT'S REALLY
FOR THE HOMEOWNER. BECAUSE THE
HOMEOWNER IS ENTITLED TO
PROCEEDS FROM THE SALE ABOUT
THE SALE PRICE COPY- AT THE END
OF. SO THE POINT IS TO MAX. THE
PROCEEDS FROM THE SALE WE'RE
CONCERNED THAT THIS FORTY FIVE
DAY PROVISION WHILE WELL
INTENTIONED WILL IN FACT
BITTING AND HARM HOMEOWNERS-
WHAT YOU'RE ASKING TO DO IS PUT
UP CASH AND THEN SEE OVER A
FORTY FIVE DAY PERIOD WHETHER
THEY ACTUALLY WILL BE THE HIGH
BIDDER OR NOT AND WHAT CAN
HAPPEN DURING THAT TIME THERE'S
A NUMBER OF NEGATIVE THINGS
THAT CAN HAPPEN THE HEIGHT
BIDDER CAN GO BANKRUPT THE HIGH
BIDDER. THERE NINE AND CAN THE
SENATE AND BY THE PRO. THERE'S
ALSO OF THINGS THAT CAN HAPPEN
THAT TIME AND WILK WILL CONCERN
THEY SIMPLY WON'T DO IT OR THEY
WON'T BID AS HIGH AS THEY
OTHERWISE MIGHT. BECAUSE OF
THIS RISKAND THE RISK OF
HAVING MONEY TIED UP FOR A
MONTH AND A HALF SECONDLY NO
ONE IS. HAS ANY INCENTIVE TO
MAINTAIN THE PROPERTY DURING
THAT TIME NOT THE- HOMEOWNER
WHO IS IN DANGER OF LOSING THE
HOUSE NOT ATTENDED IF THE
PROPERTY HAS BEEN RENTED.
CANNOT BE- BLEND WHO DOESN'T
OWN THE PROPERTY AT THAT POINT
AND WON'T HAVE ACCESS TO
MAINTAIN IT. SO AGAIN WHILE THE
WHILE THE PROVISION AS WELL
INTENTIONED WE UNDERSTAND
SENATORS- DESIRE HERE. BUT WE
ACTUALLY THINK IT WILL HAVE A
NEGATIVE EFFECT RATHER THAN A
POSITIVE ONE. WE TO WORK
ABILITY IS THAT WERE DISCUSSED
THE SENATOR PER THE POLICY
ISSUE IS WHAT I WANTED TO BRING
TO THE ATTENTION OF THE
COMMITTEE. AND I APPRECIATE
YOUR I'M. NOT INSULTING ME.
THANK YOU. I WILL GO BACK TO
THE PHONES FOR YOU WHO WOULD
LIKE TO GIVE US YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION AND THAT YOU OPPOSE
SB TEN SEVENTY NINE IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE QUEUE. THERE'S NO
ONE IN QUEUE AT THE MOMENT IF
ANYONE WOULD LIKE TO QUEUE UP
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO. NO ONE
ON THE PHONE AT THIS TIME SIR.
RIGHT THANK YOU THEN YOU CAN
CLOSE THE LINES FOR SENATE BILL
TEN SEVENTY NINE. NO BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS MR KILEY. I THANK YOU
SENATOR SKINNER AYE I LIKE THE
PREMISE OF THIS BILL A LOT BUT
I FIND THE ARGUMENTS OF THE
OPPOSITION- PRETTY PERSUASIVE
AS FAR AS THE INCENTIVES THIS
WILL CREATE- AND- SOME OF THESE
OTHER HARM SO I JUST WANT TO
GIVE YOU A CHANCE TO RESPOND TO
IT AND THE SOME OF HIS POINTS
MISTER RAISED ABOUT- INCENTIVES
TO MAKE. YES MY HARM HOMEOWNERS.
WELL IT DOESN'T HARM THE
HOMEOWNER BECAUSE IN THE THIS
BILL IS ONLY IMPACTING
FORECLOSED PROPERTY SO THE
HOMEOWNERS ALREADY FACING THE
SITUATION OF THEIR PROPERTY
BEING FORECLOSED BUT WHAT IT
DOES DO IS GIVE THAT HOMEOWNER
IF THEY CAN'T IN THE FORTY FIVE
DAY WINDOW- PUT TOGETHER A BID
THAT WOULD MEET. THE BID THAT
WAS FIRST INITIATED IN THE
AUCTION TO BE ABLE TO BUY TO
GET THEIR HOPE. AND CERTAINLY
IN THE LAST FORECLOSURE CRISIS
WE SAW IN EXPERIENCE THAT MANY
OF THOSE WERE FORECLOSED ON. IT
WAS DUE TO THE TERMS OF THEIR
LOAN. AND THAT THE- IN THE U.
THEY WERE GIVEN BAD LOAN BY A
LENDER AND THAT IT WASN'T THAT
THEY WERE COMPLETELY WITHOUT
CAPITAL OR CASH THEY JUST COULD
NOT MEET THE TURN THEIR FELT
PROPERTY WAS NO LONGER THE SAME
VALUE AND THEY COULD NOT MEET
THE TERMS OF THAT EXISTING LONG
SO FOR EXAMPLE IF THIS EXISTED
DURING THE LAST FORECLOSURE
CRISIS WE MAY HAVE HAD MORE OF
THOSE. HOMEOWNERS FACING
FORECLOSURE BE ABLE TO ACTUALLY
PURCHASE THEIR HOME NOW THIS
BILL DOES NOT PREVENT CORPORATE
PURCHASED OF HOMES IT'S NOT BUT
WHAT IT DOES DO IS BY IN THAT
WINDOW. IF THE INITIAL BID. A
CORP ENTITY OR AN INDIVIDUAL
WHOEVER PUTS IN. A HIGH BID.
THEN THERE'S A FORTY FIVE DAY
WINDOW FOR THE TENANTS. OR THE
OWNER OR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FOR
AND FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
ENTITY TO BE ABLE TO- OUTBID
THAT. IF THERE'S NO OUT BEATING
OF IT THEN WHOEVER PUT IN THAT
INITIAL BID. GETS TO PROCEED
WITH THE SALE. SO YES THERE IS
A FORTY FIVE DAY WINDOW WHERE
THE HOME THAT WAS UNDER
FORECLOSURE WOULD CONCEIVABLY
AMIN IN THE WORST CASE.
ATTENTION WE SOMEONE NOT
MAINTAIN IT BUT- WE HAD A MUCH
HIGHER SPECTER OF ENTITIES THAT
BOUGHT HOMES DURING THE LAST
FORECLOSURE CRISIS WHO LEFT
THOSE HOMES BIT VACANT. AND
THERE WERE- I HAVE A VIVID
MEMORY DURING THAT TIME WHEN I
WAS IN THE ASSEMBLY OF HALF
WALKING WITH THE CITY MANAGER
OF RICHMOND. AND AT A DIFFERENT
TIME WALKING WITH CITY
OFFICIALS IN OAKLAND HE THROUGH
CERTAIN NEIGHBORHOODS WHERE
EVERY THIRD HOME WAS COMPLETELY
ABANDONED HAD BEEN STRIPPED OF
ALL OF ITS WIRES. STRIPPED OF
PIPE STRIPPED OF THE REFER
PEOPLE WHO WERE- THEN TRYING TO
RECOVER THAT VALUE AND- HE
PACKED ON THE NEIGHBORHOOD WAS
HORRIBLE WE'RE NOT GOING TO
FACE THAT TYPE OF CIRCUMSTANCE
IN THIS CASE BECAUSE WE ARE
NOT. IT IS NOT A- THE FORTY
FIVE DAY WINDOW IS IN AND OF
ITSELF MINIMAL. SO WELL
CERTAINLY IN A WORST CASE WHAT-
MISTER BELOW IMAGINED MIGHT
OCCUR IN SOME CIRCUMSTANCES BUT
IT WOULD BE FEW. OTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS MISSOURI
THANK YOU AT FIRST I WANT TO
START OFF BY WISHING THE
SENATOR A VERY HAPPY BIRTHDAY
AND THEN I WANT TO MENTION IT
JUST THAT YOU KNOW IN THE LAST
CONVERSATION WE HAD ABOUT PRIOR
BILLS THIS IS PART OF THE
SOLUTION. THE ASSEMBLY BANKING
AND FINANCE COMMITTEE HAS BEEN
LOOKING AT FOR CLOSURE DATE AT-
FOR THE LAST RECESSION BETWEEN
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN IN TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE. AND WE WERE
SADLY REMINDED THAT IMPACTED
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS WE ARE
NOT TALKING ABOUT LITTLE
NUMBERS- AND SO I THINK THAT
WHATEVER WE CAN DO TO ENSURE
THAT OUR HOUSING CRISIS- IS NOT
EXASPERATED DURING THIS
RECESSION IS IMPORTANT. AND I
THINK YOU'VE MADE AMENDMENTS
AND CHANGES- AND CERTAINLY IS
PART OF TRYING TO IDENTIFY HOW
WE KEEP- INDIVIDUALS IT IN
THEIR HOME BUT ALSO ALLOW THAT
THE HOUSING MARKET IS
ACCEPTABLE AT EVERY BE CALLOUS
AND- IN AN EQUAL AND- AND IN A
WAY THAT'S MORE YOU KNOW. MORE
THIRTY AND THEN FOR PEOPLE WHO
CAN COME IN AND GIVE UP SOME OF
THIS I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
THE. YOUR QUESTION. YEAH I AM I
APPRECIATE THE CAN AND HEARING
FROM THE IN YOUR- I GUESS MY
EXPERIENCE IT'S JUST BEEN A LOT
DIFFERENT AND I MEAN WHAT I'VE
SEEN IS YOU KNOW THAT- FOR SOME
PEOPLE BODIES OF FORECLOSURE
THEY TURN AROUND AND RUN ABOUT
TWO PEOPLE AND THAT PROVIDES
HOUSING A LOT OF TIMES THEY
RENOVATE THAT PROPERTY AND THEY
CAN BRING IT UP. TO A BETTER
STANDARD AND THEN RE RENTED
OUT- YOU KNOW THAT'S WHAT I'M
SEEN HAPPEN IN THE MARKET- YOU
KNOW OBVIOUSLY I CAN'T SPEAK TO
WHAT YOU SEE IN YOU KNOW IN
YOUR PARTICULAR DISTRICT BUT I
GUESS I WOULD GET THAT IS AN
ISSUE I WOULD WANT TO SEE
SOMETHING IS MORE SPECIFIC TO
ADDRESSING THE ISSUES THERE
MAYBE IT'S A LOCAL SOLUTION
MAYBE THERE'S OTHER WAYS TO
PROTECT. DRESS THAT BUT IT JUST
IT IT SEEMS. SOMEWHAT UNFAIR TO
ME THAT WE HAVE A PROCESS WHERE
ANYBODY CAN COME YOU KNOW AND
BID ON THAT PROPERTY IF IT'S UP
TO FORECLOSURE INCLUDING THE
TENANTS. INCLUDING NONPROFIT
GROUPS THAT ARE THAT ARE DOING
GREAT WORK AND COMMITTEE
PROVIDING A RENTAL- PROPERTIES
AND- AND PROVIDING AFFORDABLE-
RENTALS. EVERYBODY CAN SHOP
EVERYBODY HAS AN EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY TO PURCHASE THAT
PROPERTY AND THEN PUT IT TAKE
TO GET USE AND SO I JUST I
DON'T SEE THE REASON TO.
SOMEHOW GAME THAT SYSTEM A
LITTLE BIT AND SAY OKAY WE'LL
BUT OKAY YOU DID WHEN YOU GOT
THE BID THAT FORTY FIVE DAYS.
PEOPLE HAVE TO COME IN AND JUST
KIND OF. A ONE DOLLAR MORE. IT
TO ME DOESN'T SEEM LIKE THE
MOST AFFECTED WERE FAIR PROCESS.
AND AGAIN NOT WHAT I'M SEEING
IS THE MARKET REALLY DOES SEEM
TO WORK- IN PROVIDING FOR
UPGRADED AND MORE HOUSING AND
RENTALS- I'M JUST NOT SEEN THE
NEED TO ESTABLISH THIS IS A
STATE WIDE POLICY YEAH THOUGH I
DO. I MEAN I'M LISTEN I'M
HEARING WHAT YOU'RE SAYING HAS
BEEN GOING ON IN THE EAST BAY-
AND CERTAINLY THAT'S A PROBLEM.
THROUGH THE CHAIR PLEASE ISSUE
BUT TO RESPOND CERTAINLY I GAVE
YOU A PERSONAL EXAMPLE BECAUSE
WHERE I LIVE BUT IT WAS NOT
UNIQUE BUT LET'S LET'S SET THAT
ASIDE USE THE TERM GAMING I
THINK ONE COULD SAY THAT WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS PREVENT
THE GAMING OF A SYSTEM THAT
WERE ACTUALLY. LEVEL THE OWNER
OCCUPANT WHO'S UNDER
FORECLOSURE FOR THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ENTITY DOES NOT HAVE
THE SAME ACCESS TO. LARGE
AMOUNTS OF CASH AT THE MOMENT
SOMETHING GOES ON TO AN AUCTION
THE WAY THAT MANY OF THESE
LARGE CORPORATIONS HALF AND SO
UNDER THE CURRENT SYSTEM AN
ENTITY. THE COMBINED BALK WITH
CASH HAS THE ADVANTAGE SO THIS
IS TRYING TO CREATE A MORE
LEVEL PLAYING FIELD SO THAT.
OTHER ENTITIES THAT ALSO
DESERVE TO OWN HOMES WOULD BE
ABLE TO COMPETE. AND I THINK IF
WE- I MENTIONED AND I THINK
THE- OR MISTRUST A DOCTOR FROM
ONE HUNDRED. THAT NOT ONLY WELL.
THERE WAS A GROUP THERE WAS A
VERY SIGNIFICANT DROP IN BLACK
AND LET LET NEXT HOMEOWNERSHIP.
IN GENERAL THERE WAS A
SIGNIFICANT DROP IN HOME OWNER
OCCUPANT HOMEOWNERSHIP THREATS
TO CALIFORNIA WHICH STILL HAS
NOT RECOVERED. AND WHEN WE
THINK ABOUT. WHAT OF
HOMEOWNERSHIP REPRESENTS IN OUR
COUNTRY. AND THE ABILITY FOR IT
FOR CREATING RETIREMENT
SECURITY GENERATIONAL WEALTH
AND SO MUCH MORE IT SEEMS TO ME
WE SHOULD BE DOING EVERYTHING
WE CAN. TO ENSURE THAT
INDIVIDUALS WHO WANT TO OWN AN
OCCUPIED THEIR HOME HAVE AT
LEAST AS FEAR OF AN ADVANTAGE
IN A PROCESS LIKE THIS AS AN
ENTITY THAT HAS ACCESS TO A LOT
OF CASH. JUST AS A QUICK FALL
TO THAT I MEAN I AGREE WITH
EVERYTHING HE SAID THE LAST
PART OF WHAT YOU SAID THERE.
BUT IN TERMS OF I MEAN CORRECT
ME IF I'M WRONG BUT FOR
CLOSURES THERE IS A NOTICE
REQUIREMENTS. AND THEY'RE
USUALLY POSTED IN NEWSPAPERS SO
AND I THINK IT'S AT LEAST
THIRTY DAYS. SO ALL THOSE
PEOPLE WOULD HAVE NOTICE OF THE
FACT IT THIS PROPERTY IS UP FOR
FORECLOSURE. AND SO FREEZING
LIKE ONLY THE PEOPLE CAN
ACTUALLY QUICKLY I MEAN
EVERYBODY HAS THAT SAME NOTICE
IN A PUBLIC. A FORMER NEWSPAPER
OTHERWISE. AT WHICH THEY COULD.
COME UP WITH THE CASH OR NOT SO
I DON'T FEEL LIKE THE PROCESS
THE EXISTING. PROCESS SORT OF
BELIES WHAT YOU'RE SAYING THERE
THAT ONLY THE PEOPLE THAT CAN
COME UP REALLY QUICKLY WITH
MONEY AND AGAIN I MEAN IF YOU
DON'T HAVE THE MONEY AT THAT
TIME. WHAT'S TO SAY YOU'RE
GONNA HAVE AN IN FORTY FIVE
DAYS I MEAN THAT'S NOT. WE'RE
NOT TALKING ABOUT A WHOLE LOT
OF DIFFERENCE OF TIME THERE IF
YOU'VE ALREADY HAD THIRTY DAYS.
FOR INSTANCE BUT I MEAN CORRECT
ME IF I'M WRONG ON THAT PROCESS.
WELL THERE IS SOME NOTICE
THERE'S ALSO UNDER THE CURRENT
SYSTEM THE BALK AUCTION WHICH
IT GIVES AN ADVANTAGE TO AN
ENTITY THAT CAN PURCHASE
MULTIPLE AT ONCE. VERSUS THE
PERSON WHO'S JUST TRYING TO BUY
THAT SINGLE PROPERTY EITHER THE
OWNER OCCUPANT OR THE TENANT.
THIS SAID I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
I THINK THIS DOES FALL INTO THE
CATEGORIES MISS LIMóN SAID OF.
SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO BE
ADDRESSING GIVEN WHAT'S COMING
BUT TO ME IT ALSO FALLS IN THE
CATEGORY OF LESSONS LEARNED
FROM THE LAST HOUSING CRISIS. I
CAN REMEMBER THROUGH THAT
CRISIS PEOPLE AT THE COUNTY
STEPS WHO HAD THE RESOURCES THE
FACILITIES SNATCHING UP HOMES.
THROUGH THE OPTIONS IN THE
FORECLOSURE PROCESS IN IN A WAY
THAT REALLY FOR PRECLUDED
OTHERS INTO MANY OF THOSE. WERE
BOUGHT ON SPECULATION NOT
ACTUALLY OCCUPIED AND WE ALSO
HAD IN MORE RURAL AREAS. A LOT
OF HOMES NOT BEING OCCUPIED%
THAT THEN BECAME PROBLEMS IN
THOSE NEIGHBORHOODS SO I THINK
THIS IS AN APPROPRIATE STEP
AND- EIGHT A VERY GOOD SOLUTION
THAT. THAT HELPS. ADDRESS SOME
OF THE ISSUES THAT WE HAD
LEARNED ABOUT BEFORE THAT'S WHY
I THINK THIS IS. VERY IMPORTANT
POLICY. SO I THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD I WILL
ALSO NOTE THAT THE BILL WAS
AMENDED PREVIOUSLY SO WHAT'S
BEFORE US HERE IS JUST A
RECOMMENDATION. THE MOTION OF
THE TO PASS OR- NOT TO PASS AS
AMENDED BECAUSE THOSE WE TOOK
THEM RIGHT DOESN'T YET THE
AMENDMENTS WERE BECAUSE WE HAD
SO MUCH TO HELP. RIGHT WE ARE
ABLE TO PROCESS PREVIOUSLY
PROCESS THE AMENDMENTS JUST
JUST FROM A PROCESS STANDPOINT.
RIGHT CENTER YOU MAY CLOSE
THANK YOU ARE TOO GOOD
DISCUSSION I APPRECIATE. BY
BOTH. THANK YOU. SO LOOKING FOR
A WE ALREADY HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND THAT MOTION IS DUE
PASS. CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
STONE BY STONE HI GALLAGHER.
CHAU. TO AND SALAS HI GONZALEZ
I HOLDEN KALRA. KILEY. NOT
VOTING KELLY NOT VOTING. LIMON
LIMON I OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE NO
REYES. IT HAS THREE VOTES
PEOPLE TO PUT THAT BELONG CALL
SENATOR AND WHEN WE GET MORE
MEMBERS BACK YOUR TICKET. RIGHT
LET'S MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER
FIVE SENATE BILL ELEVEN FORTY
SIX SENATOR UMBERG. SO IF THIS
IS THE TIME TO CALL IN AND BE
READY IF YOU ARE. CALLING IN
FOR TESTIMONY ON SENATE BILL
ELEVEN FORTY SIX. SENATOR YOU
MAY PROCEED THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. FIRST OF ALL
LET ME ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS
PROPOSED BY THE COMMITTEE AND
LET ME THANK THE COMMITTEE IN
THE CHAIR FOR THEIR DILIGENT
WORK ON THIS BILL IT'S REALLY
TECHNICAL BILL- AND IF IT WAS
ONE BORN OF COLLABORATION
BETWEEN CONSUMER ATTORNEYS IN
CALIFORNIA DEFENSE COUNSEL-
SPECIAL THANKS TO MICHAEL BELOW
MIKE A STAR LIBERTY SAVANNAH TO
KERR IN NANCY DRABBLE THE BILL
DOES THREE THINGS IN LIGHT OF
THE CURRENT CRISIS. ONE IT
REQUIRES THAT ATTORNEYS ACCEPT
SERVICE ELECTRONICALLY OTHER
SHOULD BEEN DONE A LONG TIME
AGO- MOST ATTORNEYS ARE DOING
THAT SUMMER BEING DIFFICULT
THIS ELIMINATES THAT. OPTION
BEING DIFFICULT NUMBER TWO IT
ALSO PROVIDES REMOTE
DEPOSITIONS- DOESN'T REQUIRE
THEM BUT PROVIDES FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONDUCT REMOTE
DEPOSITIONS AND THREE IT- MOVES
THE DATES THAT ARE ATTENDED TO
THE TRIAL DATE WITH THE TRIAL
DATE LET ME EXPLAIN. SO CIVIL
TRIALS IT WILL SCRIBBLE TRIALS
WITH THIS DEAL THIS BILL DEALS
WITH CIVIL TRIALS ARE BEING
MOVED RIGHT NOW TO DATE
SOMETIMES TURMAN. WHEN TRIAL
DAY IS A GIFTED THERE ARE DATA
SO WITH IT THIS GUY CUTOFF DATE
TODAY IS EXCHANGE OF EXPERTS-
THAT IN SOME UP. IF THE COURT
SPECIFIED. CREATES A LOT OF
CONFUSION REQUIRES MORE
PRACTICE ALL KINDS OF THINGS SO
THIS BILL CLARIFIES THAT AND
MOVES ALL THE DATES THAT
ATTENDED THERE TOO- THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR ORIGINAL VOTE.
THANK YOU I HAVE TWO WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT LISTED MY CUSTOMER
LIBERTY WITH CONSUMER ATTORNEYS
OF CALIFORNIA. AND MIKE BELOW
CAN. CALIFORNIA DEFENSE COUNSEL
BOTH ON THE TELEPHONE ARE YOU
WITH US TODAY. WELL YES MR
STONE I GUESS- MISS LIBERTY
WILL HOPEFULLY FOLLOW UP ON ME
OKAY MICHAELA FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEFENSE COUNSEL-
EXACTLY OF SENATOR- BURKE
INDICATED THIS IS A TECHNICAL-
BILL WHICH BASICALLY CODIFIES
SOME RULES THAT THE SUPREME
COURT ISSUED ON AN EMERGENCY
BASIS- THAT THE SIMPLEST IS.
REMOVING THE REQUIREMENT OF THE
STIPULATIONS FOR RECEIVING
NOTICES BY LAWYERS THIS IS
SIMPLE COMMON SENSE. AS TO THE
REMOTE DEPOSITION ALL THE BILL
ALL THE BILL REALLY DOES IS
ALLOW THE DEPONENT AND THE
COURT REPORTER TO BE PHYSICALLY
SEPARATED- IF THE- NOTICING
PARTY THAT DESIGNATES THAT AND
A COMMONSENSE APPROACH DURING
THE PANDEMIC FOR SURE- THERE'S
SIMPLY NO WAY TO OVERSTATE
WHAT. WHAT'S HAPPENING THE
CHAOS IN THE SYSTEM WE HAVE-
CRIMINAL CASES PILING UP IT'S
GOING TO BE SOME TIME BEFORE WE
CAN CONDUCT JURY TRIALS. IN OUR
COURTS CIVIL CASES THIS ALLOWS
THE PRE TRIAL PROCEEDINGS TO
CONTINUE SO THAT PEOPLE CAN BE
READY FOR 12-1 AND WHEN THE
COURTS CANFINALLY OPEN UP AND
GET JURIES AND TRIAL BILL. SO
WILL PLAN SUPPORT THANK CENTER
NUMBER FOR HIS. PARTNERSHIP
WITH BILL. THANK YOU. MY LIFE.
OKAY SO WE'LL NOW MOVE TO THE
WITNESS VIDEO ROOM IS THERE
ANYONE. IN THE WITNESS VIDEO
ROOM WHO'D LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. I'M SORRY MISTER CHAIR
CAN YOU HEAR ME NOW YES WE CAN
GO AHEAD PLEASE. THANK SORRY
ABOUT THAT THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
ESTEEMED MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MIKE A
STAR LIBERTY I'M THE PRESIDENT
OF THE CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA HERE TO TESTIFY IS
ONE OF THE SPONSORS OF SB
ELEVEN FORTY SIX- AT THIS BODY
KNOWS ALL TOO WELL ALL THREE
BRANCHES OF GOVERNMENT HAVE
BEEN. DEVASTATED BY THE IMPACT
OF COVERT NINETEEN TO BE SURE
OUR COURT SYSTEM SHUT DOWN AND
ALL FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES FOR
WEEKS AND IN SOME INSTANCES
MONTHS. ELEVEN FORTY SIX PADA
FIVE THE EMERGENCY RULES PUT
INTO PLACE BY THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL AND THE CHIEF JUSTICE.
I KNOW THAT IT'S BEEN A LONG-
I'M EATING HERE THIS MORNING
AND I DON'T WANT TO BE LABOR
ANY OF THEM POINT. SENATOR
UMBERG FORM BELOW MADE I WOULD
LIKE TO DO. READ THAT ALL OF
THESE DIFFERENT- THREE
PROVISIONS ARE ABSOLUTELY
NECESSARY TO GET THE WHEELS OF
JUSTICE TURNING ONCE AGAIN. AND
BOTH THE EAST SERVICE AND
REMOTE DEPOSITIONS I HAVE BEEN
A LONG TIME COMING AND TO BE
CRYSTAL CLEAR WITH RESPECT TO
THAT REMOTE DEPOSITIONS. YEAH
THANK IS JUST. OTHER TO ABOUT
REQUIRE BACK THAT UP AS OFFICER
AND THE WHAT BE IN THE SAME
LOCATION LOCATION SO THE NEW
LANGUAGE- MAKES NO REFERENCE TO
THE LOCATION OF ANYONE
PARTICIPATING IN THAT
PROCEEDING- WE NEED CONSISTENCY
ACROSS THE STATE AND WE BELIEVE
THAT THIS. BILL ELEVEN FORTY
SIX WOULD PROVIDE THAT- WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE AND I'M CAN'T HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU.
RIGHT I DON'T SEE ANYONE IN THE
WITNESS VIDEO ROOM IS THERE
ANYONE AT THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION. SEEING NONE ANYONE IN
THE HEARING ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
ELEVEN FORTY SIX. SEEING NONE
OPERATOR YOU CAN OPEN THE LINES
AND HAVE FOLKS CALL IN IF THEY
WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER SUPPORT
FOR SENATE BILL ELEVEN FORTY
SIX. AND AGAIN WE'RE TAKING
NAMES. ASSOCIATION AND THAT YOU
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SHOW YOUR SUPPORT ON THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. AND WE WILL AYE ONE
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
ANDY WE'VE BEEN BOND JUDICIAL
COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. BETTER CARE THERE ARE
NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP
AT THIS TIME OKAY THANK YOU WE
WILL NOW THEN MOVED TO
OPPOSITION I HAVE LISTED DAS
YOU AND ON THIS OF THE
CALIFORNIA COURT REPORTERS
ASSOCIATION WITH HERNANDEZ ARE
YOU ON THE LINE. I AM THE
SECRETARY THANK YOU. NOT SURE
HERNANDEZ ON THE HOUSE. THANK
YOU- NOT YOUR HERNANDEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA COURT
REPORTERS ASSOCIATION WE ARE
STATEWIDE ASSOCIATION INCLUSIVE
OF OFFICIAL COURT REPORTERS A
COURT ROOMS AS WELL AS
DEPOSITION OFFICERS. AND
OTHERS- WE DO HAVE AN UP CLOSE
ENOUGH AMENDED POSITION AND
WITH OUR SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS
WE WILL NOT ONLY REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION THAT WE WOULD JUST
SUPPORT- LET ME CLARIFY A
COUPLE OF THINGS. ON THE LETTER
OF THE LAW CURRENT LAW- DID NOT
PROVIDE MUCH FLEXIBILITY FOR
REMOTE DEPOSITIONS YOU
RECOGNIZE THAT HAVE A PROBLEM.
UNDER CURRENT LAW- IT'S THAT A
PARTY TO A CASE MAY NOT APPEAR
FIVE REMOTE B. AND ONLY
WITNESSES THAT ARE NOT PART USE
MAY APPEAR BY TELEPHONE. AND
ONLY AFTER A COURT ORDER SO
CERTAIN. THE STATUTE YEP THE AN
FBI FORTY SIX DOLLARS PER THAT.
CHANGE IN GENERALLY WE'RE OKAY
WITH THAT. THE ONE CONCERN THAT
WE HOUSE. IS THAT HAVE SB
ELEVEN FORTY SIX WAS DRAFTED IT
OPENED UP WITHOUT ANY
LIMITATION UTILITY OF A
DEPOSITION RECORDER TO BE
PHYSICALLY PRESENT OUTSIDE OF
CALIFORNIA LIVING OUT BY
CALIFORNIA. ZOOM INTO
CALIFORNIA FOR WHAT WOULD
OTHERWISE BE A CALIFORNIA
DEPOSITION EVEN IF DECENT
VISUALS ARE LICENSED IN
CALIFORNIA BESIDES WHERE OUT OF
STATE OR ANY WORDS IN THE
SALEABLE WE THINK THAT IT'S
PROBLEMATIC IT GOES TOO FAR TOO
SOON. THIS BILL IS SOMETHING
THAT WILL TAKE A FACT AND
REALLY BE IMPLEMENTED AFTER THE
EMERGENCY ORDERS ARE LOOKED AT-
AND AT THAT JUNCTURE WE DO
SUPPORT HAPPENED BUT BELIEVE
YOU TO HELP YOU WITH IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA BUT WE
DIDN'T TAKE KINDLY JOHN THAT.
YEAH A LOT MORE WORK THAN. THE
FACT THAT HAVE NEVER. STATE WE
DO KNOW THAT THERE ARE OF STATE
COMPANIES THAT HAVE TARGETED
CAL. FOR OUT OF STATE REPORTER
AND CAT COURTROOM HAPPY HAPPY
YET. IN ORDER TO DO TO
CALIFORNIA TO. THIS WHAT IMPACT
THE WORK. ARE YOU CAL WE'RE
ALSO OPEN UP OF WHAT HAPPENS TO
EXIT BETTER TRANSFER TO SOMEONE
WHO IS OUT OF STATE. SO OUR
SUGGESTIONS OF THE PUBLIC
SCHOOL BOARD SB ELEVEN FORTY
SIX WITH ONE EXCEPTION KEEP
CURRENT LAW. ONLY FOR THOSE
DEPOSITIONS REPORTERS WHO ARE
PHYSICALLY OUTSIDE OF
CALIFORNIA DURING THE
DEPOSITION. SO JUST KEEP
CALIFORNIA LAW FOR THAT. I'M
THAT WAY COULD BE BY COURT
ORDER OR WHATEVER THE
REQUIREMENTS ARE UNDER CURRENT
LAW WE GOT A BIG HUGE STILL
HUGE IMPROVEMENT OVER CURRENT
LAW. YEAH I THINK WE SUGGESTED
THAT MIGHT BE IMPORTANT TO APPS
HAVE THE REPORTER STATE ON THE
RECORD WHEN YOU'RE SHE STATE
NAME. AND OTHER INFORMATION OF
WHERE HE OR SHE IS AFTER THE
QUICK BUT IN CALIFORNIA THE
OUTSIDE A COUPLE OF WEEKS SO
THERE'S CLEARLY THAT CALIFORNIA
LAW APPLIED. AND THAT AND WE
KNOW WHAT WE'RE DOING SO WITH
THOSE TWO WOMEN WOULD REMOVE
OUR OPPOSITION. AND WE WOULD
SUPPORT THE BILL WE BELIEVE THE
COURT GOING GOING TO RESUME. WE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND I'M
AVAILABLE FOR ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU. IS THERE ANYONE OF
THE WITNESS VIDEO ROOM. WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SENATE BILL
ELEVEN FORTY SIX. C. NINE
ANYONE IN THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION. SEEING NONE ANYONE IN
THE HEARING ROOM. SEEING NONE
OPERATOR NOW IS THE TIME TO
TAKE ANYONE TELEPHONICALLY WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SENATE BILL
ELEVEN FORTY SIX. YOU SPEAK OUT
POSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND AS A
REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. AND
MISTER KERR NOBODY'S QUEUING UP
AT THIS TIME TENS JUST GIVE IT
ANOTHER. LITTLE BIT ANYONE
WHO'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION SENATE BILL ELEVEN
FORTY SIX PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. OPERATED THAT CATCH
ANYONE. NOBODY HAS QUEUED UP
SIR OKAY THANK YOU YOU CAN
CLOSE THE LINES FOR SENATE BILL
ELEVEN FORTY SIX WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. GALLAGHER YEAH THANK
YOU SENATOR AND I'M INCLINED TO
SUPPORT THE BILL- I DID I DID
WANT TO MAYBE. GIVE YOU AN
OPPORTUNITY JUST ADDRESS SOME
OF THE CONCERNS FROM
OPPOSITION. I THINK ONE OF THEM
WAS THE ISSUE OF YOU KNOW RIGHT
NOW ALL GROUP THERE IS A
REQUIREMENT THAT THEY BE A
LICENSE TO THE DEPOSITION
REPORTER IN CALIFORNIA. AND
IT'S APPEARS THAT THAT'S NOT
THE CASE UNDER THIS BILL- AND
THEN. YOU KNOW THE ONE AREA
WHERE I THINK. WE KIND OF DO
NEEDS AND AT LEAST AS MUCH AS
WE CAN IN PERSON IS
DEPOSITIONS. YOU KNOW I MEAN
THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS THAT
HAPPEN IN A DEPOSITION. THAT
THAT MIGHT NOT NECESSARILY BE
CAUGHT. IF IT'S REMOTE AND YOU
KNOW MAYBE. THERE'S A GLITCH
AND- SOMETIMES INAUDIBLE- IN A
MOST DEPOSITIONS THAT I'VE BEEN
IN. YOU KNOW IT IS USUALLY IN A
CONFERENCE ROOM WHERE YOU CAN
HAVE PEOPLE SPREAD OUT THE
PEOPLE COULD BE WEARING MASKS
SO. YOU KNOW IF THE PARTIES I
GUESS BOTH PARTIES THAT ARE IN
THE LAWSUIT OR WANTING TO HAVE
AN IN PERSON DEPOSITION IF WE
PUT IT UP TO THE DEPONENT TO
SAY. WELL NO I WANTED TO BE ALL
REMOTE. DOES THAT SOMEHOW
BECAUSE A PROBLEM I JUST
THINKING THROUGH THOSE ISSUES I
COULD SEE HOW THAT. YOU KNOW
MIGHT POSE A PROBLEM FOR
GETTING YOU KNOW TO THE JUSTICE
OF THE CASE AND GETTING YOU
KNOW GETTING DOWN TO THE NOT
SYMBOLS OF THE CASE AND MAKING
SURE THAT THERE'S A GOOD CLEAR
RECORD. RIGHT AS YOU'RE
DEVELOPING YOUR CASE SO MAYBE
IF YOU COULD JUST ADDRESS SOME
OF THOSE ISSUES ON THE
DEPOSITION. FROM SURE- MISTER
CHAIR PLEASE- THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GALLAGHER- I
AGREE WITH YOU AND I THINK MOST
PRACTITIONERS WOULD AGREE WITH
YOU THAT HAVING THE COURT
REPORTER PRESENT PHYSICALLY
PRESENT AT THE LOCATION OF THE
DEPONENT IS CERTAINLY
PREFERABLE FOR ALL THE REASONS
YOU JUST MENTIONED- IN THIS
BILL DOESN'T PRECLUDE FOR
EXAMPLE. A COURT REPORTER FOR
BEING PRESENT DOESN'T PRECLUDE
ATTORNEY FROM BEING PRESENT UP
FOR THE DEPOSITION. WHAT WHAT I
THINK MISTER HERNANDEZ IS
SAYING IS THAT FOR OUT OF STATE
DEPOSITIONS OR FOR DEPOSITIONS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA YOU YOU NEED
TO HAVE A CALIFORNIA REPORTER.
BOB IS A PRACTICAL MATTER THERE
ARE. OBLIQUE TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF DEPOSITIONS THAT ARE TAKEN
EVERY DECADE MAYBE THOUSANDS OF
TAKEN EVERY YEAR OUT OF STATE
I'VETAKEN I DON'T KNOW MAYBE
TWO HUNDRED DEPOSITIONS OUT OF
STATE AND YOU HAVE A COURT
REPORTER FROM THAT LOCALE. OF
THE THERE'S NO REQUIREMENT
TODAY NOR SHOULD THERE BE A
REQUIREMENT THAT YOU HAVE A
COURT REPORTER WHOSE LICENSE IN
CALIFORNIA IF YOU'RE TAKING A
DEPOSITION IN NEW YORK- I
UNDERSTAND THE CONCERNS I DON'T
THINK THOSE CONCERNS ARE GOING
TO BE REALIZED IN IN A IS- YOU
PROBABLY SEE IN THE ANALYSIS
THE- COURT REPORTING- COURT
REPORTERS BOARD SUPPORTS THE
BILL AS WELL AS THE- DEPOSITION
COURT REPORTERS- ASSOCIATION
SUPPORTS THE BILL THIS HAS NO
IMPACT ON CORPUS. THIS ONLY
APPLIES TO DEPOSITIONS. AND
THEN JUST QUICKLY ON THAT WHAT
IF BOTH PARTIES. ONLY IF AS
OPPOSED TO. OKAY THIS IS A
QUICK FOLLOW UP IS I MEAN JUST
WITH REGARD TO AS YOU WERE
SAYING WHAT IF BOTH PARTIES
WANT TO HAVE THE DEPOSITION
REPORTER PRESENT. WITH THE
DEPONENT. SO THAT AND I THINK
THE REASON YOU WOULD BE HEY I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT-
REPORTER IS GOING TO HEAR
EVERYTHING IS GOING TO BE IN
THE ROOM TO HEAR EVERYTHING AND
MAYBE THERE. TO AVOID THE
PROBLEM OF SOMETIMES REMOTELY
MAYBE SOME BECOMES INAUDIBLE OR-
AND MAYBE DOESN'T GET RECORDED
PROPERLY. IF BOTH PARTIES WANT
TO HAVE THAT BUT WE LEAVE IT UP
TO THE DEPONENT TO SAY WELL NO
I DON'T WANT THAT. ZACH POSE A
PROBLEM AS IT IS THAT'S BEEN
MIKE RIGHT KIND OF HITS IT'S
NOT UP TO THE DIPLOMA. SO FOR
EXAMPLE IS AN ATTORNEY WHEN YOU
NOTICE THE DEPOSITION. IT'S
WITHIN YOUR CONTROL TO
DETERMINE WHETHER THE COURT
REPORTER IS GOING TO BE
PHYSICALLY PRESENT OR NOT IF
YOU CHOOSE NOT TO THE COURT
REPORTER PHYSICALLY PRESENT.
AND YOUR RECORD IS NOT WHAT YOU
WISH IT TO BE THEN YOU TAKE
THAT RISK- SO- WHAT TAUGHT IN
THE LANGUAGES SAYS THAT THE
ELECTION OF THE DEPONENT FOR
THE DEPOSING PARTY. THE
DEPOSITION OFFICER MAY ATTEND
THE DEPOSITION AT A DIFFERENT
LOCATION. SHOULD I READ THAT IS
SAYING THE DEPONENT. EVEN IF
THEY'RE NOT OF TO THE K. IN MY
JUST BE A WITNESS THAT THE WERE
DEPOSING. THAT DEPONENT COULD
SAY NO I DON'T WANT THEM
PRESENT YEAH NO NO NO THE
DEPONENT IF. WE WILL CERTAINLY
CLARIFY IF THAT'S THE WAY IT
READS BUT THE IF I'M THE
ATTORNEY NOTICING THE
DEPOSITION I NOTICED A
DEPOSITION OF. A PERSON. THEN
I'D I NOTICED THAT I RANGE OF
THE CORE REPORT IF THE DEPONENT
SAYS I DON'T WANT THE COURT
REPORTER BE PRESENT. THEY HAVE
NO OPTION AND IF AND IF THERE'S
ANY AMBIGUITY WILL CLEAR THAT
UP THAT THE PERSON WHO NOTICES
THE DEPOSITION. MAKES THE
TERMINATION- AT LEAST INITIALLY
AND CLEARLY IF THE PERSON WHO
IS DEFENDING THE DEPOSITION
WHICH THE COURT REPORTER
PRESENT. THEY THEY CAN ALSO
THEY GET TO COURT REPORTERS
THERE IF THEY LIKE ONE REMOTELY
AND ONE PHYSICALLY PRESENT.
YEAH THAT'S ALL I WANTED TO
CLARIFY AND IT SOUNDS LIKE
THAT'S YOUR INTENT SO. AS IF
THERE IS AN AMBIGUITY OTHER ONE
WE WILL WE WILL- EXAMINE IT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT THE
DEPONENT CAN'T PRECLUDE A COURT
REPORTER FROM BEING PHYSICALLY
PRESENT. THE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. SIGNALED SENDIRI
MIKLOS ORIGINAL VOTE. THANK YOU
ARE LOOKING FOR MOTION THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS- AMENDED.
AND I WILL NOTE. THANK YOU WE
DO HAVE A MOTION IS SECOND.
THANK YOU HAVE NOTE THAT ONE OF
THE MOMENTS AS WE ARE AT ENERGY
CYCLICALS. SO WE HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE. STONE HI STONE I
GALLAGHER. CODER I CHAO. TO
GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ I HOLDEN
KALRA KILEY KILEY AYE MON. I
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE I RAYOS.
BUT HAS SIX FIRSTS THANK YOU
THE BILL IS OUT THANK YOU
SENATOR MEMBERS ALL RIGHT
CENTER CASKEY WE NOW MOVE TO
OUR ITEM NUMBER SIX SENATE BILL
EIGHT NINETY EIGHT IF ANYONE
WOULD LIKE TO CALL IN ON SENATE
BILL EIGHT NINETY EIGHT NOW'S
THE TIME. TO DIAL THAT NUMBER
AND WE WILL START WITH THE
OPENING FROM CENTER BY CASKEY
THINKING MISTER CHEER AND
COLLEAGUES ONE THE GREATEST
HURDLES- FAMILIES FACE WHEN
CONTEMPLATING WHETHER TO PURSUE
A POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION IS
THE SKYROCKETING COSTS OF
ATTENDING COLLEGE DESPITE THESE
TROUBLING TRENDS MANY
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES CONTINUE TO
SEE VALUE IN A POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION FOR THEIR CHILDREN
THE SAVINGS PLAN SUCH AS THE
SCHOLAR SHEER FIVE TWO NINE
ACCOUNT PROVIDE FAMILIES OF ALL
INCOME LEVELS WITH THAT THE
FIRST SET OF INVESTMENT OPTIONS
WHEN. USED FOR QUALIFIED HIGHER
EDUCATION EXPENSES I THINK THE
STAFF REPORT DOES A GOOD JOB OF
SHOWING UP AT AT ALL INCOME
LEVELS PEOPLE THAT SET UP THESE
PLANS ACTUALLY INCENTIVIZE
THEIR KIDS TO ATTEND COLLEGE
HOWEVER FROM ACCOUNT OWNERS
FACED WITH THE JUDGMENT THE
CREDITOR HAS THE ABILITY TO
ATTACH THE ACCOUNT TO SATISFY
THEIR JUDGMENT CALIFORNIA IS
JUST ONE OF TWENTY TWO STATES
WITHOUT STATE CREDITOR
PROTECTION FOR FIVE TWENTY NINE
COLLEGE SAVINGS. PLAN SO THIS
BILL EXPANDS LIST OF JUDGMENT
EXEMPTIONS- ON THE CALIFORNIA
BANKRUPTCY LAW IN ORDER TO
INCLUDE FAMILY SAVINGS AND THE
SCHOLARS SHARE ACCOUNT DOES
THIS BILL WILL ENSURE THAT
FAMILY COLLEGE SAVINGS ARE
PROTECTED UNDER A- UNDER
AGAINST JUDGMENTS I'M I'VE
TAKEN RECENT AMENDMENTS TO
LIMIT THE EXEMPTION TO FIFTEEN
AT THE FOR EACH OF THE FIRST
TWO YEARS THE ILLINOIS. MODEL
BEFORE FILING FOR BANKRUPTCY IN
THE MONEY MUST BE AN ACCOUNT
FOR TWO YEARS BEFORE THE BANK
BANKRUPTCY COULD BE COMPLETELY
EXEMPTED AND FINALLY A STAFF
REPORT NOTES OUT THE BILL
REVISES THE STATUTES- A SETTING.
FOR THE AMOUNTS OF VARIOUS
TYPES OF PROPERTY OWNED BY THE
JUDGE DEBTOR THAT IS. LEAGUE
FROM INFO OF MONEY THESE-
MODIFIED EVERY THREE YEARS BUT
A JUDICIAL COUNCIL WAS
COMPLETELY IT WAS DONE IN
TWENTY NINETEEN AND THIS WOULD.
LINE UP WHAT IT WHAT THE
EXEMPTION IS GOOD WHAT THE
STATUE WAS HIM I HAVE A FEELING
OF MAR STATE TREASURER ON THE
PHONE WHOSE. AND HER STAFF AND
I URGE ACT. THANK YOU I HAVE
TWO WITNESSES LISTED FEW AMOK
CALIFORNIA STATE TREASURER AND
STANDS EDO DEPUTY EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE SCHOLARS SHARE
INVESTMENT BOARD. AS WITNESSES.
WAS EALTHIEST YOUR SEATS ARE
YOU ON THE LINE. THE ONLY
MARKING YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN
HEAR PLEASE PROCEED. OKAY GREAT
THANK YOU WITH THE CHAMBER TO
THE COMMITTEE I AM PROUD TO
SPONSOR SB EIGHT NINETY EIGHT
WITH SENATOR BOB WHITE COUNTY
THIS REALLY SHORT DOLLARS YOUR
PIPE UNITE COLLEGE STATING THE
CHARACTER TEXTED. FROM
CREDITORS SHOULD ANY
UNANTICIPATED FINANCIAL
CHALLENGES ARISE WHICH IS NOW.
HOW DID GIVE THE UNCERTAINTY IN
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY DUE TO
COPE WITH NINETEEN. FEDERAL LAW
CURRENTLY ALLOWS FAMILIES TO
SEEK FEDERAL PROTECTION FROM
CREDITORS DURING BANKRUPTCY
PROCEEDINGS. HOWEVER CALIFORNIA
IS ONE OF ONLY TWENTY TWO STATE
WITHOUT THE CREDITOR PROTECTION
OUTSIDE OF BANKRUPTCY. FOR FIVE
TWENTY NINE COLLEGE SAVINGS
ACCOUNT SO IN THE UNFORTUNATE
EVENT THAT THE ACCOUNT OWNER IT
START WITH THE JUDGEMENT.
CREDITOR HAS THE ABILITY TO
ATTACH THE ACCOUNT TO SATISFY
THEIR JUDGMENT THE RESULT THAT
CAN BE VERY DEVASTATED A FAMILY
MEMBER THAT THEIR LOVED ONE. IS
ESPECIALLY- JUST BECAUSE THE
CHILD IS THE BENEFICIARY OF THE
ACCOUNTIN ANY FAMILY MEMBER OR
FRIEND CAN CONTRIBUTE. TO THAT
ACCOUNT FOR THE CHILD'S FUTURE
EDUCATION NOT JUST THE PARENT
OR GUARDIAN WHO MAY BE THE
VICTIM OF FINANCIAL HARDSHIP IN
THE FUTURE. THANK YOU FOR
TAKING THOSE AMENDMENTS THAT I
AM PROUD TO SPONSOR EIGHT. SB
EIGHT NINETY EIGHT M. ON THE
PHONE IT STANDS VETO DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE SCHOLARSHIP
THAT THAT BOARD WHO CAN ANSWER
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS YOU MAY
ALL HAVE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU. MISTER SEAT ARE YOU
OFFERING. TESTIMONY OR JUST
HERE FOR QUESTIONS. I'M HERE
FOR A TECHNICAL ABOUT. CULTURE
OKAY THANK YOU. SO WE WILL NOW.
TO ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
REGISTER SUPPORT FOR S. SB.
EIGHT NINETY EIGHT IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE WITNESS VIDEO
ROOM. SEEING NONE THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION. SEEING NONE
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM I
SEE NOBODY HERE SO WE WILL NOW
GO TO THE PHONE LINES FOR
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
REGISTER SUPPORT FOR SENATE
BILL EIGHT NINETY EIGHT WILL
TAKE YOUR NAME YOUR AFFILIATION
AND THAT YOU SUPPORT THE BILL
OPERATOR CAN WE GO TO THE PHONE
LINES. THANK YOU TO SUPPORT
EIGHT NINETY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY THE ZERO WE
WERE LINE ONE TWENTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON SHARE
AT REMEMBERS DANIEL CANDOR
CHRYSLER ON BEHALF WOULD THE
CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME CONSUMER
COALITION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
BUT FOR ANY I TO SHOW YOUR
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. ONE MOMENT IF
ONE IS KEEPING UP. EVERYBODY
ELSE IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SHOW
YOUR SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I WILL GO TO
LINE ONE TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE ONE TWENTY THREE.
ONE TWENTY THREE ARE YOU HEADED.
HOWEVER THE NUMBER LONG AT THE
HELP THINKER WITH FIFTY AND
EVERYTHING THEN IT MOVED OUR
OFFICE FROM THE AND WE ARE NOW
THANK YOU THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIRS NOTE NOBODY ELSE THINK
YOU AT THE TIME. OKAY I DO NOT
HAVE ANY OPPOSITION LISTED SO
WE WILL GO TO THE- WITNESS
VIDEO ROOM. SIR ANYONE THERE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO. THIS
INDICATE OPPOSITION TO SENATE
BILL EIGHT NINETY EIGHT. C.
NINE WHAT ABOUT THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION. SEEING NONE
THERE'S NO ONE HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM. SO WE WILL GO TO
THE PHONE LINES ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER
OPPOSITION TO SENATE BILL EIGHT
NINETY EIGHT. OPERATOR. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME TO
SHOW OPPOSITION. ONCE AGAIN
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO TO SHOW YOUR OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL. PLEASE QUEUING UP
STRUCTURE. I'M SORRY REPEAT
THAT YOU DID YOU SAY NO ONE IS
KEEPING UP. BUT HE IS QUEUING
UP AT THIS TIME SIR. OKAY THANK
YOU SO AFRAID TO GO AHEAD AND
CLOSE THE LINES FOR SB EIGHT
NINETY EIGHT BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS THIS RIVER NORTH E.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN-
SENATOR THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK
ON THIS ISSUE I KNOW THAT
YOU'VE BEEN VERY PURSER- THAT
YOU'VE. THAT YOU'VE PERSEVERED
THROUGH A LOT I COMPLETELY WITH
YOU THE- MY SET ASIDE CHILD
SHOULD NOT BE SHOULD NOT BE-
PART OF A BANKRUPTCY
PROCEEDING- YOU KNOW THE ISSUE
THAT OF COURSE WE'VE BEEN
DISCUSSING IS HOW TO PUT AN
EXCLUSION LIKE THAT INTO STATE
LAW WITHOUT- INCENTIVIZING
PEOPLE TO HIDE ASSETS FROM THE
BANKRUPTCY PROCESS IN THIS WAY
AND I KNOW THAT YOU'VE- YOU'VE
BEEN VERY DILIGENT WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS. SO YOU'VE NOW
TIED TO THE EXCLUSION TO THE
ANNUAL GIFT TAX EXCLUSION WHICH
AS YOU SAY IS ABOUT FIFTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR IS THAT
EXCLUSION PER FIVE TWENTY NINE
ACCOUNT OR IS IT EXCLUSION
TOTAL. FOR THE PARTY ENTERING
IN THE BANKRUPTCY. THROUGH THE
CHAIR. PER FIVE TWENTY NINE
ACCOUNT. OKAY SO WHAT IS TO
PREVENT SOMEONE WHO- HAD THE
DISHONEST MOTIVE OF TRYING TO
SHIELD ASSETS FROM THE
BANKRUPTCY PROCESS WHAT IS TO
PREVENT THEM FROM. BUT IN MANY
FIVE TWENTY NINE ACCOUNTS
BECAUSE THERE'S NO LIMITATION
ON WHO YOU CAN OPEN ACCOUNT FOR
YOU CAN DO IT FRIENDS NEIGHBORS
THE GUY DOWN THE STREET AS LONG
AS YOU'VE GOT THEIR INFORMATION
YOU CAN OPEN A FIVE TWENTY NINE
ACCOUNT FOR THEM. SO WHY
COULDN'T A BORROWER JUST OPEN
MANY FIVE TWENTY NINE ACCOUNT
TO PUT FIFTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
AND EACH ONE. BOTH THROUGH
THEIR- FIRST YOU'RE A
RETIREMENT ACCOUNTS THAT YOU
HAVE A FOUR OH ONE K. OR- OF.
THE RETIREMENT. SO FOR ALL
THROUGH YOUR- THERE'S AND THEN.
AMOUNT OF. OF MONEY THAT YOU
CAN PUT IN THEIR TAX EXEMPT
WITHOUT. WITHOUT LOOK IT JUST
HAS TO BE A REASONABLE. AMOUNT
FOR YOUR LIFE'S RETIREMENT. THE
SECOND- MEASURES THAT WE HAVE
THE- WILL RULE AGAINST
FRAUDULENT CONVEYANCES ANY
BANKRUPTCY COURT. TRUSTEE IS
ABLE TO GO BACK FOR YEARS. AND
FRAUDULENT CONVEYANCES THAT
WOULD BE MADE BY SOMEBODY SO.
EITHER THE- FACT THAT YOU'VE
GIVEN US IT LOOKS AS THOUGH
THAT THERE'S A SCHEME TO.
DEFRAUD YOUR CREDITORS AND THAT
THOSE TOOLS ARE ALREADY
AVAILABLE TO- THE BANKRUPTCY
TRUSTEES IN THE ESTATE. IF THEY
WERE GOING ON SO I WOULD
IMAGINE THAT. A CHAPTER SEVEN
TRUSTEE AND WOULD LOVE TO GOAL.
AFTER SOMEBODY THAT PROJECT WE
DID THAT. IN AGAIN MEMBER
THESE. POST BE SPENT. AS A-
TRUSTEE THE- TREASURES OFFICES
JUST LIKE THREE HUNDRED THIRTY
NINE THOUSAND THE COUNCIL THAT.
TEN THOUSAND BUCKS IN OF RIGHT
NOW. SORT OF WHAT THE WORLD.
WHAT THE WORLD LOOKS LIKE WITH
THAT SO. I THINK THAT IN THE-
UNDER. TO SOMEBODY DID THAT.
THE TOOLS ARE AVAILABLE TO THE.
POWERS THAT THE TRUSTEES HAVE
RIGHT NOW. OKAY I MEAN I KNOW
WHY. IF WE AGREE THAT. ACTIONS
LIKE THE ONE I DESCRIBED WILL
BEFRAUDULENT THAT WE COULDN'T
JUST SAY THAT WHEN WE WHEN WE
PUT THIS IN THE STATUTE WELL
IT'S JUST IT'S JUST IT'S IT
MARKS UP THE EXEMPTIONS WE
NORMALLY JUST SAY THESE ARE THE
EXCEPTIONS THAT THE SECTIONS
UNDER THE BANKRUPTCY. CODE
ENTERED THE FIVE HUNDRED
SECTIONS GIVE ALL THESE POWERS
TO THE TRUSTEE TO DO THINGS AND
THOSE WITH THAT'S A THAT'S A
FEDERAL ENTITLED FEDERAL LAW
THAT THEY HAVE FOR POWERS THAT
THEY HAVE PLUS THE STATE
INTERPRETATION SO IT WOULD BE
IT'S JUST A DIFFERENT.
DIFFERENT SECTIONS THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT JUST GAVE STATES THE
RIGHTS IS JUST THE DEAL WITH
THE EXEMPTION MEASURE NOT THE-
DAD AFTER INTENT THAT'S A
DIFFERENT. CODE SECTION OKAY
WE'LL GIVE YOU ANOTHER EXAMPLE-
IN THE ANSWER MIGHT BE THE SAME
I'M THINKING. BUT THERE'S
NOTHING THAT PREVENTSSOMEONE
FROM CHANGING THE BENEFICIARY
OF A FIVE TWENTY NINE PLAN
AFTER IT'S BEEN ESTABLISHED SO.
IN THEORY A BAD ACTOR COULD
ESTABLISH MANY DIFFERENT FIVE
TWENTY NINE PLANS- DECLARE
BANKRUPTCY GO THROUGH THE
BANKRUPTCY PROCESS AND THEN
CONSOLIDATE THEM BACK INTO A
SINGLE BENEFICIARY. BUT WITH
WOULD THAT BE LEGAL THE
DEPARTMENT OF AVOIDING. I WOULD.
THREE CHAIR PERSONALLY I WOULD
SAY THAT IS STILL THERE ARE A
LOT ON THESE FIVE TWENTY NINE
THEY HAVE TO BE SPENT ON A- ON
THAT THE EDUCATION PLAN FIRST
FOR SOME FOR SOMEBODY- WE'RE AS
OTHER ASSETS LIKE A FOUR OH ONE
K. WOULD BE IS. TOTALLY ACCEPT
ME YOU HAVE TO YOU HAVE TO LOOK
AT YOUR LIFE EXPENSE EXPECTANCY
AT. SIXTY FIVE OR SEVENTY
WHENEVER YOU'RE RETIRED YOU CAN
HAVE SEVERAL MILLION DOLLARS IN
A FOUR OH ONE K. THAT WOULD BE
PROTECTED BY THE BANKRUPTCY
CODE RIGHT NOW SO I DON'T KNOW
WHY SOMEBODY WOULD SAY LET'S.
LET'S JONES THE FIVE TWENTY
NINE PLANS IT IN IT THAT HAVE
LIMITATIONS ON HOW I CAN PULL
UP THE MONEY IF. IF THE GOAL
WAS TO FRAUDULENT LEE PROTECT
ASSETS. AGAINST CREDITORS IN
AGAINST THE STATE OKAY WELL
WHEN ONE FINAL QUESTION ON ON A
DIFFERENT TOPIC. BUT WHY DID
YOU ONLY EXEMPTS FIVE TWENTY
NINE PLANS THAT WERE OPEN
THROUGH SCHOLARSHIP. I KNOW
MANY CALIFORNIANS HOLD FIVE
TWENTY ON PLANS THAT ARE OPEN
UNDER THE LAWS OF OTHER STATES.
BECAUSE THERE'S NO FOR.
ADVANTAGE TO USING SCHOLAR
SHARE SO WHY WOULD YOU NOT JUST
MAKE A GENERIC GENERICALLY
APPLY TO ALL FIVE TWENTY NINE
PLANTS. DO CHAIR. BUT WE HAVE
CONTROL OVER THOSE- THOSE
ACCOUNTS OF P. PEOPLE ARE FREE
TO BUY THOSE OTHER ACCOUNTS
THIS IS THE ONE ACCOUNT THAT
CALIFORNIA CONTROL SAID THAT
THE- TREASURE RUNS AND QUITE
FRANKLY WE WANT TO ENCOURAGE
PEOPLE TO USE THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM I MEAN IT'S
THERE'S I WOULD IMAGINE THAT
PEOPLE WOULD SAY OH THIS IS
PROTECTED FROM LIQUIDATION IN
THE BANKRUPTCY VERSUS THE
INDIANA ACCOUNT FOR THE I GUESS
THE ILLINOIS ACCOUNT WOULD BE
IN THE SAME SAME AMOUNT SO.
WE'RE WE'RE CHOOSING THE ONE
THAT WE HAVE CONTROL OVER AT
LEAST TREASURE HAS CONTROL OF
TO- TO GIVE THIS EXEMPTION OF.
MY FOLLOW YOUR YOUR THOUGHT
YOU'RE SAYING WHY WOULD YOU
JUST ACCEPT EVERY. EVERY FIVE
TWENTY NINE- CULTURE PROGRAM
AND AGAIN THE OF THE IDEAS THAT
WE DON'T CONTROL THAT WE'D BE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT
RETIREMENT FROM SERVICE WORK
pSTATE BANKRUPTCY LAW SO I MEAN
IF WE CHOSE TO. EXEMPT ASSETS
IN ALL THE FIVE TWENTY NINE
PLANS TO REGARDLESS OF WHERE
THEY WERE CHARTERED WE COULD
YEAH BUT- I MEAN AS YOU SAY.
MAYBE WE WANT TO AND
INCENTIVIZE PEOPLE TO OPEN THEM
pHELP ALL THE PARENTS THEY
ALREADY HAD FIVE TWENTY NINE
PLANS OF RICHARD ELSEWHERE. SO
I MEAN I GUESS I RECOGNIZE IT
WILL TAKE THE COMMITTEES TIME
OUT IT'S HI I'M SUPPORTIVE OF
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO A
LITTLE TROUBLED BY THE PATH
THAT YOU'VE TAKEN. THE I WISH
THAT THE TWO THOUSAND DOLLAR
LIMITATION- PER YEAR JUST FOR
THE LAST TWO YEARS COULD HAVE
BEEN IN TOTAL. NOT A PER
ACCOUNT BECAUSE I THINK THAT
WOULD. PEOPLE WHO ARE TRYING TO
GAME THE SYSTEM AND I WISH THAT
YOU EXIT ALL FIVE ONE PLANTS
NOT JUST FOR SURE. ONCE THANK
YOU MISTER. TO CHAIR ITS- IT'S
ALWAYS GOOD. FOR ME HERE IN.
FOR ME TAKES. MY LAW. UP PRINT
NORMALLY I. ASKED TO KIND. BUT
THIS IS SOMETHING ELSE I'M NOT.
PREPARED TO DO THAT WITH THIS
BILL RIGHT NOW BUT I WILL AND-
I'M SURE I'LL BE COMING BACK
WITH SOME OTHER EXEMPTION- OF
PROGRAMS AND- IDEAS AND I'LL-
KEEP THAT IN MIND IT WOULD BE
UNUSUAL HERE IF YOU DID. WITH
THAT. OTHER QUESTIONS COME. ALL
RIGHT SEEING NONE SENATOR YOU
MAY CLOSE HIGHER CHEN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. SO I AM LOOKING FOR-
A MOTION AND A SECOND. THE
MOTION AND A SECOND THANK YOU
THAT MOTION IS TO PASS KALRA
PLEASE. THIS RELEASE WOULD YOU
SANDRA PLEASE. STONE HI STONE
AYE GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER AYE
CHAU CHIU. GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE KALRA KILEY
KILEY AYE LIMóN OBERNOLTE FIVE
OBERNOLTE I REYES. RESIGNED.
THAT HAS SEVEN VOTES RIGHT THE
BILL IS OUT THANK YOU MR THANK
YOU. OUR FINAL ITEM SENATE BILL
FIVE NINETY TWO BY CENTER
WIENER IS SUPPOSED TO BE
PRESENTED BY MISTER KALRA WHO
IS IN SENATE NATURAL RESOURCES
PRESENTING A BILL. SO WE'RE A
LITTLE BIT STUCK UNTIL MISTER
KALRA CAN GET TO US SO WHEN WE
RUN THROUGH. THE LIST OF BILLS
AND WE HAVE SEVERAL BILLS THAT
ARE ON CALL AND OTHERS SO THAT
IN CASE PEOPLE HAVE NOT HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE NOW IS YOUR
TIME TO VOTE. SO ITEM NUMBER
ONE SENATE BILL ONE ONE FIVE
SEVEN FIVE BRADFORD IS OUT BUT
IF THERE ARE MEMBERS HERE WHO
HAD NOT VOTED CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. HOLD ON TO ME HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE LIMóN. RIGHT THANK
YOU ITEM NUMBER TWO IS SB
FOURTEEN TENET IS ON CALL I'M
GOING TO LIFT THE CALL. COOLEY
OF SOME MEMBERS CHAO. GONZALEZ
HOLDEN HOLDEN I. KALRA J. THAT
STILL NEEDS ONE MORE VOTE I'M
GOING TO REPLACE THE CALL HAS
ITEM NUMBER THREE SB ELEVEN
NINETY TWO HOURS AGO I'M GOING
TO LIFT THE CALL. GONZALEZ
HOLDEN ALL RIGHT HOLDEN I KALRA.
CHAU. I THANK YOU THAT STILL
NEEDS ONE MORE VOTES FROM GOING
TO REPLACE THE CALL ITEM NUMBER
FORCE SB TEN SEVENTY NINE
SKINNER THE BILL'S ON COLUMN
AND LIFT THE CALL. GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NOT VOTING. CHAU. TO
HOLDEN- HOLDEN I KALRA REYES.
CHRIS I. THE BILL STATED STILL
NEEDS ONE MORE VOTE I'M GOING
TO REPLACE THE CALL. I REMEMBER
FIVE S. B. ELEVEN FORTY SIX
UMBERG IS OUT BUT CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. CHAU TU. HOLDEN
HOLDEN I KALRA REYES REYES I.
THAT HAS EIGHT THAT OKAY THANK
YOU SEVEN SB ELEVEN S. B. EIGHT
NINETY EIGHT WE JUST DID I
THINK WITH THIS THESE PARTIES
NOW THE CONSENT AGENDA CONSENT
AGENDA IS OUT THE COLLAPSE OF
MEMBERS IN CASE ANYONE HERE
HADN'T HAD A CHANCE TO VOTE.
CHAU GONZALEZ. HOLDEN HOLDEN I.
CALL. GONZALEZ FOR THE CONSENT
AGENDA. GONZALEZ I'M OKAY THANK
YOU. I UNDERSTAND MISTER KALRA
HAS PASSED. SO WITH CENTER
WINNER ASKING KALRA TO COVER
AND HIDE HERE ASKING WAS REYES
TO PRESENT SB FIVE NINETY TWO
SO WE WILL ALLOW THAT SO WE'LL
MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER SEVEN. IF
YOU ARE WANTING TO TESTIFY AND
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SB FIVE
NINETY TWO AND YOUR ON THE
LINES WERE WATCHING THIS THIS
IS THE TIME TO CALL IN. SO WE
WILL START WITH THE AUTHOR'S
STATEMENT MISERIES THANK YOU
FOR TAKING THIS UP FOR US YOU
MAY BEGIN. THANK YOU ON BEHALF
OF SENATOR WIENER. WITH THE
RECENT POLICE KILLINGS OF
GEORGE FLOORED AND BRIANNA
TAYLOR THE HORRIFIC COBIT
NINETEEN. OUTBREAK AT CENTER
SAN QUENTIN AND THE NATIONAL
CONVERSATION ABOUT RACISM IN
OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM. SB
FIVE NINE TWO IS MORE RELEVANT
THAN EVER. WE NEED TO REMAKE
OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
FROM THE GROUND UP. FROM
POLICING TO OUR COURTS AND THE
SYSTEM OF MASS INCARCERATIONS.
SB FIVE NINE TWO IS ONE
IMPORTANT PIECE OF TIS PUZZLE.
SB FIVE NINE TWO BY SENATORS
CENTER WIENER EXPANSES SOURCES
A PROSPECTIVE JURORS TO INCLUDE
STATE TAX FILERS TO CREATE A
MORE INCLUSIVE AND DIVERSE JURY
POOL. OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM CAN ONLY FUNCTION
PROPERLY WHEN IT UPHOLDS THE
BASIC RIGHT THE DEFENDANTS MUST
BE TRIED BY A JURY OF THEIR
PEERS. WE HAVE A CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHT TO A JURY THAT IS A TRUE
REPRESENTATION OF OUR DIVERSE
CITY. BUT MAY FALL SHORT
BECAUSE JURY POOLS GENERATED BY
DMV RECORDS AND REGISTRAR OF
VOTERS IS MORE AFFLUENT AND
LESS DIVERSE THAN CALIFORNIA'S
DEMOGRAPHICS. THE JUSTIFICATION
FOR USING THESE TWO LISTS IS
NOT BASED ON EMPIRICAL EVIDENCE
AND STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THEY
EXCLUDE LARGE SWATHS OF OUR
POPULATION MAINLY RACIAL
MINORITIES. NOT ONLY DOES THIS
EXCLUSION RESULT IN RACIAL IN
CALIFORNIA'S JURY POOLS. IT
ALSO DEPRIVES CALIFORNIA COURTS
OF THOUSANDS OF PROSPECTIVE
JURORS. MIKE SPENT EXPANDING
THE REQUIRED SOURCES OF
PROSPECTIVE JURORS TO INCLUDE
THE LIST OF STATE TAX FILERS SB
FIVE NINE TWO WILL ALLOW JURIES
TO BE MORE INCLUSIVE AND
DIVERSE. WELL JURIES ARE THE
BACKBONE OF OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM
THEY CAN ONLY SPEAK WITH THE
VOICE OF IT AND THE FORTY OF
THE COMMUNITY IF THEY TRULY AND
ACCURATELY REFLECT THAT
COMMUNITY. SB FIVE NINE TWO IS
OVERDUE AT THE COMMONSENSE
REFORM THAT ADVANCES FAIRNESS
DIVERSITY AND LEGITIMACY IN
CALIFORNIA'S CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM. THANK YOU THANK YOU MR
S. WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
WITNESSES THANK YOU THERE'S A
MOTION IS THEIR SECOND AND A
SECOND THANK YOU. I HAVE ONE
WITNESS IN SUPPORT OSCAR PO
BROWN FROM THE SOLANO COUNTY
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE ARE
YOU ON THE LINE. CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES WE CAN HEAR YOU I AM CAN
YOU HEAR ME. OKAY GOOD POLICE
RECEIVED UP GOOD AFTERNOON.
OKAY GO. GOOD AFTERNOON I AM
OSCAR BARBARO I AM A BOARD
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION AND CHIEF
DEPUTY PUBLIC DEFENDER IN
SOLANO COUNTY CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION PROUDLY
SUPPORTS AND SPONSORS SB FIVE
NINETY TWO AND APPLAUD SENATOR
WIENER FOR BRINGING THIS
IMPORTANT AND TIMELY
LEGISLATION TO ADDRESS AN
INHERENT AND SYSTEMATIC
IMBALANCE OF THE RACIAL MAKEUP
OF OUR STATE'S JURY POOL. BY
ADDING THE LIST OF STATE TAX
FILERS TO THOSE WHO ARE
SUMMONED TO JURY SERVICE OUR
STATE CHALLENGED THIRTY THREE
OTHER STATES IN THIS NATION
THAT USE A DUPLICITY IN
ADDITION TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
MOTOR VEHICLES AND VOTER
REGISTRATION. ASSEMBLY JURORS
AND FOURTEEN OTHER STATES THAT
SPECIFICALLY USED STATE TAX
RULES AS ONE OF THE LISTA SOME
INJURES. FOR THE LAST DECADES
WITNESSED CALIFORNIA CRIMINAL
TO IS JUST. PROSECUTED OUR
COURTS MEMBERS OF OUR BLACK AND
LATINO. POPULATIONS OF OUR
STATE RELATIVE TO THEIR NUMBERS
IN THE POPULATION. HOWEVER WHAT
IS NOT THE ADDRESS IN OUR
SYSTEM IS THAT WE ARE SELECTING
JURORS TO DECIDE THE FATE OF
OUR CLIENTS. OF CRIMINAL
BEHAVIOR THE REVERSE SCENARIO
EXISTS. THERE ARE
DISPROPORTIONATE NUMBER OF
CAUCASIAN CITIZENS THAT APPEAR
IN CHIU TERRY PULLS RELATIVE TO
THEIR NUMBERS IN THE
COMMUNITIES WHERE THE CASES ARE
PROSECUTED AND THE SIGNIFICANT
UNDER REPRESENTATION. OF BLACK
AND LATINO CITIZENS IN THESE
POOLS. RIGHT DECADES OF THIS
PHENOMENON BEING THIS THAT LIST
CHALLENGE IN OUR TRIAL
APPELLATE COURTS THE SITUATION
REMAINS THE SAME. DUE TO THE
SYSTEMATIC EXCLUSION OF
MINORITY POPULATIONS THAT
RESERVE HOLD FROM USING ONLY
THOSE TWO LISTS. BECAUSE COURTS
HAVE BEEN HELD THAT THESE LIST
OF THEMSELVES ARE QUOTE.
NEUTRAL HOWEVER THE REALITY IS
THAT THE IMPACT OF USING THESE
LIST TO ANYTHING BUT- THE ON
THE IMPACT. TOOLS IN THERE IS
THE UNDER. OF MINORITY
POPULATIONS. IN OUR JURY POOLS
IS. IN LIGHT OF THE DEAD JUST
IMPACT OF THE KORAN VIRUSES HAS
HAD ON MINORITY IN THIS. THIS
BUDGET WILL HER HELP CORRECT
GOING FORWARD TO RACE IN BATTLE
OF OUR TO RIPPLES BY ALLOW
KERRY COME TO SOMEONE FROM ACT
LIST OF STATE TAX FILERS
SUPPORTER DONE YEARLY AND
CONTRASTS WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF MOTOR VEHICLES- AND- WISHARD
DONE EVERY FIVE YEARS AND
VOLUNTARY VOTER REGISTRATION
WHICH IS NOT REQUIRED TO BRING
RENEWED AT ALL. GIVEN THAT
MINORITY RESIDENTS WHO ARE
TENDING TO BE MORE TRANSITORY
IN THEIR LIVING PATTERNS AS
MANY AS YOUR PRIOR HEARINGS.
TODAY HAVE ESTABLISHED. THE
CAUSE OF A THE COST TO JERK. IN
MAILING. IS HOUSEHOLDS WHILE
PEOPLE ARE KNOWN LONGER
RESIDING ARE SUBSTANTIAL THE
USE OF STATE TAX FILERS IN
PROVIDING MORE ACCURATE LIST
WILL. CAUSE THE JURY
COMMISSIONERS COSTS TO BE
REDUCED DRAMATICALLY AND THAT
HAS BEEN PROVEN BY STUDIES IN
THE STATE IN NEW YORK IN THE
FEDERAL COURT SYSTEM. AND THE
AMERICAN BAR ASSOCIATION AND
THE COUNCIL OF THE NATIONAL
COUNCIL STATE COURT SUPPORT.
ADDING STATE TAX FILERS AS A
WAY TO BROADEN THE BASE OF
JURORS TO PROVIDE A MORE
REPRESENTATIVE. SAMPLE THE TWO
IN THIS LED WILL HELP
CORRECTIVE PROSPERITY AND THE
DEPRIVATION OF JUSTICE THAT
RESULTS FROM THE CURRENT SYSTEM
BY INCLUDING MORE CALIFORNIA'S
CITIZENS IN THE JURY PROCESS
AND PRE LIFE IN THE CLASS.
PROTECT OF BEING TRIED BY A
JURY OF ONE'S PEERS ONCE PEERS
FROM A REPRESENTATIVE CROSS
SECTION OF THE COMMUNITY.
FINALLY MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THERE'S BEEN SOME CONCERN
EXPRESSED BY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THAT PIECE OF TAPE
STATE TAX FILERS MAY RESULT IN
MORE NONCITIZENS BEING SUMMONED
FOR SERVICE. HOWEVER AS
EVERYONE SHOULD KNOW EVERY
CALIFORNIA JURY SUMMONS STATES
THAT IF YOU WERE SUMMONED AND
YOU ARE NOT A U. S. CITIZEN
YOU'RE DISQUALIFIED FROM JURY
SERVICE AND YOU CAN NOTIFY THE
JURY COMMISSIONER OF THAT
WITHOUT EVEN HAVING TO GO TO
THE COURTHOUSE. AND THERE'S
ALSO NO CITIZENSHIP REQUIREMENT
TO OBTAIN A DRIVER'S LICENSE OR
IDENTIFICATION CARD AND THOSE
ARE THE LISTS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY. USED SOME INSURERS.
SO YOU KNOW SOMEONE WHO'S TRIED
OVER TWO HUNDRED TRIALS IN THE
STATE I CANNOT EXPRESS TO YOU
HOW DISHEARTENING IT IS TO TURN
TO A CLIENT WHO YOU ARE
OBLIGATED TO HELP INSURE. GETS
A FAIR TRIAL AND WHO IS
ENTITLED TO HAVE A JURY OF
ONE'S PEERS PROTECTED. AND THEN
TO WATCH THE PANEL SUMMONED OF
JUROR PANEL THAT'S SUMMONED. TO
TRY THE CASE COME INTO A
COURTROOM AND ALMOST NONE OF
THOSE PEOPLE ARE THE SAME RACES
AS I. CALIFORNIA CODE.
ASSOCIATION URGES. FOR THIS
LONG OVERDUE CHANGE TORTURE
SYSTEM. IN ORDER TO MAKE OUR TO
PANEL MORE. OF OUR POPULATION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I DO NOT
HAVE ANY OTHER SUPPORT.
WITNESSES LISTED SO WE WILL NOW
SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO GIVE US THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION. AND THAT THEY
SUPPORT THIS BILL IN THE
WITNESS VIDEO ROOM. SEEING NONE
THE REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION.
SEEING NONE IN THE HEARING ROOM
ITSELF. SEEING NONE SO OPERATOR
YOU CAN OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES
FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO.
GIVE US THEIR NAME AFFILIATION
AND SUPPORT FOR SB FIVE NINETY
TWO. TO SHOW YOUR SUPPORT FOR
SB FIVE NINETY TWO PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY THE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND OUR FIRST PERSON
IS LINE ONE TWENTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YEAH GOOD AFTERNOON
THAT THEY HAVE A DIMARTINO ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS ENOUGH
TO BE STRONG SUPPORT. SIX WITH
A LIME ONE TWENTY FIVE. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS JIM WEINBERG
ON BEHALF OF THE FRIENDS
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SB FIVE NINETY TWO THANK YOU.
ONE OF FOR YOUR NOW OPEN. ONE
ZERO FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE
NUTCRACKER WITH THE CONSUMER OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE COURT THANK
YOU. AND THE FINAL REMINDER
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
THE BY ZERO TO SHOW YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL. AND WE
DO HAVE ONE QUEUING UP ONE
MOMENT.
MY TWENTY FIVE YOUR YOU
ARE OPEN. DANIEL B. TERRACE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
IN SUPPORT. MISTER CHAIR THERE
ARE NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS
QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME. RIGHT
THANK YOU I DO NOT HAVE ANY
FORMAL OPPOSITION LISTED FOR
TESTIMONY. BUT IS THERE ANYONE
IN THE HEARING ROOM WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
SENATE BILL FIVE NINETY TWO.
SEEING NONE ANYONE IN THE
WITNESS VIDEO ROOM. SEEING NONE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION.
SEEING NONE OPERATOR OPEN
APPLIANCE FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO. OFFER OPPOSITION THEIR
NAME AFFILIATION AND THAT
THEY'RE OPPOSED TO SB FIVE
NINETY TWO. TO SHOW OPPOSITION
TO SB FIVE NINETY TWO PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME. YET TO SHOW
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. MR CHERNOBYL
IS QUEUING UP RIGHT THANK YOU
THANK YOU OPERATOR FOR YOUR
SERVICE TODAY AND FOR HELPING
US OUT- YOU CAN NOW CLOSE THE
LINES ON SB FIVE NINETY TWO AND
I WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE. THIS RACE TO MAKE
CLOTHES. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR RIVALS THANK YOU. SO WE DO
HAVE A MOTION AND SECOND THAT
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE. STONE HI STONE II
GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER NOT VOTING.
CHAU CHOW I CHU CHU AYE
GONZALEZ. HOLDEN HOLDEN I.
KALRA KILEY. KILEY NOT VOTING
LEVINE LIMON II OBERNOLTE
OBERNOLTE NOT VOTING RHYS FIVE
RESIDE. IT HAS SIX VOTES SO THE
BILL IS OUT THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
WE'VE GOT SOME MEMBERS FACT
LET'S ROLL THROUGH THE AGENDA
ONE MORE TIME AND CATCH MEMBERS
WHO MAY NOT HAVE HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE ON THE BILL
SO WE'LL START WITH THE CONSENT
AGENDA. CHECK SHALL I.
K. ITEM
NUMBER TWO IS ON CALL I'M GOING
TO LIFT THE CALL THIS IS SB
FOURTEEN TEN CAREER AND
BRADFORD. CHAU SHALL I GONZALEZ
KALRA. THAT SIX CORRECT YES ALL
RIGHT THE BILL IS OUT I
REMEMBER THREE S. B. ELEVEN
NINETY TWO RAZA WHO IS ON CALL
I'M GOING TO LIST THE CALL.
MAKE SURE THAT THIS IS ALL HEAD
OVER TO THEFOOD ON OF SO ITEM
NUMBER ONE SB ELEVEN FIFTY
SEVEN. YES WE HAVE A BETTER
OKAY ITEM NUMBER TWO SB
FOURTEEN TED GONZALEZ THAT'S A
COPYRIGHT IS THE COVER YOUR
BRADFORD BILL. OKAY IT'S OUT.
OF THE LAWS NOT BURNING. I
REMEMBER THREE ELEVEN SB ELEVEN
NINETY DORADO. GONZALEZ I
REMEMBER FOR SB TEN SEVENTY
NINE SKINNER. WE HAVE YOUR VOTE
OKAY I'VE NEVER FIVE SB ELEVEN
FORTY SIX NUMBER. WE HAVE YOUR
VOTE OKAY I REMEMBER SIX SB
EIGHT NINETY EIGHT WHITE HOUSE
SKI- WE HAVE CONSOLES I K. ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN SB FIVE NINETY TWO
WIENER. GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
OKAY AND DID YOU GET A CHANCE
TO GO TO CONSENT YES. OKAY IT
THANK YOU I THINK WE'RE MISSING
MISTER KALRA SO ONCE HE GETS
OUT OF. SENATE NATURAL
RESOURCES WE WILL TAKE HIM UP.
BOB THAT'S SO WE WILL BE A FEW
MORE MINUTES WILL GIVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO GET HERE. THE.
ALL RIGHT THIS CALL RIGHT THANK
YOU NO NO I KNOW YOU HAD A
TOUGH BILL ANOTHER COMMITTEE
YEAH AND WE HAD MISSED REYES
PRESENTED FOR YOU SO
EVERYTHING'S COOL I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE GO TO VOTE ON
EVERYTHING SO LET'S RUN THROUGH
THE AGENDA- FIRST OF ALL
BECAUSE I'M NOT SURE WHAT YOU
WERE ABLE TO VOTE ON OR NOT BUT
WE'LL START WITH CONSENT. OKAY
SO LET'S START WITH CONSENT.
KALRA RIGHT KALRA HI THANK YOU
AND EVERY BILL IS OUT SO YOU
JUST ADDING ON SO ITEM NUMBER
ONE ELEVEN IT SB ELEVEN FIFTY
SEVEN BRADFORD I THINK WE HAVE
YOU ON YEAH CORRECT OKAY ITEM
NUMBER TWO SB FOURTEEN TEN
COPYRIGHT BRADFORD. WHAT KALRA.
KALRA HI I'VE NEVER THREE S. B.
ELEVEN NINETY DORADO KALRA.
KALRA HI ITEM NUMBER FOR SB TEN
SEVENTY NINE SKINNER. KALRA I
KALRA HI I REMEMBER FIVE SB
ELEVEN FORTY SIX UMBERG KALRA
THE KALRA HI I'VE NEVER SIX SB
EIGHT NINETY EIGHT BY CASKEY
KALRA. KALRA HI AND THEN ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN SB FIVE NINETY TWO
WIENER KALRA KALRA HI. THINK
EVERYONE GOOD NO NO WORRIES
THANK YOU MISTER KALRA THANK
YOU STAFF AGAIN AND EVERYBODY
THIS IS CONCLUDES OUR BUSINESS
AND WE ARE ADJOURNMENTS.